[Musique]
wesh bonjour bonjour les gens bonjour Le
Chat comment tu vas bienvenue c'est le
c'est le faux départ de backseat il est
18h30 l'émission commence à 19h et comme
tous les jeudis elle commence pas fait à
19h on va prendre un peu plus de temps
vous allez enfin vous allez on va
prendre plus temps justement ça va oh la
fatigue du mec à 18h45 on va démarrer
l'émission avec une première séquence on
va recevoir deux youtubeus absolument
géniales que je vous présenterai mais
vous les connaissez sûrement c'est Lena
de la chaîne chaîne scarabette et
Valentine de la chaîne science de
comptoir euh si vous connaissez pas
encore vous allez voir ça va partir en
abonnement YouTube très rapidement chez
vous hein ça je vous le dis euh voilà
mais en tout cas content de vous
retrouver ça fait plaisir de vous voir
les amis bienvenue Bienvenue on continue
à faire les réglages caméra tout ça tout
ça on est on va être prêt vous inquiétez
pas
ah le t-shirt Bernie ouais merci pour
l'orette merci beaucoup euh le t-shirt
Bernie oui le t-shirt Bernie que que
Claire claire caché la streameuse m'a
m'a rapporté de Californie c'est un
officiel
où est le public le public va arriver
tiens il est en train d'arriver le
public
tranquillement vous inquiétez pas nous
sommes des professionnels du streaming
toute façon c'est à c'est comme à la
télé tout est truqué et et ça va bien se
passer donc ouais non bienvenue à vous
he bienvenue les amis installez-vous
confortablement vous avez le temps
d'aller vous servir une bière ou tout
autre boisson non alcoolisé tant que
vous voulez il y a aucun problème
mettez-vous bien et voilà le public
s'insta le public pose son manteau tout
ça tout va bien se passer
et profite des bières en plus
oui qu'est-ce que je voulais dire euh
oui attendez il s'est passé un truc trop
marrant pas marrant du tout mais je vais
vous raconter euh on va refaire le jeu
du chapeau vous savez comme la semaine
dernière le truc où on doit découvrir
son personnage le jeu dans lequel je
joue moi aussi et donc le principe c'est
que bah sur le plateau avec mes
chroniqueerss ce soir d'ailleurs les
chroniqueerss c'est Malek Antoine et et
Léa et du coup les chroniqueerss et moi
on a des on a des petits papiers que
j'ai là qu'on m'apporte et les papiers
sont nominatifs où il y a les
personnages des trois autres joueurs
mais pas le sien parce que le but c'est
découvrir le sien et du coup on
m'apporte les papiers de tout à l'heure
genre une demiheure avant le début de
l'émission moi je fais ah cool j'ouvre
le premier papier bah je vois mon
personnage et du coup je suis un connard
du coup j'ai dit ah je suis désolé j'ai
vu mon personnage et tout du coup voilà
j'ai généré une panique donc merci à
François et à pempf qui dans la panique
la plus générale ont changé mon
personnage en dernière
minute voilà je referai pas je referai
pas mais j'ai pas l'habitude moi ah bah
bravo ouais non mais voilà voilà voilà
voilà euh
non mais on est des professionnels he
c'était qui je vous dirai après je vous
diraiis je vous dis non mais vous verrez
abonnez-vous vous le saurez pardon
j'aime beaucoup ce nouveau jeu et son
emplacement hororaire dans l'émission
c'est vraiment cool moi aussi c'est pour
ça qu'on le refait mais je vous avais
promis que on discuterait vous et moi on
va prendre le temps de discuter de
nouveaux jeux dans back seit cette année
on va essayer d'essayer d'A on va
essayer d'essayer ouais ouais ouais on
va essayer d'autres trucs le jeu du
chapeau moi je taime bien je trouve ça
sympa c'est luique c'est rigolo le cou à
la con on pourra le refaire on a envie
maintenant qu'on sait que ça marche mais
euh mais si vous êtes chaud le chat
faudra qu'on ait un petit brainstorming
pour discuter ensemble
de bah des jeux quoi de de de ce qu'on
peut imaginer comme jeux dans
l'émission donc voilà
euh puisque j'en suis alors point
information les premières vidéos de Paul
and shield vont être publiées ce soir
euh c'est PEMF qui m'a dit ça il
m'aenvoyé un message PEMF tu confirmes
dans le chat c'est bon ce sera mis en
ligne ce soir Paul and shield c'était
mon festival que j'ai organisé samedi
dernier euh plusieurs heures de de
stream du coup sur lesqueles on a fait
des tables rondes passionnantes sur des
sujets politiques tout ça je confirme
dans le chat voilà PMF confirme donc ça
va arriver ce soir sur une chaîne
Youtube spéciale Paul and shield qu'on a
créé spécialement pour les pour
l'événement et euh voilà quoi chez moi
on l'appelle le jeu du postitte oui oui
oui le jeu du postit
oui oui ça existe aussi jeu du chapeau
jeu du postit jeu du personnage appelez
ça comme vous voulez euh tu te fais
autoconcurrence tu conseilles de
regarder quoi du coup non mais regardz
backsit quand même quand même quand même
bon donc du coup le public ça va le
publicou
ouais bienvenue ça fait plaisir de vous
accueillir soyez les bienvenus bon vous
connaissez on n pas encore vraiment
commencé l'émission donc voilà j'ai le
temps de vous accueillir en bonne et du
forme euh merci d'être là merci pour
votre participation au financement de
l'émission c'est grâce à vous qu'on la
fait cette émission et euh voilà quiez
bien l'émission profitez bien euh il y
aura une pause au milieu vous inquiétez
pas et hésitez pas à balancer les
applaudissements quand il y a des
passages de séquence après les
génériques les jingles ce genre de truc
et et ben sinon non voilà qui fait bien
l'émission quoi ça va être cool
euh donc voilà et vous le chat ça va
vous êtes des S et des Bros
absolument un invité politique et vous
lui donnez lui-même comme personnage en
vrai ce serait drôle mais non on a dit
non on a dit que cette année on a
arrêtait de faire le le jeu avec
l'invité politique on l'a fait l'année
dernière c'était marrant mais avec les
chroniqueur on se dit qu'en vrai c'est
pas absolument nécessaire de faire un
jeu avec un invité politique on peut le
faire entre nous euh c'est chill et
cetera euh et toi comment ça va moi ça
va moi ça va très bien moi je me repose
en ce moment je vous ai dit mon mois de
septembre a été infernal donc là le mois
d'octobre ça va onvo y les molo mais on
reprend les QG il y a back seit et le
reste du temps je fais parfois quelques
streams mais
tranquille
h et d'ailleurs demain demain je serai
au Zénit de Paris ah oui alors pour ceux
qui savent pas demain je serai ouais je
fais le Zénit ouais non pas du tout en
fait je suis invité par une association
étudiante qui s'appelle copain qui est
une association qui fait de la
solidarité étudiante et de l'aide
alimentaire et ils font un un concert de
bah de charité pour pour attirer
l'attention et mobilisé sur la
solidarité étudiante et l'aide
alimentaire et ils ont entre les
concerts ils ont invité des
personnalités à venir parler au public
donc il y aura Salomé saké il y aura moi
j'en suis très heureux il y aura plein
d'associatifs qui vont venir parler et
tout donc c'est a un petit mou de un
petit MS d'action si vous voulez venir
aux éudes de Paris demain profitez du
concert il y aura sosom maness il y aura
plein de il y aura plein d'artistes
incroyable hésitez pas à aller checker
ça s'appelle le copain festival cop1 le
chiffre 1 le copain festival demain aux
éiles de Paris venez ça va être une
super soirée en
vrai donc donc voilà quoi
euh qu'est-ce que je peux vous dire
d'autre est-ce que vous avez des
questions comment tu détermines les
invités qui interviennent chaque semaine
les invités on les détermine le lundi en
général avec mes coproducteur on on se
met d'accord sur qui on a envie d'avoir
cette semaine et on fait en fonction de
l'actu ensuite on les invite on a plus
ou moins des du succès parfois c'est un
peu galère et ouais teste lumière ouais
ouais ça Mar joyeux
[Rires]
non vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
sérieuxire ah ou ça va très bien
[Musique]
ouais
merci
beaucoup c'était ah vous avez fait les
bougies qui se rallument ah la blague
elle est drôle ah on l'a fait chaque
année il y avait que ça au supermarché
mon
cul
TR ça marche pas vas-y reprends merci
c'était pas du tout prévu ils vous ont
prévenu là tout à l'heure d'accord ok
bah voilà et ben merci en vrai ça fait
super plaisir merci à vous 35 ans voilà
j'ai 35 ans
ouais si vous
voulez à 35 ans à 35 ans Alexandre leand
avait déjà conquis la Perse voilà moi il
avait 17 ans Alexandre le Grand je sais
pas pour ce sais pas si vous savez il
avait 17 ans bref quand il a le quand il
a commencé sa campagne euh ouais ouais
35 ans B merci hein merci pour le merci
pour le jeu anniversaire ça fait plaisir
je c'est c'est c'est très gentil ça me
touche beaucoup hop
h c'est du cidre c'est trop bien du
cidre pour mon anniversaire c'est trop
bien non non un discours non non un
discours bah c'est [__] qu'est-ce que
voulez que je vous offre de plus beau
que backed pour mon anniversaire quand
même on est entre nous
euh tu vas finir au Sénat je suis trop
vieux pour le Sénat la plus jeune
sénatrice élu elle a 29 ans elle a elle
a 29 ans elle s'appelle Mathilde elle
siège avec les écolos et la semaine
dernière on avait reçu Remy Cardon qui a
été élu à 26 ans et qui à 29 ans
aujourd'hui c'est un club de jeûe à le
Sénat de toute
façon est-ce que le petit chat a
souhaité ton anniversaire pas du tout tu
penses bien
euh tu fais encore partie des jeunes de
certains partis politiques oui oui oui
oui oui oui oui oui non ça c'est sûr
Fabien Guay avait 33 ans Fabien gay
avait 33 ans quand il a été élu sénateur
c'est vrai il est mort à 32 ans
Alexandre
lerand voilà
ouais ouais c c à 27 ça va ça va ça va
ça va ça on le
sait
euh du coup voilà on commence dans 4
minutes les amis l'émission qu'est-ce
que je voulais vous dire est-ce que vous
avez des questions on va faire un point
pognon vous voyez la barre de Don elle
est là n'hésitez pas à euh participerz
au financement de backseat allez-y
faites des dons rejoignez le club
backseat faites un don mensuel cette
année je vous l'ai dit la stratégie de
financement de back seat s'appuie sur
des sur un financement mensuel le but
c'est de vous inciter avec des
contreparties cool et tout à faire un
don mensuel ce qui nous permet d'assurer
la prévisibilité du financement de
l'émission et notre objectif c'est de
réunir la somme de 33000 € par mois euh
ce qui nous permettra d'assurer l'avenir
de bacsit avec le financement
complémentaire des partenaires et des
bforfor qui devrait va nous permettre si
on y arrive bah à faire backseit pour
plein d'autres saisons parce que c'est
ça quand on a un financement régulier
bah on s'offre ça donc 33000 c'est
l'objectif on en est à plus de 18000 €
merci à vous et quand on arrivera à
19000 € le prochain palier de dons vous
déclencherez du coup le bonus qui est
l'émission cuisine de Léa avec Benoît
amont où ils vont cuisiner un
kebab voilà c'est en vrai on a tous hâte
de voir ça donc abonnez-vous si c'est
pas déjà fait point d'exclamation qui k
dans le chat ou sinon si vous nous
regardez sur Youtube c'est dans les
liens sont dans la description KissKiss
Bank Bank il y a une page de financement
participatif hésitez pas à y aller et
par ailleurs je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez venir dans le public de Back
seats euh ils le savent pas encore mais
ils onont passer une super
soirée vous pouvez venir dans le public
de back seat on tourne à Paris dans le
20e arrondissement dans le quartier
Gambetta vous recevrez toutes les
informations par mail quand vous aurez
pris vos places vos places vous les
prenez sur le Wiz event vous avez aussi
le lien en description il est dans le
chat point d'exclamation place dans le
chat sinon et euh ça coûte 35 € pour
venir dans le public on a baissé le
tarif par rapport à l'année dernière et
en plus on a un tarif réduit à 20 €.
euh donc
voilà donc c'est cool euh j'aimerais
peut-être acheter des vêtements back
seed pour aider mais est-ce que tu peux
confirmer que c'est pas fabriqué en
Chine par des ougours non je ne peux pas
te le confirmer je peux pas te le
confirmer parce que le site sur lequel
pour l'instant on a un shop de back seat
s'appelle red bubble et c'est un site
qui propose un nombre incalculable de
produits qui sont pas du tout tous
fabriqués au même endroit c'est un
espèce d'intermédiaire entre plein
d'usine et tout donc en fonction du
t-shirt sur lequel tu cliques je sais
c'est pas où ils sont fabriqués et
cetera et je et je je suis d'accord avec
vous c'est pas ouf je peux pas maîtriser
red bubble et et comme je vous le disais
de toute façon le merchandising de
backseat c'est très cool ça permet
d'avoir des coques de téléphone
absolument magnifiqu acheter la coque
Nice cock tout
ça mais par contre ça rapporte que dal à
l'émission enfin on va dire la vérité
vous l'avez vu l'année dernière je vous
ai montré je crois que c'est 1 % je
crois de l'émission l'année dernière on
a fait avec le merchandising donc moi je
suis content si vous voulez vous offrir
un beau t-shirt un beau sweite une coque
de téléphone ça vous fait plaisir mais
ça rapporte que dal en fait à l'émission
en terme de tout l'argent va en fait
tout l'argent va dans la fabrication du
du t-shirt et dans l'envoi du t-shirt
qui arrive chez vous nous on touche que
dal donc c'est pas un modèle économique
viable pour l'émission mais on maintient
la boutique quand même si vous voulez
vous l'offrir voilà pas tonette oui mon
orureeillette pardon pardon pardon
pardon je mets mon oreillette pardon hop
hop hop hop
hop c'est comme les lunettes de soleil
Paul and chill elles sont top mais made
in China ah oui sans doute oui mais tu
as vu j'ai pris des modèles en bois
quand même tu me diras ça rachète rien
mais avec une vraie protection solaire
en plus parce que j'avais le choix là
aussi on pouvait prendre des lunettes
histoire de dire genre c'est des
lunettes de soirée étudiante machin on a
fait non non moi je veux protéger les
yeux des abonnés parce que sinon après
les yeux ils crament après ils peuvent
plus regarder les streams
donc donc
voilà hop c'est plus 49 € 30 centimes la
place dans le public non c'est plus 49 €
30 centimes ça c'était le tarif de
l'année dernière c'était un peu cher
pour vous tout ça tout ça c'est c'est
c'est notre soutien au pouvoir d'achat
Michel ARD Lecler si tu nous regardes
euh hop attendez je mets mon oreillette
je m'entends vas-y teste oreillette
Nico je t'entends très très
bien ok nickel l'oreillette fonctionne
ça c'est calé ça c'est fait hop les clés
le portefeuille ça dégage hop le cidre
va être bu
h donc
euh donc voilà et ta gualante de fleur
était mine taiiti non non non pas du
tout
est-ce qu'il y aura une rediffusion de
palenshill quelque part oui ça arrive
dès ce soir il y a une chaîne Youtube
spéciale Paul enhill qui a été créée le
but c'est que sur cette chaîne Youtube
il y a toutes les vidéos des futures
éditions de Paul andchill et cette
chaîne Youtube a été créée donc la
première vidéo arrive ce soir après
après backsit
voilà donc voilà chers amis il est
18h46es je vous propose qu'on é courte
ce petit blabla parce que c'est pas moi
la personne la plus intéressante de
cette émission il y a plein de gens qui
vont venir et je vous propose qu'on se
met un petit générique on se met dans
l'ambiance et c'est parti pour baxit
générique bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue sur baxit bonsoir bonsoir le
public bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
chers amis bienvenue dans cette émission
on va parler de politique bienvenue si
vous nous regardez sur twitch bonsoir le
chat vous êtes avec nous bonsoir bonjour
si vous nous regardez sur Youtube
bonjour bonsoir si vous nous écoutez en
podcast très content de vous retrouver
dans l'émission backseat
et cette semaine comme chaque semaine on
prévoit d'avoir sur le plateau des
invités de très grande qualité des
créateurs et des créatrices de contenu
sur Internet qui viennent nous parler
d'une cause qui leur tient à cœur et ce
soir j'ai l'immense plaisir d'accueillir
sur ce plateau Lena de la chaîne
scarabet bonjour et Valentine de la
chaîne science de comptoir et on a un
petit
[Applaudissements]
jingle et on a pas de petit jingle ça ça
va arriver merci d'être avec nous si tu
veux le jingle vas-y fais-le
jingle c'est incroyable AB incroyable
non non je me suis trompé excusez-moi la
régie il y a pas de jingle c'était pas
dans mon doc j'ai fait n'importe quoi
euh voilà voilà merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes toutes les deux donc vidéastes
sur Youtube vous êtes des créatrices de
contenu et vous êtes un petit peu
spécialisé dans les questions de science
si on peut dire toi Valentine tu es
spécialisé dans des sujet très variés
donc en fait tu as pas de spécialité
particulière c'est je suis en train de
me rendre compte de l'absurdité de ma
phrase spécialiste en tout tu fais du
dans tu dans le léchage de cailloux par
exemple on en parlera on y reviendra
ouais ouais ouais ouais tu parles aussi
du pillage des océans tu parles
d'astrologie ou ASIT vidé absolument
passionnantes merci d'être avec nous et
toi Lena tu es un peu plus es
autodidactealisé bah toi tu es plus
spécialisé oui c'est ça tu parles
d'insectes c'est ça moi je fais de
l'entomologie donc c'est vraiment
l'étude des insectes rit le mot Barbar
entomologie c'est l'entomologie l'étude
des insectes c'est ça et ben je me
coucherai encore moins con ok trop bien
et donc tu fais combien de temps que toi
tu l'as fait moi ça fait depuis 2018 que
je fais vraiment de la vulgarisation
j'ai commencé les réseaux sociaux de
manière vraiment plus assdue il y a un
an et demi peu après ok d'accord c'est
ça et tu es euh tu es autodidacte parce
que toi tu as une formation dans le
secteur de l'audiovisuel si je dis pas
de conneries alors en fait je suis pas
complètement autodidacte je me suis
formée dans l'audiovisuel en pour
commencer et après en fait je me suis
formée en entomologie donc j'ai vraiment
les deux formations c'est ça et que j'ai
voulu fusionner parce que c'était
vraiment le partage avec le public qui
m'intéressait le plus en fait tu as bien
raison toi Valentine toi tu as une
formation de géologie oui tu as une
formation de géologie tu as été
journaliste scientifique pour Scien et
avenir c'est ça à quel moment tu as fait
le Shift pour venir sur les internets
euh bah j'ai jamais vraiment fait le
shift j'ai fait les deux en parallèle en
fait et j'ai lancé ma chaîne pendant mon
Master en journalisme scientifique
d'accord et voilà et après mon contrat
pour Scien avenir je me suis dit allez
je me lance à temps plein j'ai envie
d'être
chaôeuse let's go la YouTube money
euh euh donc ouais toi Lena tu le dis
toi tu parles d'entomologie culturelle
aussi tu avais décrit ça euh c'est quoi
le caractère culturel dans l'entomologie
du coup je compr en fait l'entomologie
culturelle c'est ma spécialité c'est
l'étude des insectes à travers
l'histoire et dans les différentes
cultures c'est hyper passionnant non
mais c'est trop bien parce qu'en fait du
coup on est entouré d'insectes tout le
temps sur quasiment tous les continents
on va trouver des insectes et et du coup
en fait c'est l'étude de cette place que
va prendre l'insecte dans la vie humaine
et surtout à travers les différentes
cultures parce que la menth religieuse
elle est mal vue dans un pays et dans un
autre c'est elle qui a créé la terre
quoi donc il y a il y a vraiment un
énorme tremplin y a des pays on parce
que la mre religieuse j'ai l'impression
que c'est plutôt positif chez nous en en
Europe non oui alors en Europe c'est
plutôt positif en France on dit même
qu'elle guide les pèlerins par que du
coup il y a cette manière de religion où
on suit normalement les les mains de la
manth pour trouver son chemin tandis
qu'aux États-Unis par exemple on dit
qu'elle crache dans l'œil des hommes
pour les rendre aveugles il y a un petit
quand même je savais pas du tout [__]
c'est hyper intéressant ok tu as fait
des docu aussi d'ailleurs c'est ça tu as
fait des docu tu fais pas que des vidéos
YouTube tu as fait quoi comme docu alors
j'ai fait des docu sur le bomx Mor c'est
le verre à soie qui est une qui qui
c'est hyper passionnant il y a plein de
choses trop chouette avec cet insecte
parce que c'est devenu un animal
domestique à part entière c'est plus du
tout un animal qu'on peut trouver dans
dans le dans la vie sauvage et et il y a
un lien très particulier qui se crée
avec du coup ceux qui font de la
sériculture c'est le mot pour dire on
élève des vers à soi et et du coup sur
ça j'ai fait aussi les les insectes dans
la place dans l'art parce que pareil il
y a il y a une grosse symbolique autour
des insectes dans l'art et du coup à
travers certaines époques et du coup bah
voilà c'est et ben c'est trop bien on a
quelques extraits de ta chaîne qu'on va
regarder tout de suite on va regarder
les extraits on continue à en parler
c'est l'occasion pour vous de découvrir
cette chaîne scarabette abonnez-vous on
regarde j'ai tourné une vidéo avec choco
si vous l'avez vu vous reconnaissez
sûrement petit pied et si vous êtes là
c'est peut-être parce que vous voulez en
adopter un ça c'est aubergine et ça
c'est courgette un joli début de
ratatouille qui j'espère va me faire
beaucoup de petits bébés carottes
tomates et oignons tu te dis peut-être
que j'ai complètement perdu la boule
surtout si tu arrives par hasard et que
tu ne me connais pas mais non ce sont
bien mes animaux de compagnie bon allez
on revient à petit pied c'est un 1000
patte qui d'ailleurs n'a pas vraiment
1000 pattes mais plutôt environ maximum
750 et ce qui est rigolo avec eux c'est
que quand ils se sentent en danger hop
ils ont une technique de ouf ils se
roulent en boule la tête la première si
tu aimes les animaux stylés qui battent
des records du monde est-ce qu'il faut
prendre un iu oui madame voilà c'est la
chaîne scarabet que je vous invite à à
découvrir à vous abonner première
question comment vont petits pied
aubergine et courgette ils vont bien
aubergine àondu et du coup non pardon
courgette à pondu c'est la femelle c'est
aubergine le papa c'est aubergine le
papa malheureusement le papa n'est plus
parmi nous il s'est un peu trop épuisé à
force de reproduction mais bon RIP
courgette elle va très bien bon pourquoi
est-ce que tu penses que il faut
s'intéresser aux insectes les insectes
c'est vraiment la base de tout en fait
c'est la base de la vie c'est eux à la
base de la chaîne alimentaire s' y a pas
d'insectes on Nura pas à manger on aura
pas de pollinisation donc c'est hyper
important de base et ensuite je trouve
que c'est des animaux qui sont sous côté
il y en a qui sont incroyables avec des
particularités hyper étranges des des
liens avec nous qu'on soupçonne pas par
exemple on va parler des punaises de lit
hein ça existe depuis 4000 ans la la la
trace la plus ancienne qu'on a avec eux
c'est 4000 ans donc c'est énorme
Cléopâtre avait des punaises de lit mais
on se dit pas wou c'est ouf mon
ancêcêtre hyper lointain de l'Antiquité
il avait le même problème que moi ben si
pareil les moustiques aussi c' un
problème et on lit par exemple chez les
grands philosophes antique des manières
de combattre les moustiques et notamment
il faisait exprès de construire les
villes éloigné des des des maréquages
enfin c'est des petits trucs comme ça
qu'on c'est inéressant et c'est pour ça
que je trouve c'est des animaux qui sont
un peu sous côté en plus il y en a ils
sont vraiment très beaux non mais c'est
vraih le panda c'est joli mais pardon
mais courgettes mais elle est incroy
incro courgette elle incroable courgette
on t'aime non non mais carrément euh non
non mais c'est c'est c'est c'est hyper
intéressant tu saurit l'exliquer cette
méfiance d'Ave des insects évidemment il
y a eu des des messages de dégoût dans
le chat je m attendis ce que je
comprends tout à fait elle il vient d'où
ce dégoût cette les insectes les petites
pattes je sais pas on l'a exploré ça il
y a plusieurs théories il y en a une qui
dit que on a une peur qui est ancrée
génétiquement alors tous les tous les
scientifiques ne sont pas d'accord sur
cette théorie mais en tout cas il y a
des études qui montrent que on aurait
des peurs en fait parce que du coup les
insectes posaient plus de problèmes
sanitaires
notamment qui vient de l'évolution c'est
ça que c'est ça et du coup on aurait
développer une espèce de peur ancrée
génétiquement après il y a l'autre qui
est la peur sociale qui est transmis de
génération gtion ou ça celle-là elle est
acceptée comme théorie et et ensuite il
y a tout un truc où ils viennent nous
déranger dans notre confort parfois
surtout les insectes tels les mouches
les moustiques les cafars les choses
comme ça ils viennent nous rappeler un
peu à qu'on est des animaux qu'on vit
dans la nature et ça parfois l'être
humain moderne et occidental a du mal à
l'accepter mais c'est une vision qui est
très occidentale encore une fois dans
certains pays on est beaucoup plus à
même de vivre avec ces insectes et on
les considère moins comme une une
nuisance et et voilà en fait ça ça
dépend vraiment beaucoup de de là où on
se place dans le monde et toi du coup
Valentine tu as une chaîne je le disais
qui s'appelle science de comptoir là
aussi on a des extraits on vous les
balance tout de suite et on en parle ou
là là vous pouvez miner les océans pour
sauver la planète et se faire plein de
brousouf au passage compl ah non c'est
pas ça vous avez peut-être entendu
parler du depsy mining aujourd'hui les
scientifiques savent bien que non
planter des forêts n'est pas la solution
miracle pour lutter contre le changement
climatique c'est un des outils
disponibles parmi un arsenal assez vaste
d'initiative de conservation de la
nature et en plus ça coûte vachement
cher pour un taux de réussite pas jjour
quand je dis aux gens que j'ai fait des
études de géologie la première chose qu'
me demande c'est qu'est-ce qui tourne
pas rond chez toi et la deuxième c'est
est-ce que les géologues lèchent
vraiment des cailloux alors non
seulement oui pour la petite histoire on
a même trouvé de la monorionite sur Mars
donc si jamais vous y allz vous pouvez
très bien lécher le sol et si ça reste
collé à votre langue et ben c'est que
c'est de la monomorionite ou alors c'est
que vous avez enlevé votre combinaison
et du coup votre tête a explosé elle est
allée rouler par terre elle est resté
collé au
sol du coup est-ce que tu lèes des
cailloux Valentine bien sûr mais
évidemment pas plus tard qu'il y a une
semaine d'où tu viens toi du coup en
l'occurrence euh de quelle planète ou de
quelle
planè où est-ce que tu comment est-ce
que tu en es venu on en a parlé un petit
peu tout à l'heure tu viens du
journaliste tu as fait des études du
journaliste comment est-ce que tu en es
venu à t'intéresser aux enjeux
scientifiques tu as parlé même de
formation en journalisme scientifique
toutit qu'est-ce qui t'a conduit vers
çait euh bah j'ai toujours beaucoup aimé
les sciences et un peu le côté
artistique de la chose et du coup
cherche un un un métier qui soit à la à
la jointure des deux c'est bon terme
mais on dira que voilà voilà c'est mon
côté
scientifiquep et et du coup c'est bien
parce que c'est bien la science c'est
une manière de devoir le monde mais
ouais non mais je suis bien d'accord
avec toi tu l'abordes avec humour la
science j'essaye est-ce que pour toi
c'est le truc le plus efficace est-ce
que ça a des limites bah le plus
efficace je sais pas ça dépend du public
ça dépend de ce qu'on veut faire moi je
suis clairement dans la vibe
divertissement et non pas dans la vibe
éducation enfin il y a un peu les deux
mais ouais je sais pas juste
naturellement je suis du genre à faire
des blagues et à pas me prendre au
sérieux donc juste à coller bien quoi tu
bosses aussi pour haré avec un projet
qui s'appelle scope tout à fait tu nous
en parles un peu oui oui oui c'est un
des une émission qu'on fait en live sur
twitch sur le twitch d'Arté donc
art.tv fr je sais plus bref rp.tv ouais
je crois oui et et donc on fait des
émissions thématiques sur les sciences
et il y en a une qui arrive très bientôt
la semaine prochaine le 13 sur un sujet
que je ne vous dévoilerai pas les jeux
vidéos merci Valentine bah écoute on a
hâte de la regarder il y a quelqu'un qui
demande dans le chat comment s'appelle
sa chaîne sa chaîne s'appelle science de
comptoir euh n'hésitez surtout pas à
aller à aller aller la regarder Lena ta
chaîne s'appelle scarabets est-ce qu'on
peut parler 2 minutes parce qu'on est
entre nous de de ce phénomène de la
vulga scientifique sur Youtube c'est un
truc j'ai l'impression que c'est
historique sur Youtube j'ai des
souvenirs de de de les premières vagues
de vulgarisateurs scientifiques qui ont
porté la plateforme avec eux il y avait
l'humour et ça on s'en souvient les
Squeezie les Cyprien et cetera mais très
rapidement il y a eu not à Béné il y a
eu y pensé il y a eu science étonnante
et puis enfin il y a toute une g là j'ai
cité que des mecs mais en fait il y a
aussi plein de plein de nanas
euh comment ça se fait que ça marche
aussi bien comment ça se fait que on
regarde jusqu'à 2h du matin des vidéos
sur des sujets qu'on savait même pas que
ça existait 2h avant bah parce qu'on a
envie de de s'instruire je sais pas
ouais c'est cool c'est oui non vas-y
excuse-mi toi vas-y montoi t montoi j'ai
l'impression aussi qu'on a grandi avec
ses pas sorciers euh qu'on a quand même
été vite mis dans des programmes enfin
làà je parle de ma génération on s pas
sorcier ça commence à viir mais mais on
a vachement eu quand même ce truc de
quand on est enfant d'essayer
d'apprendre en s'amusant et je pense que
ça répondait peut-être à cette demande
d'avoir un truc un peu plus adulte mais
sur Youtube je sais pas on a grandi
là-dedans et en plus pardon je non vas-y
vas-y vas-y je suis
horrible en plus on n pas l'équivalent à
la télé enfin en tout cas il y a
vraiment une case vacante à la télé sur
la science même s'il y a des tentatives
à droite à gauche et du coup YouTube
était là pour répondre à cette demande
il y a quelqu'un dans le chat qui dit
est-ce que c'est pas un peu en train de
crever la vulga sur Youtube moi j'ai pas
pas du tout l'impression enfin pardon
mais j'ai l'impression que ça revient
mais j'ai même l'impression que ça
marche du feu de dieu enfin alors que ça
revient peut-être oui d'ailleurs
peut-être qu'il y a eu un ventre mou
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a eu un ventre
mou et que d'un coup là ça commence à
revenir l'engouement en tout cas pour
les chaînes les chaînes éducation les
chaîn ouais c'est les chaînes vulga
aussi dans ce côté juste simplement
découverte enfin tu vois le carton par
exemple de villebrequin il réussit ça
intéresser à la bagnole des gens comme
moi bah c'est une forme de
vulgar je dis ça ils nous ont toujours
pas expliqué ce que c'était que le le
différentiel mais mais mais non non je
je non je sais pas oui oui il y a quand
même un peu de vulgarisation il y a plus
un peu d'explication et non j'ai
vraiment pas l'impression non je sais
pas dans le chat vous me dites hein
twitch monte pas mal en vulgarisation
scientifique ah ouais non je sais pas il
y a de la vulg scientifique sur Youtube
j'en vois pas tu connais scope oui
mainattant que tu dis ou non mais oui
oui arr aré avec scope et avec d'autres
programmes sur twitch peut-être mais
d'autres je sais en même temps si je dis
ça non mais c'est pas vrai parce qu'en
fait il y a les artisans qui nous
montrent leur artisanat les boulangers
les lutiers même il il y a tout un
collectif qui s'est monté sur twitch qui
s'appelle POC science avec voilà tout ce
qu'on prend et compagnie il y a il y a
le knes oui le knes effectivement qui
qui qui font plein de trucs aussi quand
il y a des lancements de d'Arian et
cetera tu as raison maintenant que tu le
dis Micot qui fait de la vulga de fait
non non complètement j'ai c'est juste
que j'y pensais pas mais en fait il y en
a plein puis a moi je fais des
vulgarisations sur de la science
politique mais oui de faites oui oui Non
Non mais ouais carrément de faites je me
dis aussi qui a un petit truc où on est
vite appé par l'humour ou par la le la
vulgarisation et la manière de de de
parler de certaines sciences et tout par
par des par des petites phrases quiit
lécher les cailloux par exemple
clairement moi je je pense pas forcément
à regarder des vidéos sur la géologie
mais quelqu'un qui lâche les cailloux
oui il y a un truc je sais pas ça
m'attire et et je vais aller voir et du
coup j'ai l'impression de me faire raer
pareil villebrequin pour les voitures
personnellement je m'intéresse pas trop
aux voitures mais je regarde les vidéos
de villebrequin designer automobile
aussi qui fait des super vidéos sur les
voitures et sur les design des voitures
et moi j'en ai rien à faire mais je
trouve ça super intéressant comme toi et
c'est ce que j'ai toujours aimé dans la
vulga sur Youtube c'est qu' c'est qu'ils
arrivent à me fasciner à me captiver sur
des enfin vous arrivez vous aussi toutes
les deux à me captiver sur des sujets
encore une fois 5 minutes avant je
savais même pas que le sujet existait
quoi et et et du coup c'est ça qui est
cool mais ça montre ouais effectivement
quelque chose sur la curiosité je sais
pas il y a une forme de de Al de mon
côté je politise tout mais euh ça dit
peut-être quelque chose de la volonté de
de de d'avoir des yeux ouverts sur le
monde de comprendre comment il
fonctionne de s'intéresser de
s'interroger je sais pas cette idée que
les internautes sont des espèces de
moutons qui regardent que leur nombril
et leurs pieds et tout bah la preuve en
fait on passe tellement d'heure à
regarder des trucs sur des sujets qu'on
connaît pas je sais pas on tombe dans
des rabbit hall pendant des heures et
bon on avait le cliché avant je trouve
du geek qui joue au jeux vidéo dans sa
chambre alors qu'en
fait alors que ben non c'est des gens
qui sont hyper au contraire du coup
internet donne accès à plein de cultures
différentes et qui du coup on peut
connaître pourquoi est-ce qu'on lèche
des cailloux et le design des
voitures euh il y a PMF qui dit dans le
chat sur le système éducatif ouais mais
alors là attention faut pas opposer les
deux hein enfin je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez mais la vulgare le
vulgarisateur n'est pas le concurrent du
prof c'est pas du tout le même job
absolument pas c'est un un une aide à la
limite mais non on remplace pas les
profs ne serait-ce que parce que notre
public est content de venir nous
voir c'est
tout bonne rentrée scolaire les profs
hein j'embrasse ma cousine qui est
prof non en plus il y en a plein il y en
a plein qui sont prof et qui font de la
vulga aussi donc non non non c'est un
support différent c'est c'est un contenu
différent c'estit chose et puis ouais et
puis nous n AA pas le temps de creuser
aussi on va pas donner un cours de
biologie pure parce que on a pas le
temps dans une vidéo de 10 minutes ça
remplace pas un cours de 50 minutes sur
sur les insectes et leur comportement ou
leur biologie c'est impossible quoi mais
c'est c'est même d'un certain point de
vue notre rôle à nous les vulgarisateurs
c'est de générer la curiosité chez les
gens qui regardent pour que le lendemain
en cours il lève la main il pose une
question au prof parce que parce que je
sais pas parce qu'on aura éveillé sa
curiosité un truc comme ça ça m'est déjà
arrivé unvec des profs témoignes en
disant [__] j'ai un lycéen il est venu
me voir il m'a parlé du fait majoritaire
et du 493 je savais pas quoi lui
répondre apparemment il a vu une de tes
vidéos je suis largué et cetera et
c'était super sympa de la part du prof
de me dire [__] tu as réussi à
l'intéresser sur un truc de barge et
mais donc tant mieux en fait c'est bon
courage les profs en vrai gros big up à
vous en plus vous en prenez plein la
gueule c'est vraiment pas facile mais
mais voilà en plus dans le chat là vous
êtes tous depuis tout à l'heure à vous
partager des des des chaînes de
vulgarisation qui existe sur twitch ou
sur Youtube et c'est aussi ce qui est
cool dans la vulga j'ai l'impression
d'avoir plus de facilité à dire à mes
potes oh j'ai découvert la chaîne tu
connais la nouvelle chaîne mais j'ai
plus souvent l'habitude de faire ça sur
de la vulga que sur d'autres trucs sur
l'humour ou sur des centres d'intérêts
de geek que je peux avoir par ailleurs
donc donc ouais non c'est cool eu est-ce
que vous pensez que l'avenir de la
vulgarisation est sur Youtube est-ce que
vous pensez que les vieux médias sont
morts comment vous voyez ça euh les
vieux médias je saurais pas dire mais je
pense que l'avenir est pas que sur
youtube il est un peu partout là il y a
il y a un peu une explosion des contenus
éducatifs aussi sur TikTok sur Instagram
enfin les formats cours je trouve qu'il
y a énormément de choses à faire
là-dedans mais encore une fois c'est
vraiment juste pour allumer une
étincelle quoi on n'est pas là pour
expliquer des trucs en 2 3 minutes on
peut on peut rien dire quoi juste on
balance une anecdote ou deux et puis
voilà mais je pense qu'il y a plein de
trucs à faire sur plein de médias
différents ouais ouais non mais
carrément je suis d'accord avec toi
c'est quoi vous les meilleurs retours
que vous avez eu parce que moi j'ai
raconté ce retour là comme une anecdote
mais c'est quoi les trucs qui vous ont
le plus marqué de retour de votre public
moi je crois c'est les messages privés
qui me disent ah avant j'écrasé les
insectes parce que j'aimis pas ça et
maintenant je les prends en photo et je
les
envoie ton compte quoi des insectes
après avoir vu tes vidéos oh plein c'est
trop bien plein plein si je reçois tous
les jours des messages de gens qui me
disent ah j'ai envie d'adopter des
phases comment je fais ah j'ai envie
d'adopter des papillons comment je fais
enfin plein de trucs comme ça et du coup
ça c'est cool c'est trop cool et toi
alors les miens veulent adopter du gnice
et c'est plus facile d'entretien c'est
quoi le pour ce qu'on pas la r c'est un
type de roche voilà pas très intéressant
vous pouvez la lécher voilà peer
l'uranium essayer d'éviter mais le GL
vous pouvez y aller non mais oui
effectivement le le truc de base c'est
de dire je m'intéresse pas du tout du
tout au cillou mais je regarde ta chaîne
ça c'est génial parce que du coup il y a
des gens qui apprennent des trucs et
tout enfin ça me fascine des fois je
reçois pas mal de photos de gens qui me
disent ça c'est quoi comme
caillou j'aime bien mais mettez vos
mettez une échelle sur la photo sinon
c'estile oui s'il vous plaît faites ENF
je dis ça c'est pas pour moi c'est pour
Valentine m'envoyz pas de photo de
caillou je saais pas quoi vous dire il
est droite ou il est gauche ce caillou
j' sais
rien vraiment
bon scarabet science de comptoir on vous
a invité toutes les deux pour parler
d'un sujet qui aussi un petit peu dans
l'actu ce sont les punaises de lit et on
va en par mais avant ça ça va être
introduit par une super séquence c'est
parti pour le powerpo de
[Applaudissements]
Vincent V faut que je m'installe
attendez après je mais j'ai un câble à
brancher enfin c'est le powerpoint
installe-toi oui alors ça c'est grand
changement de la saison 3 ce n'est plus
la régie qui passe les slides c'est
Vincent directement sur son ordi euh
nous sommes des professionnels j'adore
le en fait la rythmique tout ça j'ai ma
tablette pour mon texte vraiment j'ai
l'impression d'être Hugo de la crypte
ENF c'est j'adore aujourd'hui dans
l'actualité
bref salut c'est Hugo vous allez bien ça
va et toi Vincent ça fait plaisir de te
voir bah ouais mais en plus moi la
semaine dernière je suis désolé j'étais
pas là j'avais j'avais le
covid et j'ai fait une décision qui a pu
qui a peut-être un peu choqué dans je
sais pas les gens mais j'ai décidé de
m'isoler pour pas contaminer voilà ça se
fait encore certains essay voilà donc
hésitez pas hésitez pas rassurez-vous he
aujourd'hui je reviens avec un un gros
gros sujet euh je vais parler d'un ce
parasite qui nous agace tous
alors alors il y a lui aussi mais c'est
c'est je parlais d'un autre parasite he
effectivement cette semaine on m'a
proposé de parler des des punaises de
lit parce que c'est vrai que c'est le
sujet médiatique du du moment et et
c'est parti un peu dans dans tous les
sens on va parler après mais j'ai vu que
Bernard Verbert était devenu expert en
sexualité de punaisses de lit sur BFM TV
je vous ai mis un cours extrait j'en
pouvais plus je crois qu'on a la la
vidéo la punae des lit a une sexualité
toride parce que ils ont plus de 200
rapports sexuels par jour par jour alors
qu'il y a peu d'humains qui arrive à
cette performance et
deuxièmement la quantité de sperme lâché
est gigantesque ça correspondra à
plusieurs litres par rapport à notre
taille humaine voilà donc merci Bernard
merci BFM la se voilà on va reparler et
tout mais en fait ça me ça me tu parce
qu'il était très content de faire ces
petites blagues les humains voilà bref
c'était c'était drôle mais par contre
pas de King Shiming sur la sexualité des
punaises de lit on n'est pas là on n'est
pas là pour ça mais moi quand j'ai vu ce
sujet monter ces dernières semaines j'ai
pas été surpris en fait parce que sans
vouloir faire le hipster moi ça fait des
années que les punaises de lit me font
peurin je dis je dis ça mais j'avais
peur des punaises de lit avant que ça
soit cool d'avoir peur des punaises de
lit j'essaie pas de me placer adessus de
la mêlée mais voilà factuellement
j'avais j'avais cette peur là depuis
longtemps et et puis voilà moi c'est
vrai que je je suis terrifié à l'idée de
de d'ouvrir mon lit et de trouver des
des punaises de lit ou ou Pascal pro
hein
mais mais ce que je veux dire en fait
c'est c'est ça ça m'a quand même
questionné ce que je me suis dit mais
pourquoi pourquoi on en parle maintenant
en fait pourquoi donc c'est la question
que je vais vous poser ce soir là
j'adore par que je peux faire les
animation ça prend grave du temps
j'adore attendez voilà hop
là applaudissement vcent est vachement
bien
fa
euh trop mignonne la punaise je trouve
euh c'est c'est fait avec M journée
voilà
euh je pose la question parce qu'en soi
c'est vrai qu'il y a il y a rien de il y
a rien de de nouveau en 2022 donc le
syndicat des industries de
désinsectisation a totalisé plus d'un
million d'interventions professionnelles
contre 200000 en 2017 donc c'est c'est
une hausse à peu près de 15 à 20 % euh
en en 5 ans donc ça fait des années que
c'est un problème et j'iraiis même plus
loin en rappelant que les punaises de
lit étaient là avant nous sur Terre en
2019 il y avait une étude de curent
biology qui disait que les punaises de
lit sont sur terre depuis 115 millions
d'années et qu' donc elles ont survécu à
l'extinction des des dinosures donc les
les punaises sont costaudes elles vont
elles vont à la salle quoi elles
prennent de la prot elles prennent de la
way suivent les tutos de de thbo inshape
et en fait depuis bah l'humanité n'a
cessé de les côtoyer parfois sans le
savoir et dans la culture historique et
populaire on retrouve toujours ce petit
ce petit nuisible dans les peintures
rupè à la Renaissance ou même au cinéma
ça a été vraiment un sujet récurrent moi
non j'arrête là encore c'était
mi-journée voilà j'ai j'ai fait grâce à
un copain qui s'appelle Valentin que
j'embrasse j'ai fait des petits promptes
comme ça mais je trouve que les
résultats sont quand même assez
impressionnants faut le dire et mais en
fait cette petite tentative de blague
visuelle me permet de d'arriver au cœur
du du sujet et de l'une des explications
sur pourquoi selon moi ça Pope
maintenant c'est qu'en fait les punesses
de lit avant de devenir des des
personnages médiatiques en fait je
trouve que c'est un personnage qui était
fait et qui est né pour les réseaux
sociaux en fait je m'explique il y a
d'abord la bah la la la figure de la
punaise que donc c'est on appelle ça
scientifiquement c'est la la simex
lectularius si je me trompe pas voilà
pour pour les pour les intime donc c'est
un hisible c'est un un être qui est pas
très joli j'ai remplacé les visuels pour
pas trigger de de gens dans dans le
public ou sur sur le chat mais en gros
euh voilà c'est inusible en plus les
conséquences sur la santé mentale des
personnes qui peuvent avoir voir ça chez
eux c'est assez c'est assez
catastrophique et donc je trouve qu'en
fait de base la punesse de lit on a
envie de s'en moquer parce que on a
envie de se défouler dessus et je trouve
Queen plus ça c'est c'est une bonne
manière de d'ironiser sur les pires
aspects de la vie urbaine et d'alimenter
une forme bah un peu de de tendance un
peu un peu humoristique et moi ça me
rappelle ça me rappelle pas mal à New
York la la figure en fait du du rat à
New York en fait c'est un vrai problème
aussi là-bas
il y a un parallèle je trouve qui est
assez intéressant parce que en fait le
Race est devenu un peu une star des
réseaux sociaux aussi il y a même une
sorte de tourisme il y a un tiktokeur
qui filme les rat et qui invite les gens
à faire un peu des chasses au rat pour
les filmer pour le mettre sur les
réseaux sociaux je pense aussi au fameux
pizza rat c'était un rat qui était
devenu célèbre il y a quelques années
parce qu'il a été filmé en train de de
s'échapper avec une une part de pizza
dans la bouche on la remet je pense la
connaissez mais on on a la vidéo juste
pour
oh là là c'est un new yorka comme un
autre
quoi mais elle revient elle revient elle
revientelleattend parce qu'elle a un peu
peur elle voit qu'elle est filmé mais
elle va revenir elle lâche pas l'affaire
et tout voilà donc en fait il y a il y a
des pizzaarat c'est devenu un peu un
emblème aussi de la ville et cetera
et il y a il y a même j'ai vu il y a il
y a quelques semaines à peine il y a le
maire de New York qui a nommé une tsar
des rats Catheline coradi pour gérer le
problème c'est comme si dans quelques
mois il y a un peu de bruit je sais pas
non t'qu tout va bien c'est comme si
dans quelques mois il y avait un un
préposé au punaises de lit qui était
nommé par annidalgo quoi et je trouve
que c'est assez en fait les possibilités
sont assez folles et et en fait la
punase de lis c'est un vrai problème de
santé publique ça et je trouve que ça
pourrait voilà devenir une figure un peu
populaire dans la ville qu'on pourrait
classer bah entre ratatouille et les
légendes urbaines du crocodile dans dans
les égouts et cetera je pense qu'il y a
un truc symbolique qui peut qui peut se
mettre en place et je trouve que aussi
un autre point intéressant c'est que la
punae de lit c'est un être vivant qui
par définition se propage elle se
multiplie elle se faufile elle peut
passer d'humain en humain et elle peut
bah se transformer muter et cetera
exactement comme les mêmes en fait sur
sur internet de base c'est fait pour
pour se répandre au début sur Twitter
c'était surtout une petite blague entre
parisiens sur certaines salles du MK2
dans le nord-est de Paris et puis bah
progressivement C été un peu tout a
changé sur les réseaux parce que il y a
les les alertes qui sont diversifié en
gros comme certains même les punaises de
lis se sont un peu décentralisés pour
ceux qu'on la rêve euh et on a vu donc
en août il y a eu d'abord un ou là
attendez je spoil oh là là en août il y
a eu d'abord un premier témoignage une
certaine Nawal qui qui témoignait sur le
UGC de Bercy Village puis ensuite la
punaisee de lit voyage en en classe écho
mais elle voyage donc on la voit
soi-disant dans le TGV et cetera et tout
donc ça ça commence à ça commence à se à
se répondre il y a eu un lîfandre euh
voilà la crainte commence à grandir
parce qu'en plus il y a des vidéos des
photos des gens qui critiquent et qui
dis ah oui s'en est sen est pas et
cetera donc ça crée aussi pas mal de
discussions et après bah c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment l'avalanche euh il y a un
conducteur de la ligne 8 qui a dit qu'il
en avait vu même si ça a été démenti il
y a eu des services d'urgence qui ont dû
un peu fermer euh des collège des des
classes et cetera et peu importe en fait
s'il y a des démentis euh chaque
signalement et que chaque signalement
n'est pas forcément véridique et ben en
fait c'est un peu c'est un peu trop tard
parce que même si c'est difficile de
mesurer vraiment euh le l'ampleur
l'ampleur du phénomène bah pour les
réseaux sociaux ce genre de de
propagation on va dire bah c'est
vraiment du pain béni et moi ça m'a
rappelé une histoire ça m'a rappelé
alors je sais pas si vous vous en
souvenez cé à l'été 2020 l'histoire des
chevaux mutilés euh il y avait eu
beaucoup beaucoup de fake news autour de
cette histoire là et il y avait
notamment quelques plaisentins qui
avaient lancé la rumeur que c'était Nagi
le présentateur Nagi qui était
responsable de la mutilation des des
chevaux évidemment c'est c'était
délirant et tout mais c'est resté un des
arcs narratifs du Twitter français que
je trouve le plus marquant en tout cas
Fas ça a été un vrai phénomène
médiatique et en fait je me dis qu' il y
a quelque chose d'un peu d'un d'un peu
similaire avec ça mais à la différence
et là encore c'est le dernier point qui
est très important c'est que les
punaises de lit ça touche à un sujet
sensible c'est les Jeux Olympiques qui
auront lieu en 2024 à Paris et donc le
voit avec la la couverture médiatique
mondiale oui évidemment j'ai fait une
petite une petite sélection de
différents médias italiens allemand
anglais et cetera il y a un enjeu
d'image il y a un en en jeu politique
économique il y a un enjeu sanitaire
évidemment qui joue qui se joue autour
de cette petite bestiole et donc parce
que les punaises de lit permettent de
créer des mêes et des blagues sur le
sujet très controversé des des Jeux
Olympiques et ben ça ça lui permet de
gagner encore plus de puissance je
trouve sur sur les réseaux ça en devient
même un outil de bataille politique hein
vous allez en parler mais on a vu voilà
mathde panneau qui brandit une une fiole
remple de punaise à l'Assemblée
nationale au même moment où elle est
via certaines enquêtes diffusées à la
télévision subit un petit peu un un
certain contrecoup on a aussi vu
beaucoup de blagues sur anidalgo an
Idalgo qui est souvent la cible de Van
sur les réseaux sociaux bah il y a des
blagues qui ont été faites il y a des
politiques qui ont même dit voilà la
ville la plus touchée c'est Paris qui a
la tête de Paris c'est Madame Idalgo
voilà c'est vraiment ce truc de voilà
profitons-en et tout et et donc en fait
vous l'avez compris la punaise de lit
bah elle a vraiment en plus d'envahir
nos appartements ça on le sait pas
vraiment c'est difficile encore une fois
à quantifier mais je trouve qu'elle
était vraiment faite pour envahir les
réseaux sociaux il y a vraiment une
contamination qui est assez intéressante
et moi je vais pour conclure ça m'a fait
penser à à quelque chose qui m''est
arrivé il y a quelques semaines je
sortais d'un rendez-vous et je
traversais la scène et j'assiste à je
vois sur une espèce de pneumatique qui
était en train de tourner des images
pour un film et j'ai appris par la suite
que le film en question et je vous jure
c'est pas desb bar c'est un film Netflix
qui va parler de l'attaque de requin
pendant une épreuve de triathlon dans
pendant les les pendant les Jos enfin
peut-être pas forcément les Jos ça sera
peut-être pas brander comme ça mais
c'est une attaque de requin pendant une
épreuve de Triatlon c'est avec berinis
beot enfin j'ai hâte de voir ça et en
fait là je me suis dit donc je me suis
dit mais en fait je sais pas ce que
c'est toujours un peu en prod et cetera
et tout je me dis si les scénaristes de
Netflix ils sont malins et ben en fait
ils remplacent le requin par des
punaises de lit et ça serait beaucoup
plus réaliste et ça serait beaucoup plus
flippant et enfin voilà je sais pas mais
c'est juste une petite idée que je lise
comme ça avant de vous dire bonsoir et
de vous remercier de m'avoir écouté
voilà passz bonne soirée merci beaucoup
Vincent pour ce powerpo
exceptionnel merci beaucoup Vincent euh
pour ce power point extrêmement
intéressant effectivement les punaises
de lit ont t envahi nos nos réseaux
sociaux mais aussi nos appartements on
va on va en parler
euh Vincent l'a abordé rapidement dans
sa dans sa chronique il a parlé de la
sexualité des punaes de lit Valentine tu
voulais nous en parler aussi oh oui
vas-y oh oui alors j'ai préparé une
petite chronique elle s'appelle 5
minutes pour faire bann ta chaîne on va
voir on va voir vas-y alors si ça vous
démange rien que de parler des punaes de
lit parce que moi j'étais pas bien là
pendant tout la bref attendez d'entendre
sur la sexualité non des PL Bernard
verber je sais pas pourquoi je parle
comme ça pour donner le temps quand vous
tapez reproduction des punaes de lit
dans Google enfin dans votre moteur de
recherche préférée tant que c'est pas
celui qui plante des arbres là vous
tombez sur la page insémination
traumatique voilà ça donne le
ton d'ailleurs toute ressemblance avec
le comportement de certains youtubeurs
serait purement for twite donc parlons
des punaises et de l'ORS edage alors
c'est pas un ehémisme tu regrettes déjà
là non non non jusque là je suis ça
roule donc edage c'est le nom du petit
robinet d'amour des insectes et
d'ailleurs sachez que chaque espèce a un
edage bien particulier un petit robinet
bien particulier on peut s'en servir
pour identifier les espèces tu me dis si
si je me trompe hein c'est tout bon ok
euh voilà chacun son truc perso si je me
présente à la douinee je préfère juste
montrer mon passeport mais chacun son
truc après pas de King shaming donc
lesdh de la punae de lit revenons-en au
microscope c'est un de seringue ou de
poignard c'est vous qui voyez he c'est
pas un peu comme l'étage de rorcha vous
y voyez ce que vous voulez quand il est
temps donc pour le mal de disséminer ses
gènes il chope la femelle et il l'empale
avec son dart d'amour voilà il l'empale
pour de vrai gen vraiment c'est ouais il
l'empale gen voilà sans les bruitages
voilà je sais pas comment on demande son
consentement à une punaise mais je crois
pas que ce soit comme ça en tout cas
mais là où c'est encore mieux enfin pas
pas le bon choix de mot c'est qu'en fait
les insectes ont pas dauquelettes comme
nous vous savez c'est mou c'est mou et
au bout d'un moment c'est dur chez les
gens normaux moi c'est surtout beaucoup
mou euh en fait chez les insectes c'est
un exosquelette donc en fait il y a une
espèce d'armure rintérieur et c'est moi
l'intérieur voilà quand vous écraser un
insecte ça fait alors que si vous écrasz
un humain ça fait voilà c'est moyen
némotechnique dans oui je l'ai c'est pas
de moi c'est pas de moi donc je sais
même plus où j'en étais ave cette voilà
donc le mâle doit insérer son glave dans
le corps de la femelle en transperçant
son squelette imaginez la violence du
truc ouais ensuite il va lui injecter le
le principe actif directement dans le
corps avec sa seringue et lui délivre le
Pass sanitaire en passant euh oui donc
il s'en fout en fait de repérer les
voies génitales de la femelle juste il
lui transpersce le bide et elle se
démerde donc voilà c'est c'est une autre
façon de faire après ça les petits
soldats du Mâ vont voyager dans le sang
de la femelle on dit pas sang en vrai on
dit hmolymphe je me permets de voilà
parce qu'on sait jamais euh là ils vont
faire un petit tour gratuit du nomè donc
sur votre gauche voici l'œil sur votre
droite c'est le pro thorax devant vous
lesover terminus tout le monde descend
et à ce moment-là le sperme va descendre
et il va féconder l'ovule ou alors il va
être mis de côté par la femelle dans une
poche spéciale qu'on appelle la
spermatque et la femelle va pouvoir s'en
servir à loisir après si on en a besoin
un peu comme la fameuse bouteille voilà
un peu comme la fameuse bouteille de
ketchup qu'on garde au fond du frigo et
là là vous vous dites le calvaire est
fini et bien non pas du tout parce que
NAND dé plaise à Christine Boutin les
insectes c'est plutôt 400 papas une
maman non voilà et bon en l'occurrence
pour les funaises tu regrettes
maintenant
pour l'épunaise c'est plutôt 5q papa une
maman mais je suis un peu marseillaise
d'adoption donc faut pas me croire quand
je dis des chiffres voilà donc non
seulement le vaccin lui-même est un peu
traumatique mais en plus vous payez 400
millions de rappels directement après
Macron
destitution voilà après tous les
accouplements qu'elles subissent du coup
les femelles elles sont un peu mal en
point voilà elles peuvent perdre du sang
les plis peuvent s'infecter parfois
parce qu'il y a plein de bactéries un
peu sur tout tout toutes ces choses
d'amour elles peuvent même en mourir
donc en gros leur leur espér de vie
diminue drastiquement et pour limiter la
casse elles ont développé quand même la
joie de la coévolution c'est qu'elles
ont développé un genre de cible molle
sur l'abdomen qu'on appelle un
spermaledge en anglais je sais pas
comment on dit en français un organe
pour dire au mal viser là là plutôt là
là ça fera moins mal là voilà avec plus
ou moins de de succès évidemment parce
que les
hommes la question pour finir c'est
pourquoi pourquoi l'évolution pourquoi
il y a plusieurs hypothèses l'une
d'entre elles c'est que pas le temps en
fait on n pas le time gagner le temps
donc on économise un bonjour comment tu
t'appelles on économise un resto ça
laisse plus de temps pour pouvoir créer
de la valeur comme ça pour miner du
Bitcoin je sais pas ce que vous voulez
avec votre temps on a commencé du coup
en parlant d'dage alors j'aimerais finir
de la même manière pas comme les
femelles punais juste la chronique de la
même manière il y a même des récepteurs
figurez-vous des chimiécepteurs sur le
pénis de la punae de lit qui lui
permettent de goûter la femelle donc
quand il est en en place il peut savoir
si quelqu'un est déjà passé avant ou pas
en fait voilà comme ça il sait s'il est
plutôt première nation ou alors juste
Christophe Colomb quoi et et comme ça il
va adapter la quantité de poussière
d'étoile qui va incter à la femelle
derrière et c'est beau en tout cas si
vous étiez dégoûté jusqu'à maintenant
d'avoir des punaes de lit chez vous
dites-vous que maintenant vous savez ce
qu'elles font sous vous et peut-être
même dans vos interstices pendant que
vous dormez merci merci
[Applaudissements]
Valentine merci beaucoup Valentine
c'était on a appris beaucoup de choses
plus que qu'on aurait probablement voulu
savoir mais c'est ça qui est beau avec
la connaissance finalement il y en a
jamais assez merci beaucoup Lena toi tu
as fait plusieurs vidéos sur ta chaîne
pour parler avec ton public de ce sujet
le sujet des punaises de lit on regarde
une vidéo on en parle tout de suite
Bradley Cooper a déjà eu des punaises de
lit mais plus étonnant Cléopatre aussi
et oui elles existent depuis très
longtemps ces petites bêtes en fait à la
base on pense que c'était des parasites
des chauve-souris qui vivaient dans des
grottes et qu'elles ont petit à petit
évolué jusqu'à devenir des parasites des
humains oui ça me gratte et d'ailleurs
les premières traces écrites qu'on a des
punaise de lit elle datent de 4000 ans
quand même donc ça commence à faire un
bail oh et d'ailleurs on peut lire des
petites pépite quand on regarde les
traitements antiunais de l'époque moi
Démocrite je préconise de mettre des
pieds de lapin au pied du lit oui pour
le coup ça naura aucune conséquence sauf
pour les petits lapins sinon on propose
de pulvériser du cianure dans la pièce
ah bah ça pour le coup ça devrait
marcher sur les punaises de lit mais
aussi sur les humains bon les plus aisés
ils avaient vite compris la combine ont
jartait tout de la pièce et ont racheté
le maximum mais ça coûtait cher tout ça
voilà c'est un extrait d'une vidéo que
vous pouvez retrouver sur la chaîne
scarabette que je vous invite à à
découvrir si c'est pas encore fait Lena
est-ce que la punaise de lis c'est un
insecte comme les autres alors euh comme
les autres il ressemble à beaucoup
d'autres insectes mais il est assez
particulier parce que c'est un insecte
parasite c'est-à-dire que il va vivre au
dépend d'un autre et là l'autre en
l'occurrence c'est nous le des punaises
de lit donc il aime vraiment
particulièrement notre sang c'est
vraiment nous qui va venir parasiter et
du coup c'est ce qui on fait quand même
un insecte assez spécial
en voilà on on précise qu'il y a eu 1
million d'interventions contre les
punaises de lit en 2022 c'est une
augmentation de 200000 en un an donc on
est alors je sais pas si on est face à
un phénomène en nombre de punaes de lit
est-ce queil y a véritablement une
explosion ou est-ce que c'est que les
gens sont plus alertes c'est que parce
qu'on en parle bah les gens il ils
regardent ils on trouve et que du coup
ils appellent à faire des interventions
je saurais pas dire mais est-ce que
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que est-ce
qu'il y a un caractère phénoménal parce
que dans ta vidéo tu dis que ça fait
4000 ans que ça existe ça devrait pas
être un un sujet
particulièrement nouveau alors en fait
faut savoir que les les punaises de lit
ça fait depuis 2017 qu'on a vraiment une
augmentation chaque année qui est un peu
significative il y avait déjà eu en 2021
pas mal de d'articles sur les punaes de
l notamment au cru avec les les
étudiants qui se retrouvaient avec des
des des chambres infesté de punais de
lit et certains cru qui ne voulaient
rien faire pour inter enfin pour ok euh
arrêter les invasions donc il faut
savoir effectivement qu'il y a une
petite augmentation enfin une petite une
augmentation chaque année depuis 2017
qui qui fait l'objet de plusieurs
alertes de la part de divers organismes
en revanche en 2023 il y a pas d'un coup
un énorme boom de punaise de lit si vous
aviez pas peur il y a 1 an vous avez à
peine plus vous auriez de raisons
d'avoir à peine plus de peur là cette
année euh il y en a qui litent ça au
réchauffement climatique en disant que
les insectes en gros elle a moins de
prédateur qu'avant parce que parce qu'on
sait que la biodiversité est touchée
très directement par les changements
climatiques est-ce que c'est vrai est-ce
que tu as une info là-dessus ou pas
ouais alors la punae de lit elle a pas
vraiment de prédateur principal à part
nous parce que le le truc c'est que elle
elle est du coup elle a évolué pour nous
parasiter nous humains et elle est très
peu intéressée par tout ce qui est
autres animaux alors elle peut de temps
en temps aller paralyser les animaux
domestiques parce que du coup ils sont
dans la pièce et du coup ça va être
aussi des des cibles qui vont pouvoir
cibler quand par exemple ils n'ont pas
d'autres humains apportés par contre
c'est très rare et euh c'est devenu des
insectes qui vont aller dans des
chambres et nous on ne laisse plus les
animaux aller dans nos maisons donc on a
plus de petits rongeurs qui pourraent
éventuellement s'en nourrir on a plus de
de d'araignée qui pourrai venir
combattre les les punaises de lit euh ou
on fait la chasse aux toiles d'araignées
on fait la chasse au moustique on fait
la chasse aux souris au rats et
exactement c'est plutôt un insecte qui
est assez euh particulier dans ce
domaine là c'est qu'il n'a pas forcément
vraiment de pr prédateurs qui vont
pouvoir venir avoir un un impact sur les
punaises de lit euh euh tu disais tout à
l'heure que la plupart des insectes il
sont à la base de la chaîne alimentaire
la punesse de lit elle a elle sert à
quoi c'est compliqué c'est une question
qui est compliquée c'est un insecte
parasite souvent les parasites il sont
là du coup pour réguler les populations
euh pour le coup on n pas de il y a
aucune preuve qui dit que les punaises
de lit sont porteurs de maladie donc ils
sont là pour se nourrir ils ont une
place dans l'écosystème parce qu'ils ont
réussi à avoir cette petite place là ils
ont réussi à avoir cette petite niche
après tout animal qui disparaît se fait
remplacer dans la biodiversité mais là
bon on va pas dire que il va y avoir un
énorme trou si la punase de lit
disparaît en revanche il faut s'enlever
de la tête qu'on peut éradiquer les
punaises de lit maintenant c'est même
plus imaginable d'accord euh est-ce que
l'on sait ce qui explique cette
augmentation j'ai vu la question posée
dans le chat depuis 2017 est-ce qu'on
connaît les facteurs qui permettent
d'expliquer ce ce retour des punaises de
lit est-ce que c'est que en France
est-ce que c'est en Europe est-ce que
c'est dans tous les pays développés sais
pas alors c'est partout dans le monde
les réchauffements climatiqu
effectivement c'est une raison qu'on
voit beaucoup amener sur le débat public
mais en fait c'est plus plus
généralement la chaleur qui fait que le
cycle de la vie de la punaise de lit est
réduite donc plus il fait chaud plus les
œufs vont éclore vite plus les adultes
vont muer rapidement et du coup vont
pouvoir se reproduire rapidement
d'accord donc c'est pour ça que on dit
que le réchauffement climatique a un
impact et effectivement quand il fait
chaud là on a un mois d'octobre qui est
particulièrement clément on va voir que
que la reproduction et les interventions
pour agir sur les punaises de lit vont
encore continuer pendant je pense
jusqu'à novembre voire même si on
continue comme ça peut-être début
décembre et et ça c'est c'est
problématique parce que il y a plus de
place à avoir une grosse invasion de
punais de lit en fait d'accord ok est-ce
que l'hiver sera bénéfique la question
est posée dans le chat alors l'hiver
dans nos contrées fait que la punaise se
met en dormance et donc arrête de venir
se nourrir et arrête du coup de se
reproduire et du coup l'invasion va se
réduire par contre elle se met en
dormance et dès qu'il va refaire beau
elle va recommencer donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut traiter très rapidement quand
on a des punaises de lit même quand on
chauffe chez nous euh bah du coup ça pas
dépendre de comment est-ce qu'on chauffe
euh par exemple moi je suis sous les
toits je descends rarement en dessous de
18°r c'est largement suffisant pour que
les punaises de lit elles continuent il
y a des logements où on chauffe plus ou
moins et du coup bah là si vous chffz
avant chez vous effectivement elles vont
pas se mettre en dormance il y a
quelqu'un qui demande comment est-ce
qu'on sait qu'on a des punaises de lit
chez nous est-ce que il y a que les les
piqûures les démangeaisons qui nous
permett d'identifier le fait qu'on a un
problème ou est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut
simplement les chercher oui bah alors il
y a plusieurs signes la première c'est
les piqûes sachant que c'est assez
difficile quand même de différencier les
piqûes de punaise de lit de piqûes par
exemple de moustique c'est un peu
compliqué on peut avoir des des petits
signes les dermatologues souvent
réussissent à un peu plus essayer
d'épingler si telle ou telle piqû donc
on a les piqûes elles gratent très fort
généralement sachant que chacun a c'est
des sensibilités particulières mais
ensuite la deuxième chose à vérifier
c'est son matelas et notamment son drap
si on voit des petites traces de sang
c'est assez spécifique des punaises de
lit parce que du coup le moustique ne va
pas laisser une trace de sang quand
typique tandis que la punaise de lit oui
en général va laisser unete trace
ensuite c'est de soulever le drap de
changer les draps complètement et on va
essayer de trouver des œufs on va
essayer de trouver des excréments les
excrément c'est tout noir et ça
ressemble un petit peu à de la
moisissure c'est assez assez spécifique
et et et voilà ça c'est les
principaux signes à regarder pour
vérifier si on a des punaises de lit
chez soi est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on fait
si on apprend si on découvre voilà qu'on
a des punaises de lit est-ce qu'il y a
des numéros de téléphone est-ce qu'il y
a des des actions spécifiques qu'on doit
faire mettre en place alors on panique
pas déjà vraiment faut enlever la il
faut en arrivant en comprenant comment
fonctionne la punaise de lit et surtout
comment ça fonctionne une invasion de
punaise de lit il faut qu'on arrive à
calmer déjà parce que le problème des
punaises de lit on est on l'a dit ça ne
transmet pas de maladie par contre ça
peut amener plutôt de de l'anxiété du
stress de l'angoisse de l'isolement
social et ça c'est vraiment
problématique c'est plutôt ça qui va
poser problème donc on ne panique pas
euh on met tout son tout son linge de
lit à la machine à laver on va le mettre
à une température le plus haut possible
donc au-dessus de 60° c'est très bien on
évite les les les cycles de lavage trop
court donc va plus privilég les cycles
de lavage coton lin ce que vous voulez
ensuite on va essayer de trouver un
Balet vapeur ça c'est super parce que
les insecticides qu'on trouve dans les
commerces ne marchent plus donc c'est
même plus la peine les punaises sont
devenus résistantes c'est ça c'est ça ça
coûte très cher et c'est complètement
inutile donc vraiment on on utilise pas
en plus c'est souvent pas bon pour votre
santé donc en plus encore raison de plus
de pas l'utiliser ok ok donc on va
plutôt aller chercher vers la vapeur et
là la vapeur chaude qui peut monter à
120° on va passer doucement sur chaque
recoin de son lit et tout ce qui est
tablee de
Chevé le sol les petits recoins des truc
qu'on fait jamais là c'est ça voilà bah
c'est l'occase on y va voilà exactement
et et on va faire ça pendant une semaine
si on continue à avoir des signes et
qu'on voit maintenant les individus
parce que quand vous voyez plusieurs
individus c'est que là vous avez quand
même une invasion qui commence à être
conséquente là vous pouvez vous référer
à des professionnels sachant que ça a un
prix c'est un coût faut le savoir mais
que voilà c'est environ 800 € par par
intervention donc ça peut monter ou et
et il faut essayer de voir si vous êtes
locataire ça c'est super important à
préciser c'est à votre propriétaire
normalement de prendre en charge les
funais de lit ah bon savoir ça ouais ok
d'accord un tonnerur d'applaudissement
pour Lena mesdames et messieurs pour ce
super conseil merci beaucoup Lena
vraiment pour ça je pense qu'il y a un
petit truc à préciser que j'ai vraiment
envie de de mettre l'accent c'est que
c'est pas une question d'hygiène les
punaises de lit il n'y a rien qui dit
que les personnes qui ne se qui ne
changent pas souvent leurs draps qui qui
ne se lavent pas qui ont des problèmes
d'hygiène ont plus de problèmes de lit
c'est vraiment une quelque chose qui pe
rien vous nêtes pour rien vous n êtes
pour rien vous avez très peu de chance
de ramener des punaises de lit si vous
prenez les précautions sur votre lieu de
travail euh dans les transports que vous
prenez euh il y a il y a pas à à
culpabiliser d'avoir des punaises de lit
et il y a pas à culpabiliser de demander
de l'aide pour les invasions de punais
de lit c'est quelque chose qui peut
arriver à tout le monde même bras de les
coup en a eu ouais donc c'est bon ou
c'est oui non mais donc si Brad Cooper
en a eu ne vous ne vous
ou
ne vous mettez pas en isolement et
surtout demander de l'aide et notamment
à des des professionnels de la
psychologie parce que ne restez pas avec
des problèmes comme ça on voit que les
gens qui ont eu des punaises de lit il y
a un gros pourcentage qui vont après
consulter pour des problèmes d'anxiété
de stress et d'insomnie et ça on veut
pasou et je précise que le gouvernement
déclenche demain un conseil
interministériel sur le sujet des
annonces sont peut-être attendu dans la
foulée donc on verra si les pouvoirs
publics mettront quelque chose de
spécifique en place chers amis Valentine
Léa Lena excuse-moi grande particularité
cette année dans l'émission backsit on
voulait inviter à nouveau des créatrices
de contenu et je suis super content de
vous accueillir parce que c'était
vraiment génial cette partie mais ça va
être encore mieux puisqu'on vous a
proposé de mettre en avant quelque chose
qui vous intéresse une cause une
association un truc comme ça Elena quand
on t'a proposé tu nous as dit ouais moi
je voudrais parler de scienceces
participativ chers amis j'ai le plaisir
de vous demander d'accueillir sur ce
plateau Manon giselin qui est docteur en
écologie au Muséum d'histoire naturelle
bonsoir Manon ça se prononce Guilain je
suis absolument désolé c'est pas grave
tout le monde fait l'erreur merci Manon
tu es donc je le disais docteur en
écologie au Muséum d'Histoire Naturelle
tu t'es intéressé aux sciences
participatives oui tu peux nous dire ce
que c'est déjà alors l'idée des sciences
participatives c'est de remettre les
citoyens au cœur des programmes de
recherche donc tout le monde peut
participer pour servir à des questions
scientifiques pour que les les
chercheurs puissent répondre à des
questions scientifiques qu'ils se posent
donc euh l'idée c'est de à la fois
sensibiliser euh le grand public à à des
questions euh scientifiques sur la
biodiversité il y en a aussi sur la
géologie d'ailleurs euh sur plein de
plein de questions différentes tout en
euh permettant Deir de fournir
énormément de données euh à des
scientifiques à moindre coût parce qu'on
a pas beaucoup d'argent dans la
recherche et donc ça permet vraiment
d'avoir beaucoup de données à grande
échelle pour répondre à des questions
par que j'allais demander parce que
j'allais demandé à quoi ça sert pour un
chercheur un che une chercheuse d'avoir
plein de gens qui viennent l'emmerder
tranquille dans son labo il connait son
truc et en fait non au contraire c'estil
y a des chercheurs qu' on on même besoin
oui par exemple on a un programme qui
s'appelle oiseaux des jardins où les
particuliers ont juste à compter les
oiseaux qu'il voient dans leur jardin et
depuis sa création il y a 10 ans il y a
plus de 100000 jardins qui ont participé
donc plus de 100000 jardins où il y a eu
des comptages ce qui est impossible à
faire pour un scientifique tout seul
j'avais fait une émission avec la surf
rider fondation qui met des bracelets au
pied des surfurs des nageurs des
plongeurs pour avoir des datas sur la
qualité l'eau et du coup ils ont un
mapage incroyable de la qualité de l'eau
qu' peuvent monitorer quotidiennement
parce que juste des gens vont dans l'eau
donc tant qu'à faire filer un coup de ma
scientifique je viens d'y penser mais ça
fait partie de ces exemples là oui oui
il aussi des exemples sur la qualité de
l'air où on fait fabriquer aux gens des
petits kits qui peuvent mettre à leurs
fenêtre pour mesurer la qualité de l'air
chez eux alors j'allais te demander ça
veut dire que nous tous là là là nous
tous les gens qui nous regardent on peut
aider des scientifiques oui tout le
monde peut participer on a pas besoin
d'un d'un niveau particulier il y a
plein de programmes qui sont ouverts au
débutants après il y a des programmes
qui demandent plus de qualification mais
ce qui est bien c'est que quand on
commence à à s'intéresser ben on se
forme sur le et oui il y a aussi des
formations et bah si je reprends
l'exemple d'oiseaux des jardins en fait
c'est pas très compliqué d'identifier
les oiseaux et de les reconnaître une
fois qu'on a un référentiel des espèces
les plus communes c'est très facile en
fait je suis infoutu de différencier de
Piaf maintenant que tu poses la question
je me rends compte que j'aurais
peut-être besoin de cette formation non
mais en vrai ouais non c'est hyper
intéressant qu'est-ce qui t'a intéressé
toi au départ dans la sciance
participative al moi je travaille sur la
surveillance de la biodiversité et donc
sur l'état des populations animal
végétal et cetera et euh c'est très
compliqué d'avoir des données notamment
dans les outr-mers moi je travaille
surtout sur les outr-mers où en fait il
y a pas forcément autant de scientifique
et cetera et on a très peu de données
sur sur sur ces territoires et il y a
aussi une question de de de
décolonisation un peu de la nature et
cetera c'est que c'est pas à nous
parisiens du Muséum d'aller dans les
territoires leur dire vous devez faire
ça ça ça et donc c'est vrai que les
sciences participatives c'est quelque
chose qu'on met très en avant pour pour
former les gens même dès l'école pour
qu'ils s'intéressent vraiment à la
nature et qui qui prennent les choses en
main vous aussi en tant on parlait tout
à l'heure en tant que créatrice de
contenu le rapport à la communauté c'est
un truc que vous encouragez les gens de
faire toi tu fais un grand oui de la
tête Lenard mais oui on parle de de la
biodiversité les insectes ça a du sens
complètement bah du coup moi ce que j'ai
fait c'est que j'ai essayé de montrer du
coup bah l'application dont tu vas
parler après et des sciences
participatives à mes abonnés et on a
fait une espèce de petite course à celui
qui allait identifier le plus d'espèces
et et du coup c'était assez sympa parce
qu'en plus c'est vachement vachement
communautaire on peut on peut échanger
dessus et et je vois qu'en fait il y a
un engouement si les gens peuvent aider
bon en vrai il y en a plein qui sont
hyper partants quoi et il suffit juste
de leur donner les moyens et souvent
j'ai plein de gens qui me disent ah bah
trop bien j'ai commencé à faire les
insectes et puis je me suis rendue
compte que je connaissais vachement plus
les oiseaux donc j'ai fait les oiseaux
et ah bah j'ai vu que c'était trop bien
j'avais plein de de de plantes chez moi
donc j'ai aussi fait les plantes et au
final bah c'est génial non mais c'est
trop cool et toi Valentine les cailloux
ouais bah tu rigoles mais il y a
effectivement un programme de sciences
participative autour des cailloux qui
s'appelle VG fait par le Muséum national
d'histoire naturelle et j'ai bossé avec
eux effectivement le but c'est tu te
balades et tu vois un affleurement donc
des roches qui affleurent et tu peux les
signaler dans leur cartes en disant oui
ça c'est telle roche je pense machin et
ça aide effectivement les scientifiques
s'en servent après pour cartographier le
patrimoine géologique alors parmi parmi
tous ces programmes dont tu as parlé il
y en a un qui a retenu notre attention
qui s'appelle l'INPN espèce et c'est une
sorte de Pokémon Go de la biodiversité
c'est ça c'est comme un Pokémon Go le
but c'est de voir le plus d'espècesibl
et surtout de les voir dans des endroits
où elles ont pas encore été répertorié
dans nos bases de données donc par
exemple je me promène je vois un oiseau
un insecte n'importe quoi je vais le
prendre en photo le mettre sur
l'application essayer de l'identifier
dans la mesure du possible alors pour
les oiseaux ça peut être assez simple
pour les insectes bah ça peut être vite
plus compliqué donc on peut essayer de
se renseigner sur Internet et cetera si
on sait pas c'est pas grave on peut
juste dire c'est un insecte et après en
fait il y a des experts qui vont valider
l'observation
identifier au mieux si ça pas été fait
donc moi par exemple je valide les
oiseaux on en a je sais pas une centaine
d'observations par jour donc on doit
valider c'est c'est bien la bonne espèce
quiid au moin une fois par jour tu tu
regardes des photos d'oiseaux et tu les
identifies c'est mon petit rituel du
matin en buvant mon café non mais c'est
trop bienah surtout qu'à Paris on en
voit pas beaucoup donc ça fait un peu
voyager en France tous les matins c'est
professeur chaîn des oiseaux en fait
c'est ça professeur cha des oiseaux tu
l'as avec toi l'application parce que
c'est une appli don dont on vous parle
tu nous en fais une démo oui alors je
sais pas si ça marche branché à l'écran
normalement c'est incroyable on est top
de la techno voilà regardez ça apparaît
c'est fou vas-y montre-nous cet appli à
quoi elle ressemble alors donc on a un
accueil avec une présentation un peu de
mes dernières observations on peut
découvrir alors faut choisir une ville
on l'a pas fait mais on peut découvrir
un peu les les animaux les plantes qu'on
a autour de chez nous et donc par
exemple si je veux poster une nouvelle
observation euh je vais sur nouvelle
observation je vais dans mes photos sur
mon téléphone et donc par exemple si
j'ai vu une pi là en venant tout à
l'heure que j'ai pris en photo je
l'ajoute donc j'ajoute une date donc et
la date et l'heure bon on met au hasard
c'est pas très grave là et on met
l'endroit où on l' prise alors soit on
peut localiser exactement là de son
téléphone ou alors on l'indique là je
vais mettre
Paris hop
hop voilà ensuite on peut dire euh le
groupe simple dans lequel auquel il
appartient bon là c'est facile c'est un
oiseau oh j'ai mis ça jusque là je
l'avais jusque là c'est ouais alors le
groupe taxonomique donc la pi ça fait
partie des passer ça
s'appelle c'est dans la même famille que
c'est pas très intuitif que les
maisésanges les moineau et cetera et
ensuite on met le nom d'espèces alors
soit on peut mettre le nom commun soit
on peut mettre le nom latin si on le
connaît alors la pie c'est assez rigolo
son nom latin c'est Pik pica donc la PE
préférance à Pokémon Go
encore voilà la pie bavarde et ensuite
on a juste envoyer l'observation et et
ce sera ce sera validé par des experts
ensuite et alors là jusque là vous
pouvez vous dire bon bah d'accord super
je prends des photos de Piaf et j'
identifie mais en fait non il y a des
quêtes oui il y a a l'application vous
donne des quêtes les gamers alors il y a
des par exemple des gestionnaires
d'espac naturel ou même des villes qui
veulent avoir des informations sur des
espèces ils savent pas si par exemple le
hérisson est présent dans telle ou telle
ville donc si sur les quêtes par exemple
là à Mayotte ils ont lancé une quête
récemment sur les
reptiles il y a aussi là pour pour
l'automne il y a une une quête sur les
champignons où on nous demande de
trouver des des des espèces en
particulier et donc si on trouve ces
espèces en particulier on a des points
en plus ah trop bien oui parce que ce
que j'ai pas dit c'est que dès qu'on
poste une observation on a des points si
on identifie l'espèce correctement et si
c'est une espèce qui a jamais été vu
dans la ville ou dans le département on
a encore plus de points bonus les pour
les gens qui posent la question dans le
chat depuis tout à l'heure l'application
s'appelle
inpn espèce elle est disponible sur
l'App Store sur vos iPhone elle est
disponible sur le Google Play Store pour
vos Android installezla euh c'est trop
trop cool alors vous du coup les
scientifiques une fois que vous avez ça
comment vous travaillez avec comment
vous fonctionnez alors en fait bah
beaucoup on est aussi validateur donc on
voit déjà passer des observations
intéressantes en validant mais également
alors par exemple là il y a des
particuliers qui ont trouver des espèces
de coléoptèes euh qui avaient jamais été
vu dans l'Est de la France c'est deux
espèces on savait pas qu'elles étaient
là-bas et cetera donc déjà c'est super
intéressant pour la distribution des
espèces euh
aussi pour surivre les espèces
envahissantes par exemple le frelon
asiatique ou la la la la perruche à
colier qu'on voit partout dans Paris
c'est super intéressant parce qu'on a
plein de données en fait gratuitement
plein de données qui arrivent et donc
qui permettent de connaître mieux la
distribution de ces espèces vous avez eu
depuis janvier dernier 300000
observations et 24000 contributeurs
l'application a été lancée en 2018 et il
y a 300 experts validateurs comme toi
qui valide et il y a plus de 18000
espèces recensées c'est énorme oui mais
mais ou pas suffisant parce que je t'ai
vu je mais en fait il y a des espèces
par exemple les les oiseaux dans
l'Hexagone on connaît leur distribution
c'est c'est c'est super intéressant mais
ça il y a pas vraiment beaucoup de
nouvelles informations par contre dans
les dans les outr-mers en Guyane par
exemple les oiseaux il y en a plein il y
a plein d'espèces on n' pas
d'information et donc là c'est super
important même sur les plantes même sur
les insectes c'est super important
d'avoir des informations parce que la
base pour protéger une espèce c'est de
savoir où est-ce qu'elle habite où
est-ce qu'elle vit et et voilà quoi si
on n' pas un minimum de connaissance on
peut pas les protéger quelqu'un qui pose
la question de savoir est-ce que ça
marche à l'étranger ou est-ce que c'est
que en France alors c'est que en France
à l'étranger il y a a naturaliste ça
s'appelle et ben voilà il y a quelqu'un
dans le chat qui l'a mis incroyable
merci vous vous êtes formidable euh non
mais c'est c'est c'est vraiment une
application super super intéressante et
ça permet de rendre un service très
direct aux scientifiques ça permet aussi
je suppose bah de enfin de de de
découvrir aussi des insectes des oiseaux
enfin juste si tu as l'app tu fais plus
attention au Piaf que tu croises ouis
complètement et en plus on peut la
combiner si on se on n'est pas très à
l'aise on peut la combiner avec des
applications diaia pour reconnaître les
oiseaux les insectes les plantes et du
coup si on n'est pas forcément très
assuré sur nos nos découvertes et ben on
met la photo d'abord dans une
application Dia qui nous donne une
espèce et là on peut la faire valider
par des experts qui vont du coup de
toute façon vérifier très précisément
quelle est l'espèce et du coup valider
après par la suite donc c'est super on
peut combiner les deux est-ce que la
base de données des résultats est
ouverte oui alors c'est pour ça
j'encourage plutôt à mettre un pseudo si
vous partagez vos observations parce
qu'en fait tout le monde peut voir qui a
été vu et où donc c'est est super
intéressant moi des fois je me dis mince
est-ce que telle espèce elle est là j'ai
pas besoin de demander une extraction de
données compliqué je vais sur le site je
tape l'espèce le lieu bah j'ai
l'information mais voilà niveau niveau
information personnelle mettez un pseudo
si tas pas dit à ton mec que tu en all
en voir un autre et que tu croises un
Piave voilà mets pas ton nom tu prends
la photo ça fait gênant enfin bref voilà
on a compris impressionnant Manon où
est-ce qu'on te retrouve le Muséum
National d'Histoire Naturelle ça ça se
visite ça venez le visiter venez le
visiter merci beaucoup Manon
l'application in PN espèce gratuit à
télécharger sur vos téléphone Lena où
est-ce qu'on te retrouve ta chaîne sur
YouTube Instagram et TikTok et Manon
aussi fait des vidéos sur Instagram elle
l'a pas dit mais elles sont super
intéressantes même sielle en a pas
beaucoup voilà je lu dis et ben tu l'as
pas dit donc Manon c'est quoi ton insta
euh c'est Manon forsteri c'est pas du
tout ça sécrit comment for F o R S T e r
i c'est le nom latin du manch
let's go Manon force St donc on te
retrouve sur insta et ben écoute c'est
super donc toi scarbet on l'a dit sur
les réseaux sociaux qui vont bien
Valentine on te retrouve vous science de
comptoir non c'est pas ça la question
sur Youtube YouTube science de comptoir
ouais YouTube Twitter Instagram TikTok
twitch ouais voilà et l'émission
d'artescope l'émission d'artescope
réalisé par notre Nicolas national qui
réalise cette émission Nicolas qui
réalise backed qui réalise également
l'émission scope merci beaucoup à toutes
les trois un tur d'applaudissement chers
amis on va se mettre un générique et on
va enchaîner avec le début de notre
émission backit à tout de
[Applaudissements]
suite bonsoir à toutes et à tous bonsoir
bienvenue sur
backsat bonsoir chers amis très heureux
de vous retrouver en direct sur ce
plateau extraordinaire on va parler de
politique on va parler des sujets de la
semaine on va jouer à des jeux débiles
on va avoir la vie d'adè et on va
recevoir notre invité politique dans la
deuxième partie de l'émission il s'agira
du président du groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée nationale ancien
secrétairegénéral adjoint de l'Élysée
sous François Hollande Boris Valo mais
avant ça on va discuter avec les plus
belles et les plus beaux des
chroniqueuses et des chroniqueurs on est
avec Antoine salut Antoine salut Jean
comment tu vas bah écoute ça va bien ça
fait plaisir d'être là mais ouais ça
fait plaisir de te retrouver tes
doctorants en sciences politiques
directeur de l'observatoire de l'opinion
de l'Institut jean- jorè exactement et
ben ça fait ça fait vraiment plaisir de
te voir on est aussi avec Léa ça va Léa
coucou ça roule ouais ouais ouais ouais
Léa tu es journaliste tu es fondatrice
du média popo tout à fait pople qui a
besoin de vous je vous le dis comme ça
vite fait je place je fais le placement
de produit r mais fais tout suite fais
le rapidos popul est en cours de levé de
fond tout à fait jusqu'à fin octobre
donc si jamais vous avez 5 balles à
claquer vous pouvez donner quatre balles
à backit un bal à popole ou bon bref ou
l'inverse vous faites comm voulez mais
vous voulez merci je PAP Paul est un
média féministe tout à fait un média
politique qui propose un regard
féministe sur la vie politique c'est
plus précis que ça à retrouver sur
kiskis b b si je dis pas de conneries
tout à fait et sur toutes les
plateformes qui vont bien pour retrouver
les podcast la newsletter sur Kessel
tout ça tout ça et bientôt un site
internet si vous le voulez bien grâce au
financement participatif et ça fait
plair de voir Léa sur le plateau de
backit On est avec Malek aussi salut
tout le monde tu vas bien Malec ça va et
toi bah écoute ça roule Malec toi tu es
conseiller en communication politique tu
es chroniqueur et tu es le fondateur du
podcast autour de moi c'est vrai qui a
enfin lancé qui vient de sortir premier
épisode la semaine dernière et des
retours incroyables la commu B qui était
là ah ouais ils ontoui j'ai reçu des
messages c'était trop cool merci encore
ce podcast représente nous alors c'est
la première discussion on va demander à
nos invités de pas parler deux mais de
parler de ceux qui sont autour d'eux le
premier épisode était avec la
journaliste nine SLA sorti la semaine
dernière le deè épisode avec Agath oprou
la semaine prochaine euh et voilà
agathprou qui était ma collègue à la
télévision chroniqueuse animatrice à la
télévision qui a sorti un bouquin à la
suite de son cancer elle va nous
expliquer que le mot cancer n'est pas un
gros mot OK et qu'il faut qu'il faut le
dire sans aucune gêne et ça va être
archi intéressant donc ça c'est pour le
prochain épisode et ben merci à vous
trois d'être avec nous ça vous va si on
parle de politique oui ben on a un pe
moi je vouais parler de toi d'abord
comment vas-tu jeanétait comment le
festival Paul enchill c'était très très
cool merci à toute qui est venue ouais
ouais tu as loupé ça Malek était là
heureusement que Malec était là on a
fait une on a fait une journée
extrêmement chill et extrêmement
politique parce que bah une succession
de table ronde dans laquelle j'ai encore
plus brusqué mes invités que d'habitude
parce que là ils étaient dans des dans
des [__] de transat et vraiment ils
all j'ai vu des images dans
transonique c'est complètement
anachronique ils étaient en mode what
the fuck et en même temps bah ils sont
pliés au jeu mes invités on a eu des
tables rondes fascinantes sur l'union de
la gauche sur la droite sur l'Union
européenne sur les médias sur les
institutions cinq sujets qui moi me
passionnent et CIN sujets sur lequel bah
du coup ouais non j'ai j'ai eu des j'ai
eu des invités passionnants et surtout
dans le bar bah voilà les gens étaient
là avec leur lunettes de soleil Paul
enchill on a bu des cous on a fait la
teuf et même Émilien warvial qui est un
collègue ami doctorant avec un super
polo jaune et noir et même un chapeau de
paille et ça quand même c'était quand
même asse milien warvial j'étais super
content de l'avoir il est absolument
passionnant il a effectivement sans rien
personne lui demande quoi que ce soit il
a pris un chapeau de paille il a fait
vas-y je suis dans le thème bat les
couilles on avait des députés de droite
avec des des colliers de fleurs mais
pareil je sais pas c'est CLA la chef de
projet qui arrivé avant qu'il rentre sur
SC vouz prendre ils ont fait d'accord de
tout façon cé tellement what the fuck
tout le monde avec des lunettes soleil
comme ça tout mond en train de boire des
coup et tout ils ont dit je sais pas où
on est mais du coup ils ont mis un
[__] de collier de fleurs et après la
question c'est ça veut dire quoi de
droite et il répondait à cette question
avec à coler de fleurs j'étais en mode
ok c'est pa ch c'est exactement ce que
je voulais créer céit vraiment la
rencontre du trisème type mais non
c'était c'était vraiment très très
coolah bravo donc ouais non merci à toi
bon allez c'est parti on parle de
politique c'est parti pour les sujets de
la semain ouis on va pas y
échapper
alors les sujets de cette semaine en
politique chers amis ça a commencé fort
lundi 2 octobre ce lundi il y a eu une
réunion de tous les chefs presque tous
les chefs de parti de la nupes pour
discuter de l'avenir de cette alliance
électorale à gauche fun fact cette
réunion a eu lieu dans un bar qui
s'appelle le bellucis le bellucis est un
bar à Paris qui est un bar historique de
la France insoumiss puisque c'est c'est
là qu'en 2017 les insoumis ont ont ont
fait leur soirée électorale euh et donc
dans la mythologie insoumis c'est un bar
important mais c'est aussi le bar dans
lequel bxseit avait fait sa première
émission en publicou avec un invité
insoumis qui s'appelait qui s'appelle
toujours Adrien catnins et qui était
venu sur le plateau nous jurer s' qui
s'appelait qui voilà qui était venu sur
le plateau obellucis nous jurer que
jamais il y aura d'union de la gauche
dans ce pays les insoumis ne signeront
jamais avec les socialistes et cetera et
un an et demi plus tard bah laanupes
était née entre-temps et un an et demi
plus tard c'est dans ce même bar que se
retrouve à nouveau du coup les les
parties prenantes de la nuupes pour
discuter de de C de l'avenir de cette
nupesse et l'avenir de cette nupess ça
va être le point d'interrogation puisque
euh bah voilà marine Tondelier la chef
des écolo après un suspense a déclaré
qu'elle n'irait pas donc elle n'y est
pas allée lundi elle était attendue elle
ne s'y est pas présenté Olivier fort le
patron des socialistes y est allé il a
été applaudi par les militants insoumis
au CR de Olivier avec nous mais en
arrivant il a été assez euh cche en
disant il faut je je je je je je je cite
ces mots il a déclaré qu'il ne fait il
ne fallait pas poursuivre ce feuilleton
délétaire en actant le fait que LV et le
PCF étaient en dehors de l' AR il ne
faut pas poursuivre ce feuilleton
délétaire donc voilà ouais clairement il
était venu à un enterrement plus
qu'autre chose et manuel bonpard donc le
le le le patron de la de la France
insoumise de l'organe de l'organisation
de la France insoumise avait écrit avant
dès le dès le 29 septembre qu'il
regrettait la décision de Fabien
Roussell de je cite quitter laanupes du
coup ma question je vous la pose très
cache à tous les trois est-ce que c'est
fini laanupes Malek
je me pose la question j'ai pas la
réponse j'aimerais te la donner mais
pour le coup on est on a on a parlé de
l'acte 2 de l'anupes qui devait arriver
bon bah là tout le monde dit est
contraint il faut savoir est-ce que
cette décision de partir en ordre
dispersé pour les européennes acte la
fin de la nuupest la fin des
fininiinitive ou est-ce qu'on est sur un
acte 2 et on se projette sur 2000 sur
2027 et en discutant du pourquoi du
comment et avec qui euh on n'insulte pas
on ninsulte pas ses partenaires quand on
veut faire union avec eux d'un côté et
euh et on arrête de de de vouloir
ventter laaky France avec des
propositions tout aussi ridicules les
unes que les autres big up à Fabien
Roussel donc il y a il y a un petit peu
à tout le enfin tout le monde doit
mettre un petit peu d'eau dans son vin
et moi je suis surtout c'est pour ça que
c'est très bien d'avoir Boris valallo
comme invité aujourd'hui je suis très
curieux de savoir parce qu'en réalité ça
se passe plus ou moins bien entre les
groupes à l'Assemblée dans le travail au
quotidien il y a des groupes de il y a
des groupes de travail au sein de la
nuupes qui fonctionneent bien euh est-ce
que les partis ne vont pas tuer l'Union
à l'assemblé nationale c'est la vraie
question ça on va en discuter tout à
l'heure mais sur l'anecdote que tu
racontais effectivement àul enchill
samedi dernier et vous retrouverez la
vidéo on a fait une table ronde sur la
gauche son union sa désunion et on avait
Léon des fontaines la tête de liste PCF
pour les élections européennes qui
défend l'autonomie du PCF pour ces
élections là et même en général et Manon
auri ancienne tête de liste en 2019 qui
défend elle l'Union et effectivement ils
ont eu ce dialogue un peu un peu tendu
mais c'est c'était attendu et elle elle
a parlé de manori faisait le l'extrait
en parlant de des relations d'amour
Hamour Chen et tout et Léon des fontaine
lui a dit bah quand on quand on a une
relation d'amour on traite pas son
amoureux de nazi ce à quoi elle a
répondu tac au tac ouais et on jure pas
à son amoureux qu'on sera plus ensemble
dans 3 ans et leschang j'étaent enfin
moi j'étais en animation de table ronde
j'étais en mode ok un partout là
clairement ça joue l'arbitre a pas
sifflé c'est validé des deux côtés et
c'est effectivement un peu ce que tu as
dit on a aussi Daniel Simonet B qui l'a
dit au micro d' LCP parce qu'elle sait
pas que l'actualité se passe sur
backseat mais on lui en veut pas qui a
dit qu'elle qu'elle soutenait pas forcé
les prises de position de de sopia
Chikirou entre autres pour attaquer les
partenaires l'entend Léa est-ce que
l'anupes c'est mort
alors est-ce que Laan est morte non
alors je pense pas je suis d'accord avec
ce que disait malac par rapport au à la
réalité en fait du travail au quotidien
là effectivement laanupes est en train
de préparer au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale on aura l'occasion de de voir
ça avec Monsieur vot un contrebudget
quand même c'est assez important une
contreprosition un contre LF en quelque
sorte donc c'est pas rien euh il y a
effectivement des initiatives on a le
sentiment en tout cas que ça semble
tenir euh dans les institutions dans une
certaine mesure sur le plan médiatique
et sur le plan national on a
l'impression que ça patine énormément ça
c'est sûr a raison hein puisque
effectivement les les signaux ne sont
pas forcément très positifs en en
matière de de d'union eu après il faut
aussi voir ce que c'était je veux dire
c'est euh à la base c'était une alliance
de circonstances pour des élections
législative c'est très précis c'estàdire
que ces partis ne sont pas arrivés à se
mettre d'accord sur un accord de
gouvernement un programme de
gouvernement si sont mis d'accord pour
la présidentielle ah oui autant pour la
présidentielle qui était quand même
l'élection clé et quand ils ont vu
qu'ils avaient chié dans la colle bah du
coup ils sont dit autant essayer de
rattraper le tir avec avec législative
mais parce que ça a arrangé tout le
monde là ce qu'on constate c'est que les
élections européennes n'intéresse pas
forcément comment dire enfin on sait que
c'est pas forcément dans l'intérêt de
tous les partis de gauche de faire
alliance mécaniquement pour pour des
résultats euh on sait que c'est dans
l'intérêt de la France enoumise donc on
n'est pas surpris que c'est eux qui
enfin que ce soit eux qui sont en train
de pousser et de forcer dans ce sens euh
par ailleurs la prochaine échéance
électorale après ça ce sera les
municipales et même chose les partis
n'ont pas vraiment l'intérêt en tout cas
les partis qui sont majoritaires dans la
dans l'implantation territoriale et la
plus forte raison euh le Parti
Socialiste n'a pas vraiment d'intérêt en
fait de faire élection ça dépend des
villes ça dépend ouais mais je suis
d'accord avec toi peu tu vois
globalement d'ailleurs ce qui s'est
passé pour les scénatoriales certains
certains candidats sont partis avec
l'étiquette certains candidats et les
filles sont partis avec l'étiquette
nupes et ça a foutu un sacrébol parce
qu'il disait bah en fait non vous ne
pouvez pas faire ça il y avait pas
d'accord et cetera donc un accord de
circonstan
euh qui demeure un accord de
circonstance en fonction aussi des des
des textes parce qu'on a vu qu'il y
avait pas forcément une voie commune non
plus pendant la réforme des retrait on
va voir ce qui va se passer sur le PG à
l'immigration mais je crains que les
choses ne soient pas aussi évidentes que
ce qu'on que que certains laisser
entendre donc voilà c'est
finalement c'est un
peu un fuck friend quoi on va revenir
sur sur repr ouais c'est ça ouais genre
si on doit reprendre la métaphore de la
relation amoureuse moi je dirais que
c'est un peu ça quoi j'adore c'est
exactement ça c'est vraiment parfait
ouais c'est vraiment des c'est un plan
cul
laanupesse Antoine est-ce que laanupesse
est morte une jolie comparaison va
enchaîner on posera la question à Boris
Vallo on verra comment il réagit
finalement l'ANP est-ce que c'est pas
votre best friend
le je pense que tout va dépendre des
résultats des européennes finalement par
que en fait si tu te retrouves au moment
des européennes avec le RN et le la
macronie est hyper enfin hyper loin
devant tous les autres parties de gauche
tu peux avoir voir finalement une une
certaine pression à l'Union pour la pour
la prochaine séquence électorale majeure
qui est la la présidentielle de et les
législatives de 2027 c'est un peu
finalement le la seule option où je vois
le laanupè perdurer et qu'il y a un
candidat unique de la gauche au moment
de la présidentielle de 2027 mais sinon
ce qui est certain c'est que là on est
vraiment dans une situation où tout le
monde est en train de se tirer dans les
pattes c'était pas tant le cas que ça il
y a encore un il a encore un an mais
plus les mois évoluent plus on a
l'impression que c'est quelque chose qui
est en train de de vraiment être mis à
mal en même temps c'est intéressant
parce que cette discussion nous fait
nous réinterroger sur qu'est-ce que
c'était qu'est-ce que c'est ou qu'est-ce
que c'était j'en sais rien je sais pas
siil faut en parler au passé de que
cette nupes toi tu parles d'un accord de
circonstances pour les élections
législatives je suis pas loin d'être
d'accord avec toi parce que moi j'ai
aussi pour l'examen de certain texte
mais c'était mais justement c'est qu'en
fait la circonst en fait c'est c'est
parfois il y a des erreurs d'analyse sur
la sur ce quiétait cl nupes enfin des
erreurs d'analyse en tout cas des
analyses avec lesquel je suis pas
d'accord la nuupes n'est pas n'a pas été
une invention de la France mise qui du
jour au lendemain s'est dit tiens je
vais sauver le PS le PC et les écolos
non mais c'est le P l'invers c'est le PS
le PC lescol c'est pas non plus le PS le
PC les écolos qui se sont dit tiens
finalement Mélenchon il est sympa après
lui avoir craché à la gueule pendant
toute la présid c'était la seule
solution de garder leur siège finalement
mais c'est ça pour les uns comme pour
les autres c'était une nécessité d'où le
caractère circonstantiel où en fait ils
ont joué le jeu non pas parce qu'ils
sont mis à en avoir envie mais parce que
c'était un besoin vital pour les uns et
politique pour les autres l F est passé
de 17 à plus de 80 députés grâce à
laanupes et les socialistes les
communistes et les écolos ont eu des
groupes à l'Assemblé nationale grâce à
laanupes aussi parce qu'en échange de ça
c'était pas la dispersion des voies à
gauche et cetera c'était l'effondrement
total de la gauche à l'Assemblée
nationale non mais clairement mais je
pense qu'il faut quand même pas négliger
aussi l'aspect que la désunion est
uniquement sur des questions
stratégiques parce que sur le fond alors
certes tu as des points de divergence et
cetera mais c'est des points de
divergence qui avait réussi à être réglé
en l'espace de 3 jours entre la
présidentielle et législative oui mais
parce que il s'inscrivait pas forcément
dans une réalité en fait c'était juste
un programme qu' n'avait pas à tenir tu
vois s'ils avaient dû réellement
gouverner ces points de divergence
auraient leur éclaté à la gueule comme
c'est le cas sur le fait qu'ils arrivent
pas à s'accorder sur certains votes
quand même dans la plupart des cas tu tu
as une convergence majeure mais même au
Parlement européen tu dans dans plus de
80 % des cas ils votent de la même
manière je pense que c'est pas forcément
là-dessus mais quand tu regardes le PC
qui s'en va c'est parce que il ve enfin
ils veulent pouvoir avoir plus de sièges
de leur manière ELV le pourquoi ils vont
seul aux européennes bah c'est aussi
parce qu'ils se disent que là ils vont
avoir plus de sièges et qu'il faut
équilibrer les rapports de force à
gauche et que s'il y a une union ça doit
être une union qui l'aurait plus
favorable que ce qui était le cas au
moment où ça a été fait pour les
législatives donc finalement tu as un
peu l'impression que c'est quand même
plus des considérations de jeux
politiques des enjeux stratégiques qui
sont à l'origine des divergences et
quand tu enfin si tu te place dans la
peau d'un électeur de gauche qui est pas
forcément le plus politisé tu vois ça tu
as juste envie de rester chez toi je
pense qu'il y a vraiment des grosses
divergences sur le plan idéologique
aussi mais qui avait déjà été enfin qui
avait été acté dans la discussion en
réalité un petit peu tu vois là il se
déchire sur des sur des purement sur un
point de vue stratégique et c'est archi
intéressant cet été je me suis fait un
petit petit moment nostalgieque gauche
pluriel et j'étais en train de réécouter
une interview de de Lionel Jospin on
occupe son été comme on peut d'accord
mais mais tu un très bon programme d'été
tu veux faire d'autres et c'est Lionel
Jospin qui disait on lui demandé l'année
dernière de réagir à la nupes il dit oui
mais on a quand même demandé à des
parties de faire en 3 semaines ce que
nous on a fait en 2 ou 3 ans et et bah
en réalité peut-être qu'on est un peu en
train de payer ce ce ce rush moi après
je je je rappelle que je soutenais
l'initiative de la primaire populaire et
donc cette union là ce travail en amont
cette discussion là je l'appelis depuis
longtemps bon benah elle est pas arrivée
et peut-être qu'on est en train de payer
ce le fait d'avoir d'avoir été trop vite
je sais pas est-ce que c'est si grave
que ça par c'est aussi le truc là je je
on on est en train de parler d'un
cadavre et cetera l'impression que c'est
la fin de la gauche et tout est-ce que
euh est-ce que la nupes va empêcher la
gauche de faire un score cumulé
intéressant aux élections européennes
est-ce que la nupes va empêcher la
gauche d'exister à l'Assemblée nationale
parce qu'il y a un côté maintenant que
les élections législatives sont passées
les jeux sont faits pour 5 ans euh
maintenant que enfin les élections
européennes n'ont pas encore eu lieu
mais on va voir on va voir quel quels
vont être les scores qui vont être faits
par les uns et par les autres euh et
tout va être rebalancé effectivement sur
les municipales puis sur la
présidentielle donc finalement est-ce
que est-ce que c'est pas trop tôt pour
crier à la mort de laanupes bah c'est
juste qu'on est à nouveau en 2019 quoi
tu te retrouves exactement dans la dans
la même situation qu'à l'époque c'est tu
fais un un pas en arrière de de 5 ans et
tu te dis bah peut-être que on va on va
enfin il va y avoir une pression au
moment de la de la présidentielle pour
qu'il y ait une union à nouveau en fait
le truc c'est que l'Union elle était là
donc le si ça avait pu perdurer ça
aurait pas été plus mal oui c'est
dommage parce qu'en fait au lieu de
capitaliser finalement sur un moment
assez fort sur des méthodes de travail
aussi enfin collective euh sur sur des
des enfin sur sur une stratégie
finalement aussi collective je veux dire
là ils auraient dans l'absolu 4 ans pour
préparer la suite et effectivement
peut-être enfin peut-être y aller en en
marche un peu dispersée pour les
européennes et et les municipales mais
en tout cas se concentrer sur là où
l'union fait la force c'est-à-dire euh
bon bah les les les les les les
élections législatives et l'élection
présidentiell donc on est vraiment en
train de perdre du temps moi je pense
que c'est grave dans le sens où
finalement l'alternative à gauche aurait
pu se construire et pourrait encore se
construire et que finalement il y a un
peu du gâi pour des raisons
essentiellement d'ego voilà et de
personnees parce que c'est quand même ça
aussi qu'il faut qu'il faut soulever euh
c'est grave dans le sens où ég de je
personne oh un petit peu quand même
quand tu prends Jean-Luc Mélenchon
Fabien Rousel je je voilà peut-être mon
analyse personnelle he ça n'engage que
moi mais oui oui j'en suis quasiment
intimement convaincu oui oui tout à fait
à mon avis ça joue un tout petit peu
dans la dans l'équation ouais ouais
chouya chouya mais quand même et tout ça
pour dire que quand même l'élection donc
on prépare le terrain la deuxième force
politique du pays actuellement et elle
est en train de s'installer avec une
alternative à gauche qui est inexistante
qui est en train de se tirer dans les
pattes constamment qui ne montre pas un
visage uni notamment sur la réforme des
retraite alors qu'il y avait un momentum
à saisir et il y a eu un échec total làd
enfin quand même tu vois forite la
gauche était unie ça conduit B non pas
tant que ça tu vois on en discutera avec
d'ailleurs enfin c'était pas si fou quoi
enfin désolé mais il y avait un moment
très fort où tout le monde était plus ou
moins d'accord où le peuple était
d'accord je veux dire ils avent peuple
de gauche mais même tu vois un peuple
qui est finalement SAU d'EM et CETA
facile de de le ramener et là en
l'occurrence il y a eu un échec à mon
avis il y a eu de la structuration
évidemment sur sur le mouvement militant
et cetera mais ça ne s'est pas vérifié
au sein des partis politiques deuxième
chose il ne faut pas négliger non plus
les élections européennes parce que si
la gauche arrive en marche dispersée et
qui a effectivement un front qui
n'arrive pas à se structurer le deuxième
parti français au sein de l'Union
européenne qui représente la France ce
sera le rassemblement national c'est
dramatique je veux dire c'est un pays
enfin c'est quand même un parti
eurosceptique dans des finalement une
une année très nière qui est l'année
2024 sur laquelle l'Union européenne est
en train de travailler sur justement la
réforme de la question des migration au
sein de l'Union européenne on se
retrouve déjà avec suffisamment à mon
sens de gouvernement d'extrême droite et
de représentants d'extrême droite au
sein du Parlement européen donc la
gauche a une énorme responsabilité à ne
pas bouder cette élection et à faire en
sorte vraiment de de de bah de de gagner
et de et de conserver une place dne de
so quoi euh il y a quand même dans ces
négociations qui ont lieu en ce moment à
au sein des partis de laanupes un
élément intéressant c'est les jeunes les
jeunes des partis de laanupes plaident
pour pour une grande partie d'entre eux
à l'exception des des communistes pour
l'Union quit parfois à se fâcher avec
leurs aînés du coup il se il se dit
qu'une des stratégies de de la France
insoumise ayant échoué à faire union
avec les partis c'est de déposer une
liste aux élections européennes d'union
des jeunes euh qui en verrait le double
message aux électeurs de gauche de notre
liste c'est celle de l'Union et en plus
c'est celle des jeunes donc il y a deux
raisons absolument extraordinaire de
voter pour cette liste là ça supposerait
par contre que des jeunes de laanupes
fassent sescessions avec leur parti et
j'ai du mal à imaginer les jeunes
socialistes et les jeunes écologiste se
barrait de leur parti mais ceci étant je
me suis mis à imaginer en préparant
cette émission je me suis dit attends il
y a un monde dans lequel ils font une
liste d'union une liste unitaire à
dépaut à dépaut d'être une liste d'union
que cette liste fait un score pas
dégueulasse voir même qu'elle arrive en
tête et que dans la foulée les jeunes de
la nuupes décident de se séparer y
compris de la fille pour créer leur
propre parti de la nuupes avec des
élections tu vas trop loin marrant mais
faites ça les jeunes sele question moi
moi je suis je suis chaud he là-dessus
mais la seule question que je te pose
c'est avec quel tune quoi mais avec
l'énergie du désespoir voilà tout de
suite est chiante parce que tu dans
participatif c'est ça que donner à poul
et après on en reparle l'ancien jeune
l'ancien jeune socialiste que je suis
peut te dire que le les jeunes
socialistes sont autonome ils se sont
battus pour cette autonomie euh c'était
en 93 avec Benois amont mais ceux qui
les finan c'est le Parti socialiste
c'est ça ouiou aussi je me souvens du
discours on la prenait par cœur au MJS
et tout ouais ouais c'est faux c'est
pour çai genre avec quel tune quoi non
mais c'est enfin oui c'est une question
de pognon mais c'est aussi une question
d'envie politique c'est une question de
réponse aux aspirations du peuple de
gauche et cetera je je je sais pas si
demain il y a une initiative qui naî
issu d'un mouvement de jeunes qui décide
de prendre mais enfin faut se rendre
compte des bolocs qu'il faut avoir faut
s'engueuler avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
Fabien Roussell marine Tondelier et
Olivier fort en leur disant niquez-vous
tous les quatre on va faire notre propre
parti unitaire de notre côté
exile et puis je vous rappelle qu'il y a
déjà des jeunes qui ont tenté un truc
comme ça ça s'app la primère populaire
il ét ISS du mouvement climat voilà vous
vous souvenez de comment ils ont été
reçus par les insoumis enfin tu vois il
y a un moment je pour ça que c'est full
de la politique fiction ce que je suis
en train de dire mais qu'il a un monde
dans lequel je sais
pas il y a des indiscrétions dans la
presse qui nous parlent de cette liste
d'union qui serait mené donc par Manon
auri avec Benoît Amon dans cette liste
là moi ta fiction moi toute façon je ve
toujours croire un petit peu à fiction
on sait
jamais quoi je pense que ça du panache
et puis franchement je vais dire je je
sais pas si en face Olivier fort marine
Tondelier et cetera vont aller tche
leurs jeunes de du parti pour cette
initiative là je te le dis pas si sûr
que ça
j'avoue non mais e e voilà vous le parti
vous l'appelez faire mieux voilà non
mais je faites ce que vous voulez vous
l'appelez faire mieux et c'est les
jeunes de la nupeste qui créent leur
propre organisation avec un congrès avec
des tendances avec mais tu es en train
de faire un coup d'état en fait là pas
les couill au point où j'en suis j'en ai
rien à [__] mais euh va avoir des
problèmes j'en ai déjà [__] mais bref
on va continuer évidemment à analyser
l'avenir de la nu Pest sur ce plateau
vous en doutez on en parlera tout à
l'heure avec notre
invité Boris Valot qui sera avec nous
tout à l'heure deuxième sujet
d'actualité dont on voulait parler c'est
un anniversaire c'est le mien non pas du
tout c'est anniversaire Jean ouais merci
beaucoup mais non on voulait parler de
l'anniversaire de la Constitution ah Jo
anniversaire la Constitution
anniversaire la Constitution 65 ans
c'est pas tout jeune 65 ans la 5e
République le 4 octobre 1958 était
proclamé la la la 65
58 65 ans bah c'est la retraite il faut
arrêter la
5è elle est elle est bonne elle est
bonne elle a déjà été faite elle est
très bien non non elle est très très
bien effectivement 65 ans plus tout de
cédent la 5e République donc cet
anniversaire a été fêté ça va ça va je
fais ce que je veux la la cet
anniversaire a été célébré hier au
Conseil constitutionnel ou d'autes ou
d'autres estce qu'
c'est le le panif de ta vie quoi et ben
attends il y avait du il y avait du
binge il y avait Laurent Fabius et il y
avait Emmanuel Macron le président de la
République en personne c'est bien ce est
venu prononcer un discours qui était qui
était assez attendu qui qui était assez
attendu Emmanuel Macron donc a profité
de cet anniversaire pour annoncer des
souhaits qui étaient les siens pour une
évolution des institutions il a parlé
d'une réforme de l'article 11 sur le
référendum sur les loi une référendum du
référendum une réforme du référendum
d'initiative partagé pour le rendre plus
accessible parce que aujourd'hui il ne
l'est pas une un élargissement des
possibilités de faire des référendums il
l'avait déjà dit une révision des
statuts de la Corse et de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie pour ouvrir la voie à
plus d'autonomie suite donc au processus
de des accords de matigon et Suisse aux
discussions qu'il avait eu avec les cors
à l'occasion de la loi sur le sur le pas
l'autonomie justement mais la en si si
si remarque le mot avait été prononcé à
l'époque par le Cornus je m'en souviens
très bien l'inscription du droit à l'IVG
dans la Constitution
euh et euh voilà je crois la possibilité
d'inscrire la protection du climat dans
la constitution voilà c'était ça les
réformes c'était ça les propositions
qu'il fait en l'état actuel ben c'est
une super proposition que nous fait
Emmanuel Macron mais ouais c'est TR
proposition de gauche ouais ouais ouais
et puis en plus ah bah ouais ouais et
puis ce qui est cool c'est qu'en fait il
refait une proposition qui fait déjà
depuis genre presque des années
désormais sur l'IVG dans la Constitution
alors entre tempemps ça a été voté par
le Parlement par une loi
constitutionnelle par une un une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle il
avait promis que le gouvernement allait
à nouveau s'en saisir de sorte à ce que
ça passe par un congrès non pas par le
référend précisément parce qu'en fait
quand il s'agit d'une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle la Constitution
n'offre qu'une seule possibilité à
savoir uniquement réviser la
Constitution à travers le vote du peuple
donc le recours au référendum lorsqu'il
s'agit d'un projet de loi
constitutionnel d'ailleurs aucune
proposition de loi constitutionnelle n'a
abouti hein jusqu'à aujourd'hui jusqu'à
celle sur l'IVG a été adopté elle a pas
abouti encore elle pas voté dans les
mêmes termes par les de chambres d'une
part et il faudrait qu'elle soit soumise
à référendum par ailleurs pour vraiment
réformer la Constitution tandis que que
le projet de loi constitutionnel permet
soit effectivement de solliciter le
peuple soit de solliciter le congrès
réuni en 35e à Versailles donc le le
Parlement Assemblée nationale et Sénat
en fait les les associations féministes
avait avait pointé du doigt le la
difficulté que de recourir au référendum
dans le cas de de l'IVG concernant
notamment les les moyens très très
importants dont disposent les antichoix
quiut des campagnes de désinformation
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux sur
Internet et cetera depuis des décennies
donc il y avait ce risque aussi de se
retrouver dans une campagne de
désinformation assez importante le 8
mars le jour de de la journée
internationale des droits des femmes
Emmanuel Macron avait promis de
reprendre à son compte donc que
l'exécutif se saisisse de cette question
ce qui implique nécessairement un projet
de loi donc voilà nous ça j'ai le
sentiment que en tout cas les
associations féministes et moi par
ailleurs qu'on se fait un peu mener en
bateau puisque désormais ce droit enfin
cette proposition sera inscrite dans une
réforme vraisemblablement plus globale l
oui euh quid aussi de la capacité à
faire adopter une telle réforme mais qui
va la voter en fait en fait c'est ça la
question c'està dire que là en l'état
actuel des choses si on fait la liste de
ce que je viens de dire c'est dur pour
la gauche de pas la voter cette cette
réforme ou alors sur l'argument de ça ne
va pas assez loin donc on ne soutient
pas mais est-ce que c'est c'est un peu
le jeu du tu préfères oui mais tu sais
préfère la République ou ou ou à défaut
tu un chemin intermédiaire entre les
deux est-ce qu'une réforme de est-ce que
est-ce que une anè réforme de la
constitution de la 5e République qui
remettrait plus de démocratie serait
suffisante Antoine mais honnêtement ça
va vraiment pas assez loin sur l'aspect
démocratique c'est-à-dire que je je
regarder le le les chiffres avant de
venir c'est en terme de de préférence
pour les différents types de régimes
politiques tu te rends compte que la
préférence pour la démocratie
représentative c'est 45 % de la
population préférence pour la démocratie
directe c'est 40 % et préférence pour
des formes d'autorité plus autoritaire
c'est 15 % et chez les moins de 35 ans
c'est la démocratie direct qui arrive
devant la démocratie représentative donc
ok davantage l'utilisation du référendum
d'initiative partagé pourquoi pas pas
mal mais ça va quand même pas assez loin
en terme de de de de demande
démocratique et là où c'est dangereux
c'est que tu te rends compte que quand
les aspirations démocratiques de la
population elles sont pas prises
suffisamment en compte mais là tu peux
avoir un vrai retour de l'autoritarisme
et dans les dernières données qu'on a on
voit queà la question la démocratie est
le meilleur système possible elle est
irremplaçable ça a baissé de 5 points et
c'est plus seulement il y a plus que de
tiers de la population qui est d'accord
avec cette idée làà donc à force de de
de pas prendre en compte finalement C
ces vraies demandes de démocratie et
davantage de participation directe sans
passer forcément par des
élus finalement il y a quand même une
frustration qui grandit et qui peut être
assez dangereuse Malek je me suis posé
la question je ne suis pas du tout
député et je ne souhaite pas l'être mais
si j'avais été député ou sénateur
qu'est-ce que j'avais enfin quelle
aurait été ma mon avis est-ce que je
voote la l'inscription devg dans la la
Constitution alors qu'à côté parce que
on nous parle d'élargissement des
domaines sur le référendum mais on nous
dit pas quoi mais on a bel et bien
compris que ça allait être un petit peu
l'immigration pour pas dire totalement
l'immigration pour faire plaisir à la
droite et pour que la droite finisse par
voter cette réforme consti ça l'article
11 ouais donc en fait est-ce que je vote
euh l'inscription de l'IVG avec
l'élargissement à la la question à la
question migratoire et on on nous parle
de l'élargissement aussi de pardon de l'
baissement du seuil pour le le
référendum d'initiative partagé combien
on sait pas voilà donc
c'est c'est un peu de la branlette en
fait cette réforme constitutionnelle les
choses mais c'est mais c'est c'est ça va
être ça enfin c'est le en même temps
d'Emmanuel Macron qui va placer à peu
près tous les acteurs face à le
responsabilité pour flinguer tout le
monde à droite comme à gauche bah pour
flinguer je sais pas si c'est pour
flinguer mais le fait que ça ça gêne aux
entournures effectivement la gauche qui
veut bien livger la Constitution mais ça
l'emmerde d'élargir la question
référendaire verss vers l'immigration et
la droite inversement qui veut bien de
faire des référendum sur l'immigration
par contre qui V dans la Constitution
moins chaud bah le Sénat il a quand même
voté le Sénat TER très restrictif hein
qui moi me satisfait pas mais le Sénat a
quand même fini par voter donc c'est
vrai que la droite a fait un petit bout
de chemin donc il y a quand même un
accord sur le fond effectivement sur
l'IVG pour le coup sur la gauche non
effectivement l'immigration au
référendum c'est c'est non Emmanuel
Macron nous avait dit qu'il voulait
faire autrement qu'il avait compris en
202 22 l'élection oui voilà il a été élu
dans des conditions qui étaient très
spécifiques différentes de 2017 et qui
voulait faire autrement qu'il avait
compris cette demande de de plus de
démocratie de de reconnaissance
aujourd'hui dans le vote du scrutin on n
est pas on est à côté total il y a pas
de réponse à ça est-ce que il y a de la
place pour la discussion euh sur ces
propositions est-ce que est-ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron veut innover aussi
dans la méthode pour élaborer pour
élaborer cette réforme constitutionnelle
est-ce qu'on va retomber dans un comité
baladure comme en 2008 avec que des
sages autour d'une table et on attend la
fumée blanche pour que les sages nous
disent regarde c'est ça qu'il faut faire
est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron va se diriger
vers un format de type grand débat ou de
type saisine du saiseux ou de type j'en
sais rien je sais pas est-ce que c'est
pas l'occasion il a déjà innové par le
passé est-ce que c'est pas pas
l'occasion de le faire à nouveau moi je
pense qu'une convention citoyenne avec
des citoyens tirés au sort pour
travailler sur le sujet de la
Constitution c'est une très bonne idée
il a il en a parlé non il en a pas parlé
il a ouvert la porte bidis l que des
Bones idé tu veux pas te présenter V il
a juré la vie de sa race qu'il y aurait
d'autes convention citoyennes il y en a
pas eu d'autes qui servira à rien comme
d'habitude mais voilà a eu la fin de vie
non je suis méchant y a eu la fin de vie
il y a eu des trucs intéressants qui ont
été fait il y a pas eu que le climat il
y a eu la fin de vie dans la foulée donc
voilà une convention c'est parilleurs
aussi le travail constituant si on veut
que le travail constituant soit
démocratique et et c'est ce pourquoi PLA
Dominique Rousseau dans une très bonne
tribune dans Le Monde et je suis
complètement d'accord avec lui ça prend
du temps ça prend beaucoup de temps
c'est pas c'est pas un peu à la ZUP
comme ça surtout surtout dans le dans le
paysage politique dans lequel on est
avec l'État l'état du débat public donc
moi je me pose la question aussi de
savoir dans quelle mesure le référendum
est un outil qui permette de répondre à
davantage d'aspirités d'aspiration
pardon démocratique c'est la vraie
question parce parce que finalement
c'est moi je trouve que c'est un outil
qui est un peu un peu éclaté au sol en
terme de démocratie parce que tu
demandes aux gens oui non le référendum
le référendum je suis d'accord avec toi
c'est ID démocque trouve pas que ce soit
un aboutissement démocratique et et
participatif par ailleurs très très
intéressant quoi enfin mais tu pourrais
le mêler à des enfin par exemple tu
parles de convention citoyenne gens tu
peux mêler la convention citoyenne avec
un référendum derrière par exemple oui
la promesse de celle de CL oui
raisonectivement à condition est une
délibérative avant et après Ré mais on
repose dans le problème historique de
cette constitution de la 5 République
c'est que ça dépend de la bonne volonté
du gouvernant c'estàd qu'effectivement
tu peux avoir un référendum qui est le
fruit d'une réflexion collective et
cetera et qui et qui qui est plutôt un
bon référendum d'un point de vue
démocrate que je partage avec toi ou tu
peux faire un référendum césariste à la
de Gaulle en disant ve voter oui ça veut
dire me valider ou pas mais la démarche
celle que décrit là Antoine elle c'est
elle est on en avait parlé il y a un an
juste après la réforme des retraite euh
où j'avais dit que la seule manière de
s'en sortir c'était justement de dire
bah convention citoyenne faites vos
travaux vos propositions on les soumet à
référendum moi je moi je m'emmèle pas je
vous promets de soumettre ça à
référendum et au moins on avance et là
le problème c'est que on tourne en rond
on tourne en rond je fais un gros big up
à démocratie ouverte cette ONG
incroyable que j'aime de tout mon cœur
qui appelle à cette convention citoyenne
depuis longtemps et donc il rencontre le
ministère du renouveau démocratique qui
est le ministère du renouveau
démocratique Olivier verrant Olivier
verrand personne
sa mais moi je terriement gant onance ah
si y a Olivier qui me dit qu'il aurait
on va peut-être innover il y a l'app
aintenantliation AG on faire des
préférendum mais bon finalement on
revient toujours au même au même
recettes et au même poure vous avez vu
la
vidéo le micro trottoir incroyable oui
j'ai vu le micro trottoir
de mais c'est pas le sujet si si ah bah
si non pourquoi pas bien sûr que si
c'est le sujet tuas un ministre qui
débarque avec un micro comme ça en leur
demandant coucou vous aimez bien la
démocratie le mec il est ministre du
renouveau
démocratique les méthodes sont
intéressantes tu vois bien sûr donc fa
par ça aussi d'accord ok c'est plus que
cétait g il la FA c'est et donc du coup
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que un
gouvernement plus démocratique c'est les
c'est les c'est les ministres qui vont
plus parler avec les gens c'est c'est
plus d'intervention c'est les réseau
soci non c'est alors moi je trouve que
pour le coup l'idée de l'application why
not à condition ouais voilà moi
aussi ouais voilà pourquoi pas ça va
coûter une beaucoup ça co voilà pour
quel résultat ça je sais pas encore une
fois moi ce que j'aimerais bien c'est
que ce gouvernement s'intéresse aux
objectifs réels qui veut mettre en place
ça c'est la bonne question mais tu vois
et qu'il définissent une stratégie et
puis parfois il y a aussi des études
d'impact parce que c'est super utile il
des gens qui font ça très bienme et j'ai
l'impression que ils s'en tap un peuine
c'est ça le problème c'est que au fond
le gouvernement ne veut pas changer la
règle du jeu si tu prends quand même le
toute l'histoire de de la macronie il y
a eu les gilets jaunes il y a eu le
covid il y a eu la réforme de retraite
et en fait tu te rends compte que
maintenant à chaque crise sectorielle
que tu as tu as la question démocratique
qui arrive derrière alors avec le RIC au
moment des gilets jaunes la crise covid
c'était pas battant les mesures prises
mais la légitimité de ceux qui les
prenaient avec le Conseil Scientifique
et la réforme des retraites on en a été
à défendre le Conseil constitutionnel
c'est dire là on en était bref enfin
tout ça tout ça pour dire que cette
question démocratique elle est vraiment
enfin c'est c'est l'éléphant au milieu
de la pièce et pourtant bon un petit peu
référendum d'initiative partagé et
cetera ils veulent pas aller dans ce
dans cette direction là je suis d'accord
je suis d'accord avec toi et c'est le
drame de cette 5e République c'est que
tu ne peux pas contraindre un
gouvernement et encore moins un
président de la République à avoir de
bonne volonté dans un dans une direction
dans laquelle il ne veut pas aller et
effectivement s'ils ne veulent pas
toucher à l'objet on pourra faire toutes
les émissions du monde les plus
passionnantes fondamentalement ça ça
changera pas les équilibres on restera
dans un système présidentialisé et
cetera pourtant Dieu sait que les
émissions sont passionnantes et Dieu
sait qu'elles sont bien abonnez-vous
faites des dons c'est incroyable dernier
sujet dont je voulais parler avec vous
c'est la panique sur les punaises de lit
alors on en a quand on préparait cette
émission on s'est dit ok comment est-ce
qu'on traite ça politiquement est-ce que
est-ce qu'on est face à un est-ce qu'on
est face à un sujet qui est une pure
hystérie collective autour d'un sujet
dont en fait bah les observations
montrent que il y a une augmentation on
en parlait pendant tout le before de
cette émission avec avec de youtubeus
extraordinaires on parlait du fait qu'il
y a pas de de phénomène massif qu'il y a
une augmentation mais qui est pas plus
importante que l'année dernière on parle
du phénomène des JO on a vu C news qui a
fait un parallèle avec l'immigration
alors que toutes les études montrent
qu'en fait non il y a pas de il y a pas
et Olivier marlex et Olivier marlex le
ministre chef dlri aussit lien qui lui
aussi a fait le lien alors que les
études montrent bien que Y a absolument
rien de spécifique à la à la fortune des
populations à leur niveau de vie à leur
niveau de d'hygiène et de propreté pour
reprendre les propos de de Lena tout à
l'heure donc le phénomène des punaes de
l qu'estce qu'est-ce que ce phénomène de
cette rentrée dit de notre paysage
politique et de notre débat public Malek
euh c'est très intéressant j'en parlais
avec les équipes en quand quand on
préparait l'émission moi les punesses de
lis ça a été un ça fait un an en fait
que moi j'en parle de mon côté c'était
une petite psychose j'ai vu des vidéos
j'étais persuadé dans voir partout trois
sociétés sont venus à la maison ça m'a
coûté la peau du derersh et en fait j'en
avais pas mais je suis tombé dans la
psychose mais à côté de la psychose il y
a aussi un vrai sujet de santé publique
qui est traité par des élus on peut
citer Mathilde panneau mais pas que faut
aussi distribuer des bons points quand
quand quand il faut le faire depuis des
années en face il y a zéro réponse zéro
réponse du gouvernement mais aussi zéro
réponse en réalité des autres groupes
politiques et là par opportunisme tout
le monde a décidé de placer la question
des punaises de lit comme une priorité
nationale Sylvain mayillard le président
du groupe Renaissance
nous en parle mais comme si vraiment
Renaissance bossa dessus mais depuis
depuis des années non tout ce que vous
avez fait vous nous avez parlé d'un
groupe interministériel qui allit bosser
dessus qui allait vous faire un petit
numéro vert encore et et un site
Internet et voilà et puis on a nous on a
fait tout ce qu'on tout ce qu'on avait à
faire math de Panau parlait en 2017 de
je crois 200000 ou 300000 interventions
par an on est à plus d'un million on est
à plus d'un million oua donc c'est qui a
un vrai sujet et que tout le monde a
voulu occulter et là par opportunisme
tout le monde veut y retomber l est-ce
que c'est un sujet que le gouvernement
mal l' anticiper euh alors oui déjà je
tiens à souligner que il y a à mon avis
euh une réponse politique qui est à
retardement de toute évidence parce que
la réalité euh du calvaire que peut
représenter les pununis de lit est une
réalité dans certains endroit que l'on
oublie dans notre dans notre République
et je parle plus particulièrement du
milieu carcéral parce que depuis 2013 il
y a des rapport quasi annuel qui alerte
sur la prolifération des punaises qui
est d'ailleurs euh qui est d'ailleurs
pardon qui qui est facilité par la
proximité dans les cellules et notamment
la proximité des matelas par en fait les
punaises de lit elles portent bien leur
nom puisquell se elles se logent
effectivement dans dans les matelas donc
depuis 2013 on a quand même la
contrôleuse des lieu de rétention et
cetera dans les centres de rétention
administratives aussi des problèmes tels
que ceuxa euh c'est un problème aussi
qui territorialement a émergé à
Marseille beaucoup la ville la plus
touchée par les punaises de Liss c'est
Marseille et depuis quand même des
années euh et en fait il faut attendre
en quelque sorte que ça débarque dans le
métro parisien pour que la classe
politique commence à s'exciter et il
faut qu' ait des articles des médias
étrangers pour dire ou ou ouille punis
dei en France est pas au j avec l'enjeu
des j oui c'est vrai l'enjeu des j moi
je trouve ça dramatique parce qu'en
réalité je vous conseille d'ailleurs un
excellent podcast d'arter radio je veux
pas faire de la concurrence au podcast
de malaleec l'avantage est pocast vous
pouz on écouter plein abonnez-vous à
popool aussi d'ailleurs qui s'appelle
profil et qui interview des personnes
avec des profils professionnels très
spécifiques et en l'occurrence une
psychologue qui intervient dans le
milieu carcéral qui parle de l'impact
sur la santé mentale des détenus de la
présence de punais de lit en fait et ça
c'est totalement occulté donc depuis
plus enfin depuis maintenant plus d'une
décennie on connaît le problème personne
n'intervient donc on attend finalement
que ce soit sous notre nez et que ça
dérange un peu la classe dominante en
quelque sorte pour intervenir aveou ouis
ouais encore en la
matière et moi je je je veux il y a
autre chose on parlait tout à l'heure de
la responsabilité de qui doit payer pour
les interventions les interventions ça
coûte un bras coû BR ça coûte un bras je
veux
dire auelà du fait que que ça coûte très
cher mais en plus quand tes mobbles sont
infestés il faut les jeter donc ça veut
dire remplacer de la litrie les gens
n'ont pas les moyens aussi enfin voilà
il y a aussi savoir comment on va faire
pour indemniser ces personnes qui sont
touchées de plus en plus par ce
phénomène et on aura peut-être la
réponse d'une d'un accompagnement de
gouvernement demain aura lieu la cette
fameuse ce comité interministériel qui
doit saisir de la question dernier mot
Antoine si tu le souhaites ouijet
trouvais que Vincent a dit des choses
très intéressant tout à l'heure
notamment sur son passage sur Pascal pro
non pardon c'était
le je pense que il y a plusieurs choses
le le phénomène des réseaux sociaux ça
montre bien comment médiatiquement un
problème un problème public peut être
construit parce que il y a une
augmentation constante des punaises de
lit depuis des années c'est maintenant
qu'on en enfin qu'on prend en compte ce
problème là alors qu'il existait
auparavant parce que ça a été parce que
ça ét é publié sur Twitter et que les
journalistes sont sur Twitter du coup
ils l'ont relayé et du coup c'est devenu
un problème et si c'est un problème dans
les jour enfin pour les journalistes ça
devient un problème pour les
représentants politiques ça c'est un
premier point et le second point c'est
vraiment de de mettre en avant le les
aspects d'inégalité sociales qu'il y a
derrière ce problème de punaise de lit
parce que quand ça coûte 800 € pour se
faire enlever les punaises de lit dans
dans son appartement tout le monde n'a
pas n'est pas en mesure de de le faire
donc encore une fois tu vois bien
comment les problème de santé publique
tout le monde n'est pas traité de la la
même enseigne par rapport à ça en
principe c'est au propriétaire de payer
euh la désinfection euh chers amis je
vous rappelle que cette émission backsit
est financée grâce à vos dons n'hésitez
pas à participer vous aussi à rendre
possible la réalisation de cette
émission chaque semaine par une équipe
de passionné j'en profite pour remercier
toutes les équipes qui fabriquent cette
émission chaque semaine les équipes
techniques les équipes éditoriales
maises chroniqueurs et chroniqueuses
vous pouvez nous retrouver sur KissKiss
Bank Bank vous avez la possibilité de
faire un don mensuel qui nous permet de
continuer cette émission on a des
paliers dans le financement participatif
à réussir on est déjà à 18000 € par mois
l'objectif pour pour qu'on réussisse à
péréniser cette émission c'est 33000 €
c'est 30000 € pardon par mois et le
prochain palier à 19000 € on aura une
émission en live de cuisine avec Léa ici
présente et beno amamont qui vont
cuisiner un kebab non ce n'est pas une
blague oui ça va vraiment arriver si
vous donnez à bxit et que vous
participer à son financement merci du
fond du cœur chers amis ça vous dit de
jouer à un jeu à la con ouais allez
c'est parti pour le jeu à la
[Applaudissements]
con alors le jeu à la cette semaine
comme les semaines précédentes on va
continuer avec le jeu du chapeau le jeu
du posite appelez-le comme vous voulez
on va devoir deviner chacun tous les
quatre un personnage qui nous a été
attribué on ne le connaît pas on ne
connaît que les personnages attribués
aux trois autres et on doit discuter
pour essayer de s'interroger
d'interroger les autres sur quel
personnage est-ce que j'ai euh je me
banane déjà voilà je vais vous donner
une petite feuille à chacun sur laquelle
vous avez les noms des trois autres mais
pas le vôtre Malec ça c'est pour toi
Antoine ça c'est la tienne et Léa
celle-là c'est la tienne vous avez un
petit peu le temps de la regarder vous
chez vous ça ça s'affiche à l'image vous
le voyez aussi sur l'écran je vous
demande d'ailleurs les chroniqueurs de
pas regardeer l'écran mais en principe
vous pouvez pas le voir tu peux pas
savoir comme j'ai kiffé ce jeu la
première
fois du coup on fait quoi avec les
enveloppes là avec la laffiche tu la
montres pas tu la montres pas tu la
regardes alors vous me faites très peur
parce que vous regardez dans ma
direction et ça me fait flipper donc tu
regardes tu regardes la feuille parce
que tu as nos trois personnages
hop
ok on est pas bien
euh ok d'accord bi j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a un thème cette semaine est-ce
que je suis un personnage
réel ah oui d'accord ah onain la vache
est-ce que je suis un personnage de
fiction oui d'accord merci tuas un
personnage de fiction est-ce que je suis
un personnage de de film d'animation non
est-ce que je suis un personnage de
alors du coup je pose plus de question
vu qu'il y a eu un nom
euh est-ce que je suis un personnage
politique tu aurais pu mais non non non
je rigole je rigole rigle tu un certain
point de vue mais non non non non
clairement non on en rediscutera mais
euh est-ce que je suis un homme euh oui
non bah masculin bah
non je regarde c'est pas un homme tu
aurais pu être journaliste sur ces news
mais non non finalement
non voilà non c'est pas un homme non non
tu es pas un homig
euh est-ce que je suis un être humain
non ok d'accord suis-jeun tre ah pardon
si si toi oui pardon ok ça y est je
confonds les OK et moi suis un être
humain non non non mais vraiment pas
non pas exactement attends attattends
mais oui non mais vas-y c'est le bordel
de façon exprè r non il y a pas de
règles commence pas essayer de faire des
scores règ la règle c'est le bordel là
je me fais carotte depuis tout à l'heure
j'ai pas pu poser une question donc on
remet les bases pose tes questions pose
une question ta réponse c'est non ça
pose ça passe au prochain
ok voilà euh d' d'ù dans vous
applaudissez ça tou été le bordel vas-y
suis-je un personnage de fiction oui
donc là j'ai le droit de continuer tu
vois oui vraiment ou suis-je
euh un être humain non ben non non
euh est-ce que mon personnage est un
animal h non non ok est-ce que le mien
est un
animal ah d'accord vous m'aidez
tellement pas non non
non est-ce que je suis un personnage de
fiction
oui oui quelqu'un dans le public a un
stylo à me balancer si quelqu'un a ça
dans sa poche non mais toi tu tu veux
pas prendre des revi cour dans la
tête j'aià oublé qui était qui donc
pareilors personnage de
fiction est-ce que je suis un personnage
récent non non non tu as tu as des anné
danste
non non tuas tu as des heures de vol
ouais des heures de vol ouais est-ce que
donc je suis un personnage de fiction on
a dit oui ok on a dit à moitié on a pas
dit oui à moitié bah si quand même
si dans un film non dans un DESS ok pas
du tout ah ou j'ai oublié les règles
désolé j'ai un animal non non [__]
euh ok je sais pas ce que je suis hein
est-ce que je symbolise quelque chose
euh quoi est-ce que est-ce que je suisis
une mascotte non non non pas comme
ça Antoine et toi
euh je je je dis que ce potentiellement
ce jeu peut être super long en fait il
peut être très très long il y a un
risque là on va pas se mentir hein on
est sur ça 2h du matin euh le est-ce que
je suis un personnage de dessin animé
oui enfin non ouais bah non du coup euh
c'est pas un dessin animé euh si si si
si il y a eu il y a il y a eu il y a eu
adaptation euh on est on est en tard
donc en fait à mon avis il va falloir
donner des indices là on est sur le
moment où il faut donner des indices euh
Malec ton indice c'est que tu ne
trouveras
pas merci Antoine euh euh tu es une
mascotte Malec Malec tu es une mascotte
je suis une mascotte ouais
euh la tu es une mascotte aussi ah je es
une ouais ouais je suis une mascotte
d'une
marque ok bah un peu quand même ah ouais
bah c'est une marque oui oui d'un
certain point de vue mais c'est une
marque ponctuelle c'est une marque
comment ponctuelle ponctuelle ok d'une
compétition sportive tout à fait Fox non
ah merde ah j'ai j'ai j'ai tenté j'ai
tenté tu vas être
déçu moins moins mémorable encore que
euh Antoine tu es un tu es
un personnage de un personnage de BD hm
hm hm hm français non et tu aimes pas
trop les
voitures on se rapproche d'une vanne
ouais oh là là c'est compliqué cette
affaire euh et moi un
indice toi mec euh on t'a vu aussi
nooche on peut dire ça ouais ouais ouais
c'est bien comme on en donne pas trop ça
ça l' re vachement ouais est-ce que je
suis
Astérix alors pas exactement dans une
saga voilà moi je suis une mascotte
sportive non non non non non non tu es
pas une mascotte sportive tu es une
mascotte commerciale commerciale et
tu non bah si si il faut des indice j'en
ai pas eu tuas tu as plein de
copains le pire indice je suis M&M
oui d' d'où ça tu es sorti d'un coup
comme ça c'est trop bien bah je sais pas
je les imaginez tous ensemble mais pas
n'importe quel M&M c'était le M&M violet
violet ah ouais trop stylé avec les
grands cils là ah yes Salz je suis le
M&M's W euh oui exactement oui c'est ça
c'est le M&M qui a été dénoncé sur FO
news la dernière fois j'étais quand même
David Douillet donc vra
vill donc je toi tu étais Laillé ouais
c'est vrai
euh cinéma saga euh je suis groot non
non mascot mec plus est-ce que je suis
une est-ce que je suis dans la saga
d'ici non de galérer là est-ce que je
suis dans une saga Marvel non ok très
bien non mais au MO comment il galère
ouais c'est je fais une story là
euh je suis une mascotteis une mascotte
d'événement sportif pour une fois que je
gagne avant puré mais merde frérot
euh des j oui ou mais j'ai plus j'ai pas
le nom de la masc déécrit là euh c'est
un truc de c'est comme une flamme non
pas du toutent pas non non pur j'ai déjà
oublié cette mascot non non ah bah
pourtant ah sais qu'elle est bien moche
que c'est bien de la merde euh ah là
c'est un
indice c'est voilà ah merde certaines
femmes dirent que ça pas étonnant que
les hommes la trouvent pas ouais ah
j'aurais pas dit que c'était de la merde
perso mais bon ça peut se révéler fort
utile dans question non mais c'était pas
le nom de la de la mascot absolument pas
non
c'est c'est vrai ce n'était pas du tout
merut d'avoir son nom Mo j'avais pas le
nom attends attends si j'ai le nom
attends attends
attends si je
l'aiangen a même expliqué sur
franceçends je filme parce que là
vraiment question de Sal je m'en
souviens beaucoup trop précis j'ai le
nom
ah ça race je l'ai
plus sinon la référence tu as la
référence la r ça semembboliss quoi une
pe une petite vUle très
mignonnez on peut l'applaudir oui c'est
ça mais est-ce qu'on a le nom oui la
frige frige ah ouais c'était bien de la
merde on ou la merde non mais c'est de
la merde du début jus la fin cette
mascotte donc ouais ouais exactement
Antoine il n reste plus que toi et moi
toi tu es un personnage communiste je te
le dis tout de suite oh là là ah bon
ouais ah ouais j'avais pas pigé en même
temps un personnage de B des communistes
qui aiment pas les voitures tu veux que
je fasse avec ça
moi et non Fabien Rousel n'est toujours
pas
communiste pard toi tu es sénateur et
toujours pas un camarade ouais tu es
sénateur genre ah
ah mais tu te tu tu te rapproches tu tu
es dans le tu es dans le bon je suis pas
de M Amidala non mais je vais vous faire
tout le tout
le je suis
Palpatine merci merci pour les ouais
merci merci merci toi du coup ouais on
peut juste dire que je pas trouvé non tu
es non non non non tu vas trouvé mon
vieux tu es un animal tu es la mascotte
d'un journal communiste qui a créé une
BD tu es Pif le chien bravo
Antoine euh méga galère méga galère les
personnages de fiction je le dis dans ce
jeu voilà on va rester sur les
personnalités politiques ouais je pense
ouais parce que si on n pas des turbos
indices franchement c'est vraiment
impossible merci beaucoup les amis on va
marquer une pause et après la pause on
se retrouve avec notre invité politique
de la semman il s'agira du président du
groupe socialiste à l'Assemblée
nationale Boris valallot à tout à
[Applaudissements]
l'heure bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue sur ma bonsoir bonsoir le
public très content de vous retrouver
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur twitch bonsoir le chat vous
êtes avec nous bonjour bonsoir si vous
nous écoutez en podcast et bonjour à
vous si vous nous regardez en replay sur
Youtube très heureux de vous retrouver
chers amis dans cette magnifique
émission back seat on va dans cette
deuxième partie de l'émission recevoir
notre invité politique le député des
Landes président du groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée nationale Boris vot mais
avant la chronique que tout le monde
attend c'est parti pour la vie
[Applaudissements]
d'adè salut adelle bonsoir public de feu
VO tu as vu ça ils sont incroyables
comment tu vas bah ça va ça va mais
l'heure est grave ah ouais mes chers
compatriotes la régie est presque avec
nous c'est pas grave peut-être on
l'oublie sinon mais voilà ouais mais non
on peut le lancer quand même maintenant
qu'on l'a il chante en Ré en régie j'ai
entendu que ça a gueulé en régie mais
ouais on arrê mais c'est pas grave nous
sommes guerre en guerre sanitaire certes
mais l'ennemi est là invisible
insaisissable mais qui progresse comme
quoi les mots de Manu 2020 c'est
recyclable à l'infini en tout cas pour
parler du sujet de de du moment la
punaise Mania c'est le sujet numéro 1
dans tous les médias depuis le patient
zéro Pascal pro la punaise Mania a
touché toute la France et y compris nos
politiques mathil Panau président du
groupe LFI à l'Assemblée nationale a
d'ailleurs interrogé la première
ministre et on va voir les images ces
petits insectes répent désespoir dans
notre pays faut-il attendre que matigon
soit infesté pour qu'enfin vous
réagissiez oh c'est beau ouais ouais
alors il y a des petits effets qui sont
pas de nous hein parce que évidemment au
QAG ça ressemblait pas à ça mais là ils
ont mis non mais ça c'est sur le Twitter
de Mathilde Panau ah ouais ouais il y a
la musique dramatique les couleurs AFAD
par le triste la bébette aussi ouais
ouais ils l'ont rajouté c'est eu qui ont
rajouté non non c'est pas du tout nous
c'est pas PF qui a fait ça d'accord ok
il ah oui c'est une totale mise en scène
Mathilde panneau quoi c'est avec la
musique je te dis le filtre triston et
tout c'est incroyable et on comprend que
Mathilde elle veuille faire une
opération de com parce que ce sont c'est
quand même son sujet depuis 2017 elle en
parle depuis très longtemps des plaises
de lit et donc dans cette séquence
médiatique c'est son moment c'est enfin
voilà elle a le droit de mettre un petit
filtre on l' ou ou non c'est ok c'est OK
un petit filtre et une petite fiole ah
non c'est quand même pas des vrais non
c'est du safran parce que je suis
trop on pas le
budget le safran c'est ultra cher donc
je prends quand même extrêmement je suis
très attentif mais voilà mais non mais
parce que la confiance qu'il faut pour
te balader avec une fiole remplie d'une
plie d'Égypte moi je l'ai pas hein
vraiment Mathilde elle est très forte
mais peut-être que sinon elle était en
mode tu sais un peu terroriste
subliminal tu sais je te préviens
Elisabeth encore un 493 et je vous fume
tous et normalement dans les effets
spéciaux je l'aurais jeté mais là je je
peux
pas mais la question maintenant c'est
est-ce que Mathilde elle va faire ça à
chaque sujet qu'elle traite tu vois
parce que ça va être compliqué
d'apporter en séance un bout de
l'autoroute 69 gen cette glissière de
sécurité c'est un fléo pour les
peupliers occitant enfin je sais pas tu
vois je m'interroge m'interroge après
petit moment histoire la communication
fio a déjà été utilisé par dans le passé
par ce monsieur qui brandit cet
échantillon qui qui n'est pas une
analyse d'urine mais de l'antthrax et
c'est une bactérie donc hautement létale
c'est Colin Powell qui était le
secrétaire d'État américain en 2003 et
il présentait Nations Unies les armes de
destruction massive iraakienne pour
justifier la guerre en Irak voilà je
sais pas si Mathilde à la ref mais il a
reconnu quelques années plus tard Coline
que ces preuves étaient totalement
fausses moi ça m'interpelle est-ce que
c'est vraiment une bonne idée de tu vois
pour renforcer ton message de t'inspirer
d'un des plus gros Mythos politiques du
siècle je je sais pas tu vois enfin
c'est comme si tu postulais pour bosser
dans une banque et tu donnes comme
référence Jérôme kviel oui non en terme
de crédibilité je sais pas interroge
alors qu'est-ce qu'une punaise de lit on
va on va entrer dans le cœur du sujet
j'ai bien écouté le bfor et si j'ai
compris ce sont des parasites Malou
femmelles qui peuvent disparaître
pendant des années et revenir en pleine
forme ils sont pas dangereux mais
qu'est-ce qui casse les
couilles une fois que c'est là ça
s'incruste tu arrives pas à t'en
débarrasser merci
Léa tu as l'impression de le voir
partout désolé non la régie c'est pas la
bonne
illustration et c'est vrai que la
description pourê un peu la
confusion subtilement faire
marquer mais là je parle du nuisible qui
vient la nuit quand tu es dans ton lit
et qui se jette sur toi pendant que tu
strolles scroll pardon des vidéos au
calme
ouais on l' tous vu celuià il est corias
hein on n pas eu le son mais vraiment
c'est l'enfer on arrive vraiment pas à
s'en débarrasser c'est vrai c'est vrai
on est sur le fil du Razor mais là mais
vraiment je parlais vraiment des
insectes dont on va parler tu vois je
sais pas encore de semaines pas des
personnalités hasbin qui sauteent sur
chaque occasion pour revenir sur le
devant de la scène ah oui on remercie la
régie pour ce montage incroyable
extraordinaire voilà alors il faut
savoir que j'ai découvert que la punaise
Mania pouvait également créer d'autres
symptômes hyper chelous comme dire de la
merde c'est que la ville qui est le plus
touchée c'est Paris qui est à la tête de
la ville c'est Madame Idalgo qui est
dans la majorité qui est avec madamealo
qui soutient et au sein de l'anupes mais
que font les mairies de l'ANUP comp fait
aujourd'hui ce sont majoritairement
cilles après il y a un autre enjeu qui
est
euh ils ont des gros cherloc hein chez
les
députés démonstration imparable de
Thomas ménag donc député Ren vous avez
noté sa conclusion non aujourd'hui ce
sont des villes majoritairement qui et
après il est passé à un autre sujet oui
et les journalistes étent en mode ouioui
finir sa phrase ça s'appelle la
technique du complotiste tu vois je n'ai
rien dit mais je l'ai dit quand même
c'était c'est intéressant moi je trouve
quand même qu'il est pas allé assez loin
notre ami parce que si on reprend son
raisonnement c'est bien Mathilde Panau
qui a des fioles remplies de punaises et
qui a déjà pris le train ma panneau et
où a-t-on déjà retrouvé des punaises
aussi dans les trains donc c'est très
probable que voilà tu dénonces tu
déonces
laiss voilà mais soyez attentif voilà
quand vous quand vous les écoutez
communiquer allez changement de sujet et
de continent parce que si Mathilde
panneau de Coline Powell peut-être que
d'autres hommes politiques s'inspirent
aussi de leurs collègues américains on
sait pas allez je vous explique et je
vous montre voilà c'était il y a une
semaine cet homme c'est Anthony blinken
actuel secrétaire d'État américain qui
organis un événement officiel au
ministère d'accord et il s'est laisséer
une petite impro guitare je vous laisse
profiter un petit peu quand même de sa
conclusion quand même ce qui touche un
peu sur ah ouais ouais il il est à
l'aise ça a l'air chiant comme concert
par contre mais ouais c'est mieux que
les vidéos de Carl
olive
mais je pense que ça a inspiré quelqu'un
d'autre par que je pense c'est ma
théorie que ce qui s'est passé c'est que
Macron a vu ses images et s'est dit faut
ramener le Cool à la maison allez Manu
allez et il s'est donc lancé à la
première occasion un dîner fashion week
all liser cette
[Musique]
semaine ça vient de là cette vidéo
[__] ouisîn Fashion Week il a géchant
d'
brillant non mais surtout regardez John
Bti le musicien américain il est prêt à
stopper à tout instant tu sens que là il
avait envie de
s'arrêteru Solo tout
seul c'est donc là il a pris la décision
et il a conclu il a conclu de lui-même
ok merci au revoir le coui et arrête de
me toucher le Do oua
évidemment et je trouve que c'est pas
mal parce que bobo où les choses vont
pas forcément mieux en France
augmentation de la précarité l'inflation
prix de l'essence Manu il a fait mieux
que le ministre américain parce que lui
il a fait un concert gratuit et une
annonce de programme monsieur le
Président qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour la vie chè la
bohème monsieur le Président 27 degr en
octobre c'est pas un peu inquiétant il
me semble que la misère serait moins
pénible au soleil on est bien bien
accompagné j'ai pas le le talent
d'Emmanuel mais plus et pour finir ce
soir vous recevez un homme qui fait de
la politique sur twitch un rival de gens
je vous l'avais présenté en ou confrère
je l'avais présenté en avril dernier
juste pour vous rafraîchir la mémoire
bonjour à tous et
[Rires]
bienvenue on sait pas si c'est Jam ou
Davina ou Augustin mais ce qui est
mignon c'est que on peut toujours
compter sur le chat
quoius 19h ce soir
avec je pense qu'il était bon de
rafraîchir la mémoire de tout le
mondeette intervie toujours le chat
j'aimerais savoir c'est jaou Michel
pas alors j'ai appris aussià côté de son
métier de streamer il avait un petit
hobby président du groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée nationale peut-être que vous
pourrez l'interroger un peu pour sair en
quoi ça consiste moi ça ça m'intéresse
et on lui demandera merci
beaucoup enchaîne et je vous propose
qu'on invite qu'on appelle à venir nous
rejoindre sur le plateau notre invité
politique cette semaine il est député
des Landes il est président du groupe
socialiste à l'Assemblée nationale il a
été secrétaire général adjoint de
l'Élysée Boris
[Applaudissements]
Valot bonsoir Boris Valot bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur le
plateau de Baxi cher confrère ouais bah
oui je twitch comment ça se passe sur
twitch alors ça fait quoi un an
maintenant ça fait non ça fait quelques
mois
ça on débute dans dans le métier nous on
est on a une une PME mais mais ça vous
plaît j'ai l'impression c'est ouais
ouais on s'amise bien franchement ave
avec Philippe brin là on on se marre
bien Philippe brin votre collègue député
social qui parle CELI qui parle moi de
temps en temps j'ai le droit de l'ouvrir
mais comme je suis le boomer du truc il
me dit c'est bon pousse pas trop donc
Boris et Philippe c'est le nom de la
chaîne à retrouver donc de députés qui
discutent avec vous et cetera on a
beaucoup de questions à vous poser Boris
valallot mais d'abord on voulait parler
avec vous du projet de loi immigration
qui a qui arrive au Sénat en novembre à
l'Assemblée début de l'année 2024
une interview dans le monde mercredi 4
octobre donc c'était hier les Français
sont favorables à la régularisation des
étrangers par le travail ça fait
longtemps que ça a pas été une question
à gauche ça la question de
l'immigration bah c'est c'est une
question dont on n pas parler ou qui a
pas été dans l'actualité comme elle est
aujourd'hui mais elle est aussi de la
pire des manières c'est pour ça que il y
a nécessité que la gauche dise un truc
c'est qu'on peut pas laisser jeis dire
Le Pen et sooti finalement dans un tête
à-tête avec Darmanin parce que sinon
c'est bon on a compris on voit où est-ce
qu'on où est-ce qu'on nous mène donc on
a fait un gros un gros boulot au Parti
socialiste au groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée au Sénat avec les
parlementaires européens euh on a
évidemment des travaux en commun avec
d'autres députés de de l'ANUP et on a
fait des propositions et c'est vrai que
l'un des sujet c'est la régularisation
par le travail parce que il y a un
paquet de de travailleurs sans papier
qui qui qui qui bossent qui font tourner
l'économie qui parfois paye des impôts
paye des cotisations sociales mais enfin
pas un papier c'estd que tu te loges pas
que c'est la galère en fait on torganise
une vie de galère et une vie d'ailleurs
de concurrence déloyale aussi donc en
réalité la régularisation par le travail
c'est bon pour tout le monde pour tous
les travailleurs il faut sortir d'une
forme d'hypocrisie ça vous savez il se
ferme les yeux il voit pas que Ben dans
le BTP il y a beaucoup de travailleurs
sans papier que des secteurs entiers
comme la restauration qui arrivent pas à
recruter sont obligés de d'avoir recours
à de la manœuvre étrangère qu'il
n'arrivent pas à faire régulariser c'est
aussi bah des des femmes des hommes
beaucoup des femmes qui s'occupent de de
nos parents âgés et et on à quel point
là il y a un enjeu anthropologique
absolument absolument majeur donc sortir
de ce truc
euh hypocrite et en se disant bah tout
le monde nous dit ouais la valeur
travail valeur travail bah voilà il y a
des gens qui bossent qui ont envie de
qui on envie de vivre est-ce qu'il y a
est-ce qu'il y a un changement de
paradigme Ops sur cette question on se
souvient du diptique de Manuel Vals
lorsqu'il était Premier ministre qui
parlait de fermeté et d'humanité est-ce
que le PS a changé sur ces questions ou
est-ce que vous êtes toujours dans cette
ligne là la circulaire Val elle avait
réglé un certain nombre de situations
aujourd'hui elle est pas appliquée ou
alors elle est appliquée selon vous
soyez dans les dans les ardenes ou ou en
sa saintis dans les land ou je sais pas
où dans les Bouches du Ron c'est pas
comme si on éit dans la même République
c'est ça s'applique pas de la même
manière quand ça s'applique OK et on a
des préfets qui sont tétanisés parce que
voilà l'ambiance est ce qu'Al est et qui
font rien même sur les situations qui
sont assez simples qui pourrait être
régularisé sur le renouvellement d'un
titre de séjour d'abord on obtient
jamais un rendez-vous en préfecture
assez de monde ou alors faut saisir le
juge administratif pour obtenir un
rendez-vous ce qui est quand même bon
c'est un peu plus loin que d' recevez du
coup en permanence parlementaire re les
les je dire c'est les parlementaires
c'est les élus qui reçoivent les
associations la préfecture ne reçoivent
plus personne et donc le le il y a
besoin de en effet de de régler une
situation moi le sentiment que j'ai
c'est que les Français sur cette matière
comme tout autre ils veulent le respect
l' républicain sauf qu'on a un
gouvernement qui a organisé le désordre
dans la République le désordre c'est
d'abord ces drames de l'immigration il y
a 1000 raisons de rester chez soi 1000
raisons de rester avec sa famille 1000
raisons de de rester dans son pays au
milieu de de ceux que que l'on connaît
il en a que quelquesines de partir dans
des conditions vous savez à quel point
elles sont absolument terribles à quel
point c'est des cicatrices indélébile le
premier désordre c'est c'est mort en
Méditerranée c'est un cimetière à
sielouelle c'est tous ces ces gens qui
vivent on les voit dans le porte du
périf dans destente c'est ces
travailleurs qui sont dans des
situations inextricables c'est ces
enfants à la rue ces enfants enfermés
c'est ces mineurs non accompagnés qui
sont traités d'abord comme des étrangers
avant d'être traités comme des enfants
alors qu'il relèvent de l'aide social
France et ben tout ça on a besoin de
remettre dans l'ordre et je compte pas
beaucoup sur le gouvernement et encore
moins sur la droite pour cela donc 66 %
des Français 66 % des Français disent
qu'il y a trop d'étrangers en France et
ils sont 51 % chez les sympathisants du
parti socialiste comment vous réagissez
à ce chiffre bah je vais vous dire je
pense que il y a sur la question
migratoire des climatosceptiques vous
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est on a
besoin d'objectiver les choses ouais on
est trop dans l'émotionnel on est trop
dans le oui et puis beaucoup dans le
mensonge moi je pense que les Français
ont moins de problème avec la question
migratoire que tous les responsables
politiques qui leur monent donc on n'est
pas en train de dire euh il y a rien qui
bouge il y a pas de phénomène migratoire
c'est pas un sujet on dit bah oui
d'abord la France est un pays
d'immigration dans l'histoire qui a eu
des vagues successives h dont le pays
s'est enrichi et ça c'est pas toujours
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait on
essaie de nous faire croire maintenant
passer simplement avec les immigrés par
exemple italiens parce que ils étaient
catholique je vous rappelle ce qu'on a
cet épisode on a appelé les les vêpres
marseillaises où on jetait des immigrés
italiens dans le vieux port avec des
morts bon euh donc c'est un pays
d'immigration c'est un pays d'accueil
c'est un pays qui intègre euh et et euh
et donc on a besoin de dire la véritéés
on n'est pas submergé il y a pas de
tsunami migratoire mais ça augmente
c'est vrai que ça augmente ça augmente
moins en France que ailleurs h mais ce
qu'on a été fait capable de faire
pendant la guerre en Ukraine et
franchement on a tous euh été saisis par
l'attaque de la Russie contre l'Ukraine
et c'est millions de réfugiés on a
accueilli 120000 réfugiés Ukrainiens en
France en quelques mois pas énorme par
rapport à l'Allemagne par rapport bah
l'Allemagne c'est 10 fois plus ouais
c'est 10 ouais mais on l' je vais dire
pour une fois on l'a bien fait c'est
qu'on a logé les gens on leur a permis
de bosser de reprendre des études
d'apprendre la langue française de
connaître les les règles qui nous
fondent qui parmettent qu'on vive
ensemble j'ai envie de dire en fait on
on les a pas vu ils font ils sont
parties du paysage ils sont ils font
parties ils se rentrent dans cette
communauté l euh dans cette tribune dont
on parle qui a été donc cossigné par un
certain nombre d'élus de gauche mais
aussi certains élus de la majorité assz
peu euh et dont vous êtes d'ailleurs
l'un des signataires il y a une approche
très à mon sens en tout cas utilitariste
de la question migratoire et euh très
économique voire industrielle et
commercial en quelque sorte euh est-ce
que vous êtes en accord avec ça est-ce
que finalement la gauche aujourd'hui
c'est une vision purement économique
utilitariste de la question migratoire
c'est-à-dire parce que moi je vais être
très sincère avec vous j'aiété
excessivement choquée par cette tribune
pour c'est vrai mais je je vous des
choqué alors oui justement donc c'est
pour ça que j'en profite pour vous dire
parce que finalement quand j'ai lu cette
tribune moi je me suis souvenu de la
phrase qu'avait prononcé Gérald d'Anin
lorsqu'il a présenté ce projet de loi à
l'Assemblée nationale en février dernier
en disant on veut ceux qui travaillent
et pas ceux qui rapinent et la question
que je me pose c'est comment vous vous
distinguez de cette affirmation Boris
valallot d'abord je je vais vous dire on
défend la régularisation par le travail
d'abord pas pour une question
utilitariste mais parce que on en croise
tous les jours moi je vois une la dame
qui a pas de papier mais qui vient
s'occuper de la personne ée à domicile
et qui vit une vie de galère qui peut
pas se loger qui est dans la
clandestinité qui est sous la menace
permanente d'une obligation qui é le
territoire de se faire arrêter par des
gendarmes ou des policiers êtreonduit
dans un avion et revenir dans un pays
duquel elle a perdu les attach et
qu'elle a eu des des motifs de de de de
partir j'ai pensé au boulanger de
Stéphane ravacleé par exemple j'ai pensé
aux apprentis qui ont été des mineurs
non accompagnés que moi j'ai vu dans les
Landes qui me disent nous on on a
d'abord migré dans le pays d'Afrique
d'un côté parce que on voulait aller à
l'école et puis on pouvait pas y aller
donc on est allé un peu plus loin et
puis ils sont ils se sont inscrits au
lycée ils se sont inscrit au CFA ils
sont devenus apprentis je pense très
précisément à un apprenti plombier il a
passé le concours de Meilleur apprentis
de France et il a été récompensé au
niveau départemental et régional j'ai
pensé moi d'abord à des gens c'est pas
des statistiques c'est des visages c'est
des c'est des personnes qui qui ont le
droit de de vivre et je dis aussi sortir
de cette hypocrisie dire bah oui il y a
des étrangers
qui concourt et c'est pas un gros mot à
l'économie de notre
pays de ceux qui ne [__] pas donc et
alors par ailleurs il y en a d'autres on
défend également le droit d'asile le
droit d'asile c'est ce qui fait notre
honneur de République depuis la
Révolution française et vous savez
qu'elle est que le droit d'asile est
attaqué que notamment dans la loi
d'armanin il y a la proposition de
revenir sur la collégialité de la CNDA
c'est la Commission qui examine le droit
à l'asile d'un certain nombre de
personnes qui le le le demande et bien
on on réclame la collégialité on demande
aussi à ce que on on en Europe on est un
système on sort du système de Dublin
mais qu'on a un système harmonisé un
système solidaire où à la fois vous
savez que selon le pays où vous déposez
votre demande d'asile vous avez plus ou
moins de chance d'être admis dans
l'asileêre afghan vaut mieux déposer
dans un certain nombre de pays nordiques
qu'en France voilà mais ENF c'est la
même personne c'est le même pays
d'origine donc on a besoin de cette
solidarité on défend aussi le droit à
une vie privée familiale le regroupement
familial nous on n'est pas il y a les
bons et les mauvais migrants voilà et
puis il y a ceux qui relèvent de l'asile
ceux qui ont un travail et les autres on
et puis il y aura il y a alors nous on a
deux autres propositions un vous avez
peut-être lu dans le monde il y a
quelques jours les portraits de ces
femmes qui ont eu un parcours migratoire
absolument terrible c'est la torture
c'est la traite c'est l'esclavage c'est
la prostitution c'est le viol c'est la
traversée de la Méditerranée à la nage
c'est les rescapés h il relève pas du
droit d'asile il relève pas non plus du
du visa étranger malade et ben il faut
probablement inventer c'est notre
proposition un nouveau type de droit au
séjour pour des motifs humanitaires
d'accord et puis on a quelque chose
devant nous quand même et là je le dis à
tous les jeunes il y a la question du
changement climatique ça va pas être
sans conséquence la question des
réfugiés climatiques moi je crois que la
France l'Europe doit le mettre dans la
la COP 28 la COP 28 il faut parler des
objectifs de réduction des émissions de
gaz à et ser bien sûr et je pense qu'il
faut aussi maintenant aborder la
question d'un statut et puis oui il y
aura il y a des gens qui ne rentreront
pas dans ces catégories là et qui feront
l'objet là aussi de oui de de de
reconduite parce que c'est pas j'allais
dire les nations ont le droit de se
fixer de se fixer des règles mais plutôt
que d'être dans la situation on a
multiplié par 5 des obligations de
quitter le territoire qui ne sont jamais
appliqué on les cible on répond
rapidement et on ne crée pas des
situations qui sont inhumaines et est-ce
que supporte pas les Français qu
j'entends parfois il profite de systèm
social s bosse il va cotiser il va il va
participer à la solidarité nationale
voilà et si on de résoudre un certain
nombre de contradictions et d'inquiétud
et c'est un sujet qui inquiète les
Français faut il faut le prendre comme
tel et pas esquiver le truc en disant
c'est pas un problème regarde les choses
en face disclaimer je vais encore
tutoyer un ancien camarade socialisteas
le
droitour on a on en a parlé ici y a
quelques semaines on aborde beaucoup la
question migratoire en la désumanisant
alors qu'on parle de de parcours de vie
tu l'as dit et et en réalité la dernière
prise de parole du Parti socialiste sur
la question bah c'est 2015 c'est la
circulaire B c'est leonarda aussi disons
les choses ouais ben oui mais c'est la
réalité et moi j'avais plus entendu le
parti dans le C GTA le Parti socialiste
dire qu'il fallait régulariser les
travailleurs sans papier et ça fait
partie aussi des raisons pour lesquelles
pour lesquelles je me suis barré je sais
que tu appelé raison pour laquelle tu
vas revenir alors on est pas
là mais je sais que tu as appelé depuis
longtemps à au fait que le parti
s'exprime sur cette question là quand
qu' a une prise de parole une nouvelle
doctrine j'aime bien le terme là qui
employé parce que au moins c'est c'est
clair et et c'est
dit c'est ça a été quoi en réalité ce
travail là pour parce que on a on parle
que de la régularisation des traversant
papiers mais j'invite un petit peu à
lire là les travaux parce que c'est
archi intéressant tu vous enfin le le
parti acte que il y a pas de tsunami
migratoire mais qu'on accueille très mal
aujourd'hui voilà qui que l'inclusion
aujourd'hui n'existe pas parce que le
système fait que qui qui enfin que que
ça fonctionne pas aujourd'hui quelle a
été la réaction au Parti socialiste ça
m'intéresse euh et quel a été le travail
pour pour aboutir à ces proposition là
d'abord le boulot enfin c'est un boulot
qui est qui est qui qui est long d'abord
parce que il faut réussir à à saisir le
à saisir le le la question il faut se
dire aussi comment on en parle à des
Françaises et des Français qui peuvent
être inquiets qui précisément euh
peuvent penser pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux qui a un tsunami H qui a de
la submersion donc on a travaillé
d'abord avec des avec des scientifiques
avec des données académiques avec
François erand par exemple qui est
professeur au Collège de France qui
enfin moi je vous je vous recommande la
lecture de son son dernier petit bouquin
dans la République des idé ça met les
choses c'est bon hein on dépassionne le
débat parce qu'on l'objective ouais donc
ça on a on a travaillé a que avec des
juristes avec des praticiens du droit à
la fois des avocats des professeurs de
droit on a interrogé des collectivités
locales qui ont accueilli des des des
centres avec avec des réfugiés euh et et
ensuite vous souvenez qu'après le
démantellement de de la jungle de Calais
ouais il y a eu des répartitions un peu
partout dans le territoire dans les
Landes on a accueilli à la fois des
Oromo et on a accueilli des Syriens et
par exemple je me souviens une famille
syrienne qui habite dans un petit
village à côté de chez moi il y a
quelques années par qu'on est à côté
d'une base aérienne à monmarsan quand il
y avait les avions qui volaient la
petite fille elle se planquait elle
avait la trouille ouais aujourd'hui elle
est déléguée de classe et c'est une des
meilleurs élèves enfin vous voyez le
truc c'est quand même elle arrivé elle
parlait pas français c'est c'est
donc on a on a
travaillé à comprendre le phénomène on a
travaillé aussi avec des ONG on a on a
auditionné et puis comme ça tu tu
commences à te fabriquer un petit peu ta
ta ta doctrine tu te dis bon les les
Français en fait il ils ont ils ont un
désir d'ordre en fait or c'est le bordel
c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure ça
marche pas ensuite
bah je l'ai dis il y a un certain nombre
de sondages qui le disent dis bah oui
c'est vrai que quand on travaille on
peut être régularisé vous voyez tout le
débat à gauche sur la valeur travail bon
ben voilà là on passe à l'acte ils saent
est-ce qu'on doit vraiment faire de la
politique en fonction de ce que veulent
vraiment euh les sondages les Français
et cetera est-ce que finalement la
première la première des promesses ce
serait pas justement d'essayer juste de
de sortir de cette question de se dire
bon en fait les français si on leur
explique que les gens sont pas là pour
gratter leur taf pour soit profiter du
système et cetera et que quoi qu'il en
soit même si on devient disons très
ferme sur les questions migratoires les
migrations ne cessont pas puisque les
gens sont dans des
situation je direeir j'ai le sentiment
parfois vous donnez un peu à manger
alors que la réalité est bien plus
compliqué ah ben la réalité est toujours
plus compliquée que que la façon de
d'aborder juste pour solder cette
question aujourd'hui puisque Emmanuel
Macron le reprend à son terme Armin
humanité et fermeté on est ni humain ni
ferme en ce moment ouais ça marche pas
voilà donc faut faut dire les choses ce
qu'on propose c'est remettre de l'ordre
et maîre de de l'humanité c'est
considérer les gens qui sont pas des
statistiques et que par exemple il
doivent être reçu en préfecture c'est
tout bête he mais aujourd'hui vous
n'arrivez jamais à avoir un rendez-vous
en préfecture vous avez jamais une vraie
personne face à vous donc ensuite bien
sûr il y a il y a ce qu' l'on croit soit
profondément et en fait on fait une une
proposition politique qui qui est
conforme à nos valeurs à dans notre dans
notre histoire longue euh dans
l'histoire longue deilleur de la France
comme comme comme pays d'immigration
mais on peut pas ne pas se poser la
question de savoir comment notre message
politique va être reçu et donc se poser
la question de savoir comment on en
parle parce que l'important c'est que
notre message politique porte c'est que
nous arrivions à convaincre dire que il
y a pas de submersion et l'objectivé
dire par exemple sur l'immigration
légale bah c'est pas le regroupement
familial qui augmente c'est les visas
talents donc plutôt des gens formés et
les étudiants bah franchement qui
pourrait s'en désoler qui pourrait sen
désoler mais le dire l'objectiver sortir
des chiffres et ben c'est autre chose
que d'agiter d'agiter des peurs et je
crois que sur ce sujetl les Français ils
ont droit quand même à un débat à peu
près sérieux vous êtes favorable à un
référendum sur
l'immigration bah c'est dire que vous
savez tout dans la question vous parz
des sondages tout est dans la question
moi je crois qu'on est des représentants
de la nation on doit être capable
d'expliquer cela sans hystériser le
débat Antoine eu tu vous avez compris
plutôt non on avait compris tu tu le
rappelais gens il y a quand même une
certaine tension au sein de la société
sur les questions d'immigration et même
au sein de la gauche avec 51 % des des
proches du parti socialiste qui sont
enfin qui trouvent qu'il y a trop
d'immigrés en France et à côté de ça on
se rend compte que l'immigration c'est
pas du tout le thème privilégié par les
Français et qui du coup et et même
encore en plus de ça ça profite
davantage à la droite et à l'extrême
droite qui sont plus forts sur ces
questionsl est-ce que
finalement le rôle de la gauche et la le
bon positionnement de la gauche c'est
d'aller sur ces questions d'immigration
ou plutôt de parler de de des sujets qui
sont les plus prioritaires pour
l'électorat de gauche c'est-à-dire les
questions de de pouvoir d'achat
d'écologie et
cetera bah en fait j'ai j'ai pas envie
de choisir c'est comme à un moment donné
on dis vous avez fait trop de sociétal
et pas assez de social B faut faire les
deux hein c'est comme quand on a
commencé au Parti socialiste à
s'intéresser aux questions
environnementales on dit Oh là vous
allez lâcher les questions sociétales
pour les questions écologiques vous
oblerez toujours la question sociale
mais non c'est les trois mais là pareil
c'est pas parce que on va passer parler
de la question migratoire qui a un sujet
qui tarude les Français qu'on va pas
parler du pouvoir d'achat et oui vous
avez raison au sommet aujourd'hui des
préoccupations des Françaises et des
Français c'est comment ils remplissent
leur frigo voilà la fin du mois c'est
plus le 30 c'est le 15 maintenant et
puis ils ont besoin de leur bagnoles
comme dirait l'autre et l'autre c'est
pas moi he non
non euh et finalement il ils sont
obligés de payer pour aller bosser donc
on on en est là et donc il faut se
battre et euh voilà tous les combats
tous les combats qui sont guidés par la
justice doivent être les nôtres je le
disais tout à l'heure vous êtes le
président d'un groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale le groupe socialiste vous êtes
donc à la tête d'une des formations de
la nouvelle union populaire écologique
et sociale née un plus on pe rien vous
cacher ah c'est fou he je suis vachement
bien renseigné sur ce sujet
euh l'une des l'un des sujets de
dissension au sein de l'anupes c'était
la question de la stratégie à
l'Assemblée nationale on se souvient
notamment de l'épisode de la réforme des
retraites où les euh les insoumis
étaient dans une stratégie qui n'était
pas celle et qui était même dénoncée de
plus en plus fort par les communistes
les socialistes et les écologistes vous
en es tout de vos relations avec mathil
panot et les insoumis comment ça se
passe à
l'Assemblée j'allais dire il nous arrive
de de nous engueuler il nous arrive très
souvent d'être d'accord mais on bosse
tout le temps ensemble moi je vais vous
dire depuis un an j'ai fait tous les
mardi matin une réunion de l'intergroupe
c'est on est chacun représentant de nos
groupes à venir discuter dans la
dernière législature mais attendez
regardez d'où on parle dans dernire
législature on se parlait pas ouais
c'est vrai on se parlait pas et on se
baladait ensuite dans le pays les gens
disaient [__] quand est-ce que vous
allez vous parler on en a marre il qui
disaient écoutez au second tour si c'est
LE PEN Macron viendra pas voter il me
disait mais vous savez si vous êtes pas
ensemble au premier tour on viendra même
pas voter au premier tour bon donc là on
se parle on a des cultures différentes
on a des histoires différentes on
a des des des des des des points de
désaccord parfois c'est simplement des
questions de degré parfois c'est des
questions de nature mais franchement la
grande nouveauté c'est qu'on en parle
alors est-ce que c'est simple tous les
jours bah c'est pas simple tous les
jours mais l'exigence que qui est la
mienne et je crois qu'elle est partagée
par Mathilde je tiens à dire que les
punaises étaient mortes parce que quand
j'ai vu ça je dis Mathilde lâche pas
lâche pas d'accord elles étaient mortes
mais elles étaient mortes elle me l'a
montré donc c'était bon euh c'est aussi
l'exigence de de Criel Chatelin de
d'André chassigne pour le groupe
communiste c'est que nous soyons l'Union
en pratique ça veut pas dire que ça
solde tous les débats mais c'est que si
ça ne marche même plus à l'Assemblée
nationale bah ça marchera ça marchera
nulle part alors il y a une perception
il y a une question de perception
Antoine tu avais des chiffres sur la
perception par l'électorat gauche
oui en fait ce qu'on voit c'est que à
nouveau dans dans des enquêtes récentes
c'est que tu as 37 % des des Français
qui approuvent le comportement du
rassemblement national à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est le parti qui est le où
le jugement est le plus positif et à
côté de ça tous les parties qui
composent la nupass ils sont plutôt en
en que de classement autour de 23 27 %.
comment tuexpliques ça finalement et
tout le tout le monde se tuoi ce soir du
coupou ouais parce queit c'est hyper
compliqué de ce vous voyez alors qu'on
se tutoi bon comment te dire
euh bahas tu as évoqué tout à l'heure
oui bon finalement tout non mais on va
suoyer c'est absurde oui vas-y euh il y
a une heure vous voyezen d'accord ok
très bien euh non mais plus plus
sérieusement tu as évoqué la question du
désaccord stratégique il a été réel et
on l'a pas fardé on se l''est dit on l'a
exprimé euh sur la façon d'être dans
l'hémicycle on a un débat on a des
discussions et la façon de se comporter
des différents groupes n'est pas la même
et c'est vrai que le le le RN bon la
stratégie de la cravate qui est l'
l'heure exacctment la cravate le Chinon
tout ça c'est très propre mais enfin ça
ça reste quand même CCRA he dans le dans
le fond des choses oui mais dans la
perception des Français dans la
perception des Français mais ça ça c'est
ce que moi c'est une discussion que j'ai
avec des des des camarades de la France
insoumise auji on est dans un vous êtes
enfin on est vous êtes dans une bagarre
de respectabilité aux yeux des
Françaises et des Français et il faut
trouver l'équilibre entre faire rentrer
la colère dans cette hémicycle parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de Françaises et de
français qui sont en colère et on peut
pas faire comme si ça n'existait pas et
en même temps on peut dire les choses
avec fermeté et en même temps voilà ne
pas être sans doute dans l'excès bon
après chacun a sa culture sa sa méthode
je sais que c'est débattu y compris dans
les rangs de la France insoumise c'est
vrai dans toutes les familles euh on a
des discussions on s'engueule surtout à
gauche Léa par que vous me donnez vous
me donnez une transition toute toute
trouvée sur une intervention que j'ai
noté en brossant les dents je j'écoutais
une interview que vous avez donné à
France interre en 2018 où lorsqu'on vous
a interviewé sur votre avis sur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon vous avez dit il représente la
gauche radicale la gauche contestataire
qui a parfois le mérite de soutenir la
gauche de gouvernement aujourd'hui vous
êtes donc attaché à cette union comme
vous venez de nous le dire et vous êtes
aussi attaché à cette à cette à ce
formatage en quelque sorte et ce sérieux
dont vous venez de parler est-ce que
d'après vous c'est finalement et lesfi
qui s'est assagie et qui vous a permis
de vous rattacher à ce groupe politique
que que vous avez que enfin que vous
avez en amitié désormais ou est-ce que
c'est vous qui vous êtes
radicalisé en 5 ans qui a fait un Pasin
vers l'autre bah j'allais dire qu'il y a
une hybridation des
cultures c'est une excellent elle est
nulle cette la synthèse c'est la synèse
syè c'est une vraie réponse des
larc je suis sur rentraîné en la matière
non non plus sérieusement la conviction
qui est la mienne c'est qu'il faut être
réformiste et radical voilà ah ça je
radical dans un certain nombre de
tournants qu'on a accomplir et on voit
bien le le le le mur du réchauffement
climatique c'est un mur donc on va pas
passer dessus l'esquiver et cetera donc
il y a besoin de tournant radicaux dans
nos modes de production dans nos modes
de vie dans un certain nombre de
décisions politique mais c'est à
l'identique s'agissant de la question
sociale on peut pas continuer d'avoir un
un pays qui souffre et Don dont le mal
qu'il arronge c'est l'injustice et là il
y a des décisions extrêmement dures et
radical d'une certaine manière mais
Bloom était radical dire quand il fait
les congés payés la semaine de 40h quand
il y a toute cette législation du
travail il est radical et bien il faut
l'être et en même temps il faut être
réformissaire donner le mode d'emploi
par exemple moi je je me me BAGAR
beaucoup sur la question de la
rénovation thermique du bâtiment a prime
Renov alors ils sont très contents et
vous étiez ce ce matin au 85e congrès
des HLM d'ailleurs qui se réunit en ce
moment ouais je me demande si c'est pas
le 83e mais c'est possible en tout cas
j'y étais C étonnant le chiffre est le
mauvais mais c'est bien bon congrès non
mais par exemple oui la question la
question de la rénovation thermique bon
en fait ça marche pas on dépense des
milliards il y a seulement 7 % des
rénovations qui permettent des gains
substantiels énergétiqu ça marche pas
donc là radical sur le fond réformiste
sur la forme mais finalement c'est ce
que LFI fait ils sont radical dans le
programme dans une certaine mesure oui
bah si parce que il passe par il il
passe par des institutions il jouent le
jeu des institutions donc ils se sont
des réformistes hein sont pas les
révolutionnaires et donc du coup
finalement vous êtes éfistes dans l'âme
depuis le départ c'est c'est la méchante
de la
bande c'est pas la méchante de la bande
c'est une très bonne question d'une
chronqueuse Méch non mais j'en sais rien
moi j'ai pas j'ai pas la même façon de
façon d'être la même façon de faire il
il y a des bah oui mais ça compte la
forme je pense qu' on juge plus la forme
que le fond parce que c'est vrai que
quand on défend un certain nombre de
propositions ensemble on le fait pas de
de de la même manière le désaccord le
désaccord stratégique bah il trahissait
d'une certaine manière aussi ce ce ce
désaccord donc moi je dirais que
aujourd'hui je suis très
conscient des tournants qu'on a à
prendre de la radicalité dans la
transformation pour changer la vie qu'on
a qu'on a accomplir mais je veux pas
être dans le ministère de la parole même
si la parole est forte je crois qu'on a
besoin de dire au français comment on y
va voilà donc c'est vous qui vous êtes
radicalisé depuis
2018 je me suis
bonifié c'est l'âge intéressant ce que
tu dis Léa merci balec non mais en
en merci je je me suis permis de me
poser la question à moi-même et moi je
le dis sans aucun problème moi c'est
Macron qui m'a radicalisé mais c'est sûr
et je alors ça c'est possible ah mais
c'est sûr en fait c'est bon ah ouiiis
une s pas d'exlication psychanalytique
mais je viens de l'avir en fait non
c'est pas ça rien à voir avec la
franç non mais c'est non c'est vrai je
je je j'exagère à peine je il y a
quelque chose dans la pratique du
pouvoir d'Emmanuel Macron dans et et là
on revient encore à la réforme des
retraites on regarde on regarde les
choses du point de vue de Sirius vous
savez point de vue de nulle part on se
dit il y a une réforme aussi importante
qui va concerner des générations des
générations que la réforme des retraites
et on a un gouvernement qui soagit les
formes les plus expéditives du débat
parlementaire qui escamote le droit
d'amendement euh qui se fout de ce que
peuvent en penser les organisations
syndical et l'unisson qui est totalement
indifférent à 13 semaines de
mobilisation dans la rue des
mobilisations millionnaires et et qui
fait adopter ce qui a jamais eu de vote
sur sur ce texte une réforme aussi
majeure que ça bon dirait mais on on est
en Hongrie pourtant Emmanuel Macron
était dans le bureau à côté du vôtre
pendant plusieurs années vous étiez
directeur général adjoint de l'IS jamais
non j'avais is bureau vous avez été dans
je lui ai piqué son bureau après ce qui
peut se
reproduire aïe aïe aïe d'accord
vous ensemble quand même pardon vous
éties allé là ensemble non ouais il
était comment non j'ai trop envie était
meilleur que moi il est Président je
suis
député non mais c'est c'est intéressant
vous avez été dans la même maison celle
du hollandisme vous est-ce que ça dit
quelque chose du hollandisme ou est-ce
que ça dit quelque chose de vous deux
comment ça se fait que c'est lui
aujourd'hui le méchant et que vous vous
êtes le départ c'est comme ça
mais en vra est-ce que c'était comme ça
plus le départ qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui
fait que le hollandisme a créé ces deux
je sais pas le hollandisme moi je venais
de chez Arnaud mondbourg j'avais
tréveillé avec la gauche du PS pendant 6
ans et demi c'est mon imitation c'est
vrai c'est vrai vous étiez à la gauche
du PS pas hollandist avec lui ouais
travaille bien d'ailleurs euh Boris
pourra faire ça
ouais non plus plus sérieusement bah non
on avait pas on avait pas la même
culture politique pas la même façon
d'appréhender aussi aussi les choses
bon la tromperie c'est que on pouvait
penser qu'il était à la fois libéral sur
le plan économique et libéral sur le
plan sociétal en fait il est libéral et
conservateur h euh mais après c'était un
camarade de promo sympa affable non
c'est vrai non mais limite la promo vous
l'avez pas choisi mais mais le parti et
le Président vous l'avez choisi tous les
deux et alors je suis pas sûr qu'il
jamais été au Parti socialiste non il y
a une époque il se déclarait de de
gauche mais c'était au tout début quand
il venait d'arriver au ministère mais
assez rapidement il a évacué ça il a
développé pu on l' cramé
donc ça commence à devenir difficile à
défendre mais
et en même temps estile ça à défendre
parce que'est-ce que vous répondez des
électeurs de gauche qui sont très très
très très très critiqu du Parti
socialiste parce que c'est le par qui a
produit Vals
Macron a prod Boris soyez pas si méchant
que ça vous le dit quoi c'est à toi de
le dire pas
less non
mais pas très cher de C bébé d'autes
bébés plus plus beau oui c'est sûr comme
qui Boris valloou c'est pas que mais non
mais non mais il y en a plein d'autres
regardez regardez les députés qu'on a
qu'on a aujourd'hui Philippe brin un
type extraordinaire Arthur de la porte
aussi Jérôme GED Valérie Rabo Marietta
caramanli enfin on on a des gens super
Fatia qui qui fait le repas qui se bat
sur le repas 1 euro qui fait la tournée
de toutes les fac pour voir tous les
étudiants qui mangent pas leurs fin sont
r trouve qu' a un retour de hype du PS
ou pas trop il y a un retour un petit
retour de hype bien sûr c'est chic
tuêtre
socialiste non mais on en parlait rément
sur par c'est le c'est le l'arc de
rédemption d'Olivier fort on disait le
côté le côté fun alors nous on a quand
même aussi des questions à vous poser
parce que il vous aura pas il nous aura
pas échappé que lundi dernier dans un
bar à Paris il y a eu un petit pot qui a
été organisé vous foncez des sourcils la
nuupest ça s'appelle ça vous dit quelque
chose qui se sont r lundi il y a un
petit pot je pas invité alors ben non
vous étiez pas invité Olivier fort
létait il est arrivé il a été applaudi
par les militants insoumis qui étaient
présents en lui disant Olivier avec nous
Olivier avec nous sauf queolivier est
pas arrivé avec des bonnes nouvelles il
est arrivé pour dire bon les gars on va
arrêter de se mentir c'est mort là le
truc de la de la liste unique aux
élections européennes non il y aura pas
non mais c'est vous percutiez pas depuis
tout à l'heure mais oui mais c'est vrai
vous faites très bien son
plan voilà la nues on en est où est-ce
qu'elle est morte c'est la question que
j'ai posé à mes trois chroniqueurs dans
dans dans la partie d'actu de cette
émission Boris Valo la nues on en est où
est-ce que c'est dead est-ce que la
gauche est divisée aux européennes et la
vocation à le rester à l'avenir comment
vous voyez la moi moi je considère que
l'union de la gauche vous connaissez la
formule c'est un combat bon
et qui a et qui a ses S qui a ses
sousbressau qui a ses tensions euh dans
l'histoire c'est c'est toujours été
comme ça c'était comme ça sous le Front
populaire cétait comme ça euh à la fin
de du du du règne de de de giscar
jusqu'à l'élection de François de
François miteran donc il aura ces
tension là la question c'est estce que
on estcide que c'est un divorce
irrémédiable
ou est-ce que et ben il va falloir
continuer à travailler en dépis du fait
queon part séparer aux élections
européennes sur des élections
proportionnelles où on est capable de
défendre un certain nombre de socles
d'idées en commun ensuite peut-être
d'avoir un intergroupe au Parlement
européen je vous pose la question est-ce
que c'est insurmontable est-ce que la
question de laïcité les question de de
nucléaire et les questions de enfin
est-ce qu'il y a des questions
insurmontables qui font que de toute
évidence la question européenne la
question européenne je cherchais la
troisème merci bah j'en suis pas sûr
parce que regardez Bernard casneu ouais
et Jean-Luc Mélenchon étaient ensemble
au Parti socialiste et défendaiit le nom
au référendum en 2005 comme quoi comme
quoi non mais tout est possible non mais
moi je crois que tout est possible mais
ce que je dire c'est que il faut quand
même que la gauche admettre que benah il
y a tout ça il y a tout ça dans son
spectre parfois ça a été dans un seul
parti aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas mais
que ce qui nous fait face aujourd'hui
c'est ce tête à-tête entre les libéraux
et les Fachaux et que notre
responsabilité c'est d'être capable j'en
sais rien moi de trouver les 15 mesures
qui vont changer la vie des Français les
15 mesures qui vont changer
l'orientation économique parce que sinon
on va dans le mur qui vont mettre de de
la justice qui vont mettre de l'égalité
qui vont tenir la promesse qui est
théoriquement celle de la de la
République faite quotidiennement aux
françaises et aux Français est-ce qu'on
est capable de faire ça ou alors sinon
franchement on plie nos petites affaires
et puis on dit bah écoutez on vous
laisse entre les mains des autres c'est
pas mon truc question dernière question
Boris valallot vous l'avez dit vous-même
pendant longtemps ça a été dans le même
parti c'était le grand parti socialiste
qui effectivement a réuni pendant des
décennies un casneuve un Vals un
Mélenchon un Emmanuelli et cetera ça a
existé ce parti làà aujourd'hui ce n'est
plus le cas tout à l'heure j'ai fait un
un scénario fiction dans ma tête parce
qu' parce que vous vous avez remarqué
que les jeunes de la nupes eux
souhaitent l'Union quit à parfois se
friter avec les vieux qu'est-ce que vous
faites si demain les jeunes de la nuupes
se barrent des parties des partis qui
leur sont supérieurs et créer un parti
nupè des jeunes pour l'union de la
gauche avec un congrès avec des
adhésions et cetera vous adhérez à C
partie je si si si tu me quittes je par
avec toi non mais c'est ça qu'est-ce qui
non j'en sais rien je vais vous dire
j'en sais rien en tout cas je peux vous
dire que il nous aiguillonne il nous
botent les fesses parfois que j'entends
effectivement certains vieux s'en
plaindre jeassure que ça fait du bien de
temps en temps
voilà ouais et puis et puis qu' se
disent finalement parce qu'ils ont
peut-être pour un certain d'entre eux
pas 40 ans de passif il y a des gens qui
se détestent je suis même plus sûr qu'il
sachent très bien pourquoi ils se
détestent le
COP par ils sont n à l' 2000 ils ont pas
bien connu 2005 il justement je pense
qu'ils ont pas ils ont pas de passif ils
sont libres ils sont très conscients des
enjeux qui sont ceux de notre temps je
veux dire qui mieux que sans sans
alors quelle forme politique ça prendra
j'en sais rien est-ce que c'est un parti
est-ce que c'est une fédération de parti
est-ce que c'est ne serait-ce que des
lieux où on peut travailler ensemble
c'est tout ça c'est tout ça à la fois
qu'il faut qu'il faut explorer moi je
préjuge de rien simplement je sais qu'on
est face à une responsabilité historique
et que moi je suis président d'un groupe
qui est plus vieux de l'Assemblée
nationale 130 ans pas l'intention d'être
le dernier et puis par ailleurs dans de
la gauche mais ça vous surprendrez pas
j'ai quand même l'aspiration parce que
le socialisme est une idée neuve c'est
très moderne c'est c'est pop Chicou je
sais pas comment vous dit
c'est c'est ouais c'est je sais pas je
cherchais quelque chose que bien tenté
mais céit tellement regard dans la
manière de
dire c'est c'est charmé le ouais c'est
ché ouais c'est une autre ça aussi un
peuard mais c'est pas grave merci
beaucoup Boris valall d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sur le plateau de B
merci on vous laisse quitter le plateau
je crois que vous partez tout demain
matin merci beaucoup et je rappelle que
vous retrouvez vous pouvez retrouver
Boris Vallot
Boris et Philippe Brun qui ont une
chaîne twitch si vous voulez continuer
ces discussions je veux pas dire mais à
de doigt de faire une concurrence Boris
et Malek je pas si vous avez vu la
petite imitation je il y a un moment où
ça part en ça peut partir ça peut partir
bon c'est la fin de cette émission les
copains on va la débriefer on va la
débriefer ensemble vous étiez pas là sur
le bfor de l'émission mais moi j'étais
super content du bfor avec Lena et
Valentine on a parlé de science on a
parlé de vulgarisation on a parlé de
punaise de lit et on a parlé de
scienceces participativ le tout en 40
minutes c'était un des meilleurs B enfin
moi j'ai trouvé que vraiment c'était
trop cool le chat j'ai eu l'impression
que vous aviez bien kiffé aussi du coup
merci encore une fois à ces trois
intervenants de grande qualité merci à
François et Laurent qui ont organisé
tout ça dans des conditions très
difficiles ces derniers jours mais on a
réussi à vous le produire c'était cool
et puis vous êtes arrivé et là
l'émission a été encore
mieux non non non c'était c'était très
très cool ça vous a plu tout à fait par
contre on l'a laissé partir sur un flop
total là toi tu étais là c'est un
regarde ce que tu dis salut bonne soirée
le
PO
c'est mais non mais c'est tu pouis lui
laisser trois mots pour qu'il se
rattrape on a compris on a compris il a
dit chebran voilà c'est
bon ch Cham chebran mais non mais
chebran mais tu as la Reff ou pas c'est
super gênant oui mais justement non mais
vous avez pas la RF aussi vous avez la r
de ch qui le ring dans
l'histoire mais
justement François miteran président de
la République dans les années 0 est
interviewé par je ne sais plus qui qui
fait une interview jeune et qui lui
demande qui fin interview John j'ai plus
cétait sur quelle chaîne télé et C et
demande monsieur le Président êtes-vous
chebran vous savez ce que ça voulait
dire vous savez ce que ça veut dire
chebran et mitan pour essayer de faire
jeune il fait vous savez les jeunes on
rien inventé moi aussi dans mon passé on
inversait les silabes dans les mots pour
faire et juste cette réponse de mitéran
sur ouais je suis chebran elle était
tellement ringarde qu'elle disait ce
qu'il fallait dire d'où le d'où ma
confusion sur chebran ça va on fait ce
qu'on peut cette émission imitation par
contre vraiment tuas vu j'ai imité Mo
imitation fait dans mait c'est quoi
d'accord Mons m vous m'avez posé une
question je vais vous répondre alors
c'est Nicolas
SAR so c'est Hugo Bernal quiite
SAR laissez-moi quand même vous répondre
ah non tu me fais peur on l'invitera sur
le plateau de backit après ces
procès char et je vais remplir le
challenge de lire le bouquin je précise
à la comm backite c'est un un donation
goal et je tiens mes promesses j'en é té
mooins voilà on en parle avec les
équipes on va vous préparer ça du pas
l'acheter quand même ah bah il va
falloir alors il y a il y a un viewers
qui m'a proposé en DM sur Twitter de me
l'envoyer premier meilleurs vous êtes
les meilleurs les viewers d'ailleurs si
vous aussi vous voulez déclencher des
paliers comme celui-ci qui est juste
auudessus de moi là voilà voilà ici vous
pouvez faire des dons à backsite
participer au financement de cette
émission le prochain palier à 19000 €
mensuel de financement sur bacsite Léa
ici présente va avec Benoît amont faire
une émission en live de cuisine pour
cuisiner un kebab kebab végétarien un
kebab végé efftivement charge à vous du
coup de faire des dons soutenez cette
émission les amis si elle vous plaît si
vous la trouvez utile si vous trouvez
qu'elle a sa place sur twitch et sur
Internet participez au financement sur
KissKiss Bank Bank faites un don 5 10 15
€ par mois à 15 € vous faites partie du
club baxit et vous avez dans le club
baxit vous avez plein d'avantages vous
avez accès au VOD en avance en
avant-première vous avez accès à des à
des à des dévis spéciaux pour les
donateurs vous avez accès au public de
bacsit
ici tous les tous les jeudis donc
n'hésitez pas ouais elle est pop cette
émission ouais elle est pop elle est
chic voilà super les copains où est-ce
qu'on vous retrouve toi nouvel épisode
de ton de ton podcast ou pas jeudi
prochain épisode de jeudi midi le 12
octobre avec agatoprou l'épisode 1 avec
N est toujours disponible vous me
retrouvez sur Instagram sur Twitter et
on s'amuse les copains et le podcast
s'appelle autour de moi autour de moi à
retrouver l tu es en plein financement
participatif de ton m pop tout fait tout
à fait donc vous pouvez retrouver tout
le projet en fait donc popul é à la base
un podcast et ça toujours un podcast
d'ailleurs je vais diffuser le prochain
épisode qui est une rediffusion du live
qu'on a fait sur la presse et le
féminisme avec Arian lavriux eu Faustine
kopievski Nora
Amadi et Lucy Barret qui est une
chercheuse en presse sur les questions
de la presse et littérature eu ça ça va
être diffusé je pense cour en weekend
cour en semaine pro donc tenez bon ça va
venir parce que beaucoup de personnes me
le demandent celui-ci et puis bien sûr
donc pople medéia qui désormais a pour
ambition de devenir un vrai média mais
qui est déjà un vrai média reconnu
service de presse en ligne voilà et on a
envie de pouvoir développer davantage de
contenu faire du docu et cetera et
cetera donc faites comme moi soutenez
popol donc soutenez popol si vous le
souhaitez et puis quoi de neuf bah voilà
moi je me barre là pas ou oui tu pars
pendant un mois tu V où je pars aux
États-Unis de l'Amérique ah voilà
pendant un mois je vais faire l'Académie
du wisme qui a été créé dans quelle
université déjà je suis plus qui a été
créé par l'administration de Joe Biden
non c'est pas vrai c'est pas du tout
l'Académie du wakisme c'est moi qui
l'appelle comme ça c'est un programme
qui est organisé par gouvernement
américain pour développer les relations
franco-américaines franco-états-uniennes
pardonnez-moi notamment sur la question
des violences sexuelles et sexistes
d'accord donc fa parti ce progr ok
d'accord Antoine o est-ce qu'on te
retrouve sur le site de la Fondation
jeaness sur Twitter toujours pareil
ensement ben oui ben écoute n'hésitez
pas à aller sur le site Internet de la
Fondation Jean jorè et sur le twitter
d'Antoine Bristiel moi je vous je serai
demain au Zénit de Paris mais ce ne sera
pas streamer ni diffusé je participe au
concert de le copain festival organisé
par l'association copain une association
qui fait la solidarité étudiante et de
l'aide alimentaire et qui mobilise
demain plein d'artistes plein de gens
comme moi pour dire un mot sur scène et
tout donc ce sera demain soir au Zénit
de Paris et et puis on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour les QAG et pour
baxit merci c'était pop ce soir allez
c'est
super mer
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]